If you are familiar with Jabrils, you know
that he is one of the most entertaining
tech creators out there. YouTube, the company,
asked him to create a full programming course.
And we are proud to be able to release the entire
course as one video on the freeCodeCamp channel.
Yo guys, all my life, I was told programming
was hard. It's only for the nerds. It takes so
much math, your grades aren't good enough.
But having programmed now for 13 years,
I can confirm that all these assumptions
are false. And that is why when YouTube
recently approached me with the opportunity
to create an entry level programming course,
I knew this was my opportunity to try and
correct some misconceptions that I'm sure
still preventing average people like you from
diving into the amazing world of programming.
But first things first, we have to knock
it off with this high wage medic field.
So you want to learn to code. I mean, I don't
blame you for insurance computer science as the
second most valuable major to learn. Now, of
course, you could just go to your school and
learn how to program or you could just learn
how to program from a dunce like me that has no
traditional schooling background. Play. Wait, hold
on before you click off this video and sign up
for a course at your local university. Let me at
least try and win your hearts with a quick story.
She's It all started when I was about nine years
old, my friend invited me over to play this new
game that I had never heard about. Yeah, man.
It's crazy. You get to play Donkey Kong if you
want and fight against link Mario Pikachu. And
sure enough, he was talking about the original
on the Nintendo 64. And like, I had always
played video games. But there is something
about this game that from that day on had me
obsessed with video games. I remember when my
family moved from Virginia to California in 2000
the whole drive across the US I was designing my
own Smash Bros levels using a little pain
in Notepad and when Christmas came around,
I asked my mother for a Nintendo 64 with Super
Smash Brothers and I played that came for
countless hours absolutely captivated with the
concept of it all I conict internal mascots all
together battling it out in a video game in
three dimensions. How is something like this
even possible? This whole experience is what
got me interested in wanting to understand more
about how video games work, no, not to learn how
to program because I was still at that age while
still learning to read write in do basic maths.
Again, he got me interested in wanting to learn
how games work. And remember this because this
will become important later. It wasn't long after
that until I came across a little website
called newgrounds.com. A place where people
like me were making simple low budget games and
interactive movies. And I believe this truly to
be the experience that planted the seed in my head
that making video games like the ones that I love
playing was actually possible for someone like
me. So a little later in life when I came across
something called Game Maker, which advertises
itself as you can start making games today,
no code required. And after weeks of begging my
mother to buy it for me, she finally did. And man,
that was such a fun time in my life. I had
absolutely no idea what I was doing. But
just doing the best that I could create logical
statements that will make a computer do what I
want to do was enough to get me hooked. Feeling
that sensation of being truly tired for the first
time. Because I stayed up all night trying to
understand how to create an inventory system
is something I'll never forget. From that day
forward. I continue to learn as much as I could,
asking all for help who are willing to help me
learning more and more not about programming,
but about how games work. Because you see,
understanding how games work is what initially
drew me to programming in the first place. And
without even knowing it. That is what I would
always fall back on when times got rough during my
coding adventures. And so moral of the story is,
I know what it's like to have an extreme urge
to learn this stuff while being not exactly sure
where to start. So I know exactly what you're
missing and how to get you on this side of the
fence. And thankfully, I've learned how to do
all this stuff without traditional schooling,
which means you and I, we speak the same language.
Now if that story didn't went over your heart,
you probably don't have one. No, I'm just kidding.
I'm just kidding. But I'm sure that this will
this. Here's my friends are glar zargar is a
highly intelligent programmer that has no joke
programmed, literal entire star systems solo using
only a ti 80 calculator. And when I told zargar I
was gonna be making your programming course he
Would not shut up about wanting to teach it for
me. Now zargar is a quintillion times smarter
than I am. But why do you not want zoglair?
To teach this course? Well watch this zargar
What is an array? Well, you see, we need a bit
of a backstory, because traditionally memory
can only store information at a 32 bit rate,
which means recursion depth called the pull up on
Moore's Law gained traction in 1996, we not only
obtain more power and memories, okay, sorry,
you've proved my point. This audience didn't
understand any of that PhD programming slowing me
It's time to go. And next time, remember, breathe.
Oh, man. So welcome to my course. In this
series, you will leave with everything you
need to start programming. Yes, you've read the
title, right? This is not clickbait. In fact, by
the end of this course, you will write your very
first application utilizing everything that we
learned. But if you're to remember anything from
this course, please let it be this. Ask yourself,
why are you here? What has drove you to want to
learn everything you need to start programming?
Again, for me, it was to understand how games
work, Whatever your reason may be, I encourage
you to write that reason in the comment section
now. And if at any point throughout this course
or hell throughout anywhere in your programming
adventures, things get tough, I want you to return
to that comment and be reminded on the reason why
you started. Trust me, you got this, I promise,
it's a lot easier than you think. And I'm going
to do the best I can on the communication side
of things to make it even easier for you on
this course. I will see you on the next part.
Yes, it's so tight to see that you've clicked
on this video and are interested in learning
some programming principles. Well, I'll tell you
one thing, if you want to become a programmer,
you aren't going to get very far without this
thing. This is called an ID. There are many,
many, many different types of IDs, some from large
organizations that you've definitely heard of like
Visual Studio from Microsoft Xcode from Apple and
Android Studio from Google. But there are also
IDs from various other organizations as well.
Pie chart from JetBrains Eclipse from Eclipse
sublime from a couple of dudes, Adam from GitHub,
just to name a few. And as you probably guessed,
today's lesson is all about ID. Hey, what does it
mean? Duh, of course, how could I forget to cover
that Id E stands for integrated development
environment. And just as the name suggests,
it's a digital environment used to develop games,
software, hardware, just about anything with code
really, that offers integration or control over
many aspects of development from debugging,
which means adding removing or changing code that
prevents your program from running as intended
all the way to compiling, which roughly means
taking your code and turning it into something
that computers can understand. Some ID support
just a single language, for example, IDL, which
is an ID that is bundled with the language Python
when you download it, and it only supports Python,
but IDs like Xcode from Apple supports a
bunch of different languages like C, c++,
Java, Python, the list goes on. But as you see,
my point here is that there are many different
options when it comes to choosing your ID.
And honestly, it can be a bit intimidating.
But again, if you want to start
programming you need in it later,
when you get more experience under your belt, you
can use Microsoft Word to write your programs,
if you really wanted to the whole, I would not
recommend this, no matter how much experience
you get, you'll be wasting a ton of time. And
that is what it is a digital environment that
is a various central parts of programming.
Where do you want to code, some games,
software, hardware, you name it, and it is
your best friend to help ensuring your success.
It's now time to install your first ID. Are you
ready? Let's do it. And heads up. There are many
different IDs out there. But instead of walking
you through each and every ID, which would be a
very boring lecture to sit through, you're instead
going to get my bias and I'm going to show you how
to install my two favorite IDs Microsoft Visual
Studio, which should interest you if you want to
get into Windows development or want to make games
using a popular engine called unity. And we'll
also be installing Microsoft Visual Studio code,
which should interest you if you're interested in
more general programming or data science, as well
as a slew of other tasks. And yes, they both have
Microsoft Visual Studio in their name. And yes,
they are two separate IDs. Now, let's get started.
Alright, so the first thing you're going
to want to do is open up your browser.
I'm going with Google Chrome as my browser. You
can choose whatever you want this far, it's not
really important, but you want to search Visual
Studio in the search bar and then click downloads,
you'll see visual studio.microsoft.com Click
downloads and it'll take you straight to The page
that you want to be on. So as you see, we have
here a Visual Studio 2019, the Community Edition,
let's hit free download there. And then you
also have your Visual Studio code, it will
hold on one second, you'll see that it pops up
down here, lets you know that it's downloading.
And then I'm gonna go back and then I'm gonna
click Visual Studio code, free download,
this is the second ID we need. And it will pop
up down here, let you know that it's downloading.
And just wait for that to download. Alright, once
those are done downloading, you can either click
on them from here in Google Chrome, if that's what
you're using, and they will start to install it.
But if you don't have Google Chrome, then
you're going to want to find whatever your
default Downloads folder is, in most cases, it
should be downloads in Windows CE downloads. But
if not, you're going to want to find that
so that you can install the IDs. So first,
let's install Visual Studio code. I'm just gonna
double click on this. And you'll see that we get a
window here that says Welcome to the windows
studio, code wizard, setup wizard. And this part's
really easy. It's just like any other installation
you've ever done, you just hit next and you agree,
read if you want. Hit next. And then here, you
want to leave this at the default location,
which is like see, somewhere somewhere Program
Files, likely. But because I already have this
installed on my system, I'm going to install
this in a very special location, so it doesn't
mess with our presets. So yeah, just leave that
how that is hit next, and then just hit next. And
here, I would recommend that you check open with
code and on both of them. And also make sure that
add the path is checked as well. And what these
to do here is allows you for like let's say you
have some Python scripts, and instead of having
to open up first Visual Studio code, and then
hitting file and then open and searching for
it, you can just go to like, let's say one
of these are a Python script, you can just
right click on it. And then you'll have this
available here where it's open with code.
So it will just open that file directly in
Visual Studio code is very convenient. You can
also do that with directories in case you have a
a file, I'm sorry, you have a folder with a lot of
Python scripts, you can just right click somewhere
in the folder, hit open with code. Very, very
useful, I would, I would definitely recommend
checking both of these, and then just hit next.
Now I'm going to go back and remove these because
again, I don't want to mess up my presets. But
this is how your years should look with of course,
this the next destination being C C program
files, whatever, whatever. And then after that,
just click install, install, and then you can
see that it's going to install. So I'm going to
take couple seconds, I'm going to take terribly
long, and bada boom, there you have it, Visual
Studio code has officially been installed. We're
gonna hit finish and launch vinje Visual Studio
code. I'm going to bring this Oops, wrong window.
Going to bring Visual Studio code over here. This
is what it looks like. Now before we get started,
there's a couple of things that you want to do,
you do definitely want to add Python right here.
So click Install. In fact, I'm going to show you
how to do it traditionally just search Python
and then install just Python. This allows you to
use Python with Visual Studio code. And there
are a few options to do that. But this one is
straight from Microsoft. So just install
the top one that's just called Python. And
another extension that we're going to need is
called code runner, just searched code runner,
open the extensions and download the first one is
going to allow us to run our Python scripts within
Visual Studio code without having to leave the ID.
It's very nice. Alright, and there you have it,
Visual Studio code is installed. If you want to do
new file, just go to File, top new file and bada
boom. If you want to save an extension use simply
save the file anywhere, we'll just do documents,
for example, and just do like my, my file I
don't know.and.pi will get you a Python script,
hit save. And now it's recognized as a Python
script. And if you get this pop up here that tells
us that Python is installed. Visual Studio code is
often really good with letting you know like what
you need and what you well not so much don't need
but really Google with let me know what you need.
So let's hit download here is in a pop up
window window, we're going to want to download
python 3.7. And then I'm just going to hit what
run odds it's save open folder here. And I'm just
going to double click that to run it. Next all
you want to do is just hit Add Python 3.7 the path
and then just click install now. And it's
just going to install now. Give a little time
and Python should be installed. And just like that
setup was successful. So back in our Downloads
folder. I'm just going to double click that The
Visual Studio installer. And I'm not sure what
you're seeing right now, but it's asking me to
type in my password. So I'm going to do that.
Let's see, hold on. No, it's an older pin, sorry.
All right, sorry, one black there for a second.
And then we have Visual Studio
installer, just hit Continue.
And it's going to start downloading and
installing some stuff shouldn't take too long,
then you should see something like this pop up.
And they're going to give you a few options,
you can ignore most of them, maybe come back to
him later when you get a bit more experience. But
all you really need is this one on here. dotnet
desktop development, because we're looking for
is the console applications using C sharp, so just
click that one. And then you just click install,
and see install on system drives recommended.
Again, I have this already installed. So I'm going
to place this in a very special location, but
definitely placed this installed on your system
drive where it's recommended. So I'm gonna hit
OK. And you get this that pops up, thank you for
installing, take a survey now. And this will start
installing, it's probably going to take a little
while. But once it's done, you won't have much
to worry about. All right, and once it's at 100%,
give it a second. It's kind of a start
automatically, because we had that checked. And
bada boom, now you have welcome connect all
your developer services, developer services.
Just hit not now maybe later, at some point
to force you to make an account anyway. So
just for now, we'll do not now start Microsoft
Visual Studio, preparing your first time use.
And here we are. Now if you want to create
a new project, you simply just hit that hit
create a new project. And then we'll ask
you what type of projects you want to make.
We're just going to do a simple c console project
and C sharp here, and then hit next. And you can
name it, let's just name it all just leave how
it is concert project one is fine. And create
console app sorry. I don't know how to
read. Give that a second, and bada bing,
it'll start up and now you're officially in. And
that's pretty much all you have to do for C sharp.
So if you're on a program in C sharp and or
Python, it's important to understand their
syntax. But first off what is syntax? Well,
syntax in relation to programming, it's pretty
much a set of rules that must be followed in
order of operation that your code must abide by
a process that must be respected if you want your
program to run. And so today, we're gonna look at
the syntax for two different languages and see
the differences between them, because I think
it could be really helpful for you to see how they
compare and contrast. And plus, you'll pretty much
learn two languages at once. And so on the left
is language C sharp using the IE Visual Studio,
which should interest you if you don't do any
windows development or want to make games using a
popular game engine called unity. And on the right
is language Python three using the IEEE Visual
Studio code, which should interest you if you want
to get into general programming or data science.
Alright, so here I have two brand new console
projects. So the first thing we're looking at
today is how both languages go about utilizing
data types. Now data types by themselves
are useless, you have to assign a data type to a
variable. Now to get started in C sharp over on
the left, I'm just going to get rid of these two
lines because I no longer need them that comes
stock with every new project. And then we're
going to use a Boolean as our example today.
Now a Boolean is a type of data that can only be
one of two types. It's either true, or its false.
So let's initialize a Boolean in C sharp. Let's
call it do it. And then we're going to assign
true to it. So do it equals true. Now this is all
great and all do it is a Boolean that we assigned
to be true. However, C sharp will not recognize
it as a Boolean unless you cast its data type. And
in C sharp, you simply cast the data type by going
before the variable which again, a variable has to
do it before it just type whatever the data type
is. So this is bool, which is short for Boolean
bool do it equals true so your error goes away and
everything checks out. And this very syntax goes
for every variable. For example, if you want to
initialize a string variable, you have to cast it.
So I'm gonna say this is a string. I'm gonna call
str short for string, and then I'm going to sign
hello to it. For example, you have to do
this for every single variable. However,
there's a bit of a catch. So I'm just getting
rid of this line because I don't need anymore.
You only Have to initialize your variables
on their first use. So like, if I wanted to
change the duvet Boolean variable, I just have to
come down here. And I need to do it equals false,
for example, and that's because we're on this line
right here. The program knows what the data type
for the do it variable is, he knows that it's a
bool. So I don't have to do it again. In fact,
if I try and do it again, you'll see that I
get an error, this error is pretty much just
telling me that like, I can't create the same
variable twice, essentially. So just remember,
you only have to initialize on the first use. And
this convention is for every single data type. So
it's Boolean strings, that's integers as floats,
every single one. Now over in Python, things are
a lot different. So let's say we want to do the
same example always want to initialize a boolean
variable? Well, in Python, all you have to do is
just write the name of a variable and then assign
whatever value you want to it. So in this case,
we're gonna assign true to it. And there we go,
we just initialize a boolean variable. That's
right. In Python, you don't have to cast your
variables, you don't have to cast the data
type of what you want your variable to be,
like you do in C sharp. And this benefit comes
from the fact that Python is what's called an
interpreted language. And what that means is,
all you have to do is create a variable and
then assign some value to it. And depending
on what value you assign to your variable,
Python will interpret what type of data type
that variable should have. And with this syntax,
it enables a lot of flexibility with the Python
language. It's one of the reasons why so many
people love Python, because it's kind of like a
breath of fresh air, as far as computer languages
are concerned. And it's one of the reasons why
a lot of developers that are into data science
when I use Python, because as you can see, you
can save a lot of time not having to type, you
know that the data type over and over and over for
your variables. However, the flexibility doesn't
stop there. I'm going to simply print out What do
it equals, like, so save it, hit the play button,
and you'll see that do it equals true, obviously,
is what you expected. But check this out. If we
want to reassign it to be false. For example,
we just come down and say do it equals false,
save, hit the play button, and we have a false
value. But this is where it gets really cool. So
currently, as you understand it, do it is a
boolean variable. But we can do do it equals
13,037, for example. So first we assign true
and then we change the mind sign to false and
then we change the mind again, and assign it to
1337. When I hit play, no errors, it just prints
out that is 1337. The last thing we assigned it
to, which is crazy flexibility over in C sharp,
we simply cannot do that if we want to change the
do it to be a like an integer, for example, we're
simply just going to get an error saying that, you
know, you cannot convert an integer into a bool.
Once a variable has its data type, it cannot be
changed. And this is probably one of the biggest
differences between C sharp and Python at the fact
that how they go about casting their data types.
Next, I want to get into command terminations
and the differences between C sharp and Python.
First things first, what is a command? Well, for
example, this bit of code here is a command. And
what it's saying is take our dude variable and
assign a false value to it. Same with up here,
take our dude variable, assign a true value to
it, and also cast it as a Boolean. These are
examples of commands. So on a very low level, the
way a computer works is that it needs to know when
these commands begin and in so it knows what it
needs to process. And so that is where a command
termination comes into play. We need something to
be able to separate all these different commands.
And in C sharp, the command termination is a semi
colon. These semi colons right here is what you
have to add to the end of every single command
to be able to tell the computer that hey, this
command is over, you can process this before you
processed the next one. I'm grossly simplifying it
but that's how it works on the higher level. And
so with that in C sharp so long as you have a semi
colon separating your previous command for your
next one, you can place your commands anywhere you
want. For example, I can move this, this command
right here to be right after the previous command.
No errors, no issues, I can put it back on
the next line and hit Tab a bunch of times,
no issues no errors. You have a lot of flexibility
using the semi colon as a command termination
C sharp has a lot of flexibility in this regard
using the semi colon as a command termination. Now
over in Python, they differ here a lot as well.
So you might look at C sharp and see okay, semi
colon that makes sense as a command termination
with Python. What How do they do that? Well, the
answer is quite simple, actually, instead of using
semi colons, they just use a line break. So if you
want to separate two commands, you just put it on
a new line. Easy as that, in fact, to demonstrate,
we can't do what we did over here in C sharp. If
we were to put these right next to each other,
and then save it, you'll see that in the problems
tab, it says that we have invalid syntax because
you can't, it doesn't know what's going on here.
Why is there a value and a variable afternoon,
it just doesn't understand how ever Python kind
of thought of all the stops, you can simply just
add a semi colon and Wallah, it will now act as a
command termination. In fact, just to prove that,
it does what I say it does, I'm going to bring
them all on the same line to command terminations.
And then I'm going to press play and show
you that it runs it prints out 1337. So yeah,
in this regard, this makes Python really really
flexible. Because you can use semi colons if you
want to. However, you'll find that most developers
don't, because it's often a lot faster to just use
the new line command termination instead of the
semi colons. And Allow me to demonstrate that. So
I'm just going to restore both scripts to back how
they were, this is a new line. This is a new line.
This to do this. Alright, so now they're back
to their back restored. So the reason why you
can save a lot of time is because if you
look at the two different scripts, they
kind of both just use a new line termination
anyway, even if you were to look at more complex
C sharp scripts, oftentimes you'll find that over
90% of a C sharp script is going to use like a new
line as a command termination anyway. So you're
actually saving a lot of time without having to
type you know, semi colon, semi colon, semi colon,
and you'll see that it turns red in this context,
because it's letting you know that it's pretty
much useless. Like we know that you want to
terminate this command by going to new line. And
then if we were to hit backspace to turns white,
because like, okay, now it's in use, we
understand what you're trying to do here. But
please know, this is a feature that comes with the
Visual Studio Code ID. So take the information as
you want, but do know that most Python developers
will probably look at you sideways if they see any
semi colons in your in your code. So yeah, there
are a couple of syntax differences there. Next, I
want to go over how they differ in code blocking.
So first question, what is code blocking? Well,
I'm gonna come over here in C sharp and give
you a quick example. First and foremost, the
way that you indicate a block of code is to use
these braces. Anything that goes inside of these
braces is a block of code. So the general syntax,
you don't have to follow this, but most developers
will put a block of code, one line in the middle
is all the code that will be ran within that
block of code, and then a brace at the end. And
so here, we can like just move our do it equals
false into here, for example. And of course,
get rid of this one because we don't need it.
And just like that, we have a block of code in
C sharp, however, a block of code like this is
pretty useless to add because it's going to be ran
regardless. However, what blocking off code allows
you to do is you can add things like for example,
an if statement. So we can say if do it, then set
duals equals false. And this block of code will
only run if do it equals true. And I want to prove
this to you. So I'm going to come up here, and
I'm going to write console, dot write line, this
is going to print anything that we want to
the console. And I'm going to say checking.
And then I'm going to come down here and
then do it again. I'm gonna say console
dot write, or wait, what is that? console, dot
write line, there we go. Um, okay, set to false.
Right. And then at the end, we need a console
dot read key. This just makes sure that the
terminal does not close when we hit the start
button, which is up here and I'm going to press
boom, terminals off screen on, bring it up,
and there we go. You see that it goes checking,
and then it sets it to false. But you are not
convinced because we blocked out this code and
it's still ran. So I'm going to change do a T
equals false and watch what happens when I hit
the start button and bring the terminal over
here. It just says checking because, again,
do it equals false And we said if do it, which
is another way of saying if do it equals true,
then run this block of code. And at the fact that
do it equals false, this block goat has never ran.
And that's code blocking, you'll find that
code blocking is very important and very useful
for all things programming. But that's how you
do it in C sharp. Now over in Python, it's again,
a lot different, I'm going to get rid of these
two lines just to make it a lot less confusing.
And so everything under the condition and indented
will be counted as that block of code. Alright,
and I'm going to run that, and you will see that
we get checking set to false. And then we also had
an extra print down here, that our move next time,
but that also prints out false as well. And again,
you're not convinced because this block of code
is run anyway. So we're going to set this value
to be false. And then I'm also going to remove
this just so it's not confusing when it prints,
and then save, hit play and only checking. And
so that is how you do code blocking in Python.
And so as you can see, code blocking is another
syntax as C sharp and Python have a lot of
differences between. But it's very important
to know how to code walk in both languages,
because you'll be using it quite a lot for for
loops for if statements for methods, functions,
all types of stuff. And the very last thing that
I want to go over today is what's called variable
scoping. So what is variable scoping? Well, with
the introduction to code blocking, that's this
right here, a block of code. Remember, this is
a block of code as well, well, more right here,
this is a block of code. But with the introduction
to these blocks of code, now you have to worry
about the scope of your variables. So let me give
you a quick example. So let's say inside of this
block of code, here, we want to initialize a new
variable. Let's initialize just to do an integer,
we'll call it a just for an example. And then
we'll assign a zero value to it right? Well,
because we initialize this integer
variable within this block of code,
it cannot be used outside of this block of code.
And to demonstrate, I'm going to come down here,
and I'm going to do outside of the block of code,
console dot write line, oops, bright line. A,
for example. And you can see what happens is it
says that this variable does not exist. What do
you mean, it doesn't exist, so we initialize it
here? Well, again, like I said, this variable,
because we initialize it within this block
of code cannot leave this block of code.
If we wanted to leave this block of
code, we have to do it like this,
we come out here, oops, we come out here and we
initialize int a equals to say, five, for example.
And then inside of this block of code, we
just change, we just reassign it back to zero.
So because it's it's initialized within this block
of code, which is our main function, we can use it
outside of this block of code. And that is
variable scoping. In a nutshell, over in C sharp,
this syntax is no different. So if we were to come
inside this block of code and initialize an A,
assign a zero to that, and then come outside
of this block of code and try and print that a
variable, you'll see that when we save and hit
the play button, that we get an error syntax
error saying that this a the variable is not
defined. And again, if we want to get around this,
we have to change the scope of a variable. So
come out to the regular indentation, and just
do a equals five, for example. And then when we
get into this scope, we're simply just going to
reassign it, change it to zero, and then we'll
be able to print it and approve that I hit save,
and then I hit play. And there you go, checking
five. And again, just want to make sure I cover
all bases. The reason why this prints out checking
five is because we said do it equals false. And if
do it is true, then this bytecode will be ran, but
because do it as false as both code is not ran.
So it just skips this entire thing. And it just
prints out five, which is what we assigned a to.
And that's pretty much it. That is everything that
you need to notice our programming in regards to
the syntax. And so in conclusion, even though C
sharp and Python have differences in their syntax,
as you can see, the differences are small enough
to be able to remember the important stuff,
you have to cast data types in C sharp Python,
you do not in C sharp, you must use semicolons to
terminate commands. Python uses new line breaks,
and C sharp uses curly braces for co blocking
while Python uses indentation. Of course,
there are more differences in their syntax.
But these are the major differences
that often confuse the developers.
All right. All right. All right. It's that time to
code your first program. Are you ready to do this
Get set, let's go. So we're going to make a
simple MATLAB application. In the console,
because it's simple, doesn't require you to
install a million things and is something you
can actually show off to your friends and family.
Now, before we jump into this first things, first,
the code to this project is in the description.
Also, I think it's important to let you know that
this lesson is kind of acting as a placement
test. If you're just beginning to program,
you might struggle with understanding what's
going on in the code. And if that is you, well,
that's okay. Because I structure this lesson
to be just a little bit difficult to follow.
Once able to code a project like this by yourself,
then, I don't think there's much this course can
teach you at that point. But I encourage you to
watch the whole thing and follow along. Anyway.
Again, the code is in the description. So you
can just refer to that and follow along with
me. Because if you do the following, you will get
the greatest inspiration to become a programmer.
After you struggle, I encourage you to go through
the rest of my course LinkedIn description,
or just check out the lessons on the stuff that
wasn't easy to follow. I have over 20 videos teach
you how to code and those videos go in depth
about their respective topics. Then, when you
feel comfortable, come back to this lesson and see
how will you do a second or third time coding your
first project. And trust me, when you ever look
at how much you didn't understand in comparison
to the next time you try and code your first
project, you will not want to stop programming
having program for 15 years, I can tell you
that feeling pretty much summarizes programming
very well, it can become quite addicting to
chase but in addiction in the best way possible.
However, if this is your second or third or more
times coding your first project, I encourage you
to not copy the code verbatim. But maybe create
your own story or at if statements and functions
this mad labs game who knows your experimentation
could start a whole new programming trend. Lastly,
if you want to share your project with me, feel
free to tweet it to me and I'd be happy to reply
back to you. But now with all that stuff out
the way, let's get started on coding your first
program. And we're going to make his application
in two different languages because I think it can
be really helpful for you to see how they compare
and contrast. And plus, you'll pretty much learn
two languages at once. So on the left is the
language C sharp using the ID Visual Studio,
which should interest you if you want to do
windows development, or if you want to make
games using one of the most popular game engines
called unity. And on the right is the language
Python three using the ID Visual Studio code
which should interest you if you want to get into
more general programming or data science. Alright,
let's actually begin writing our Mad Libs program.
Now before I write any project or program or
prototype, what have you, I usually like to
start what I like to call a skeleton and what a
skeleton is, it's pretty much just like a step
by step process in which you can expect to have
to do in order to complete the actual project.
And because this is a smaller, simpler program, we
can simply do this by writing out a few comments.
So first, I will comment out initialize variables,
and it just stands for initialize is shorter cork
at the right then after that simply gets
input from user. So we're gonna initialize
the variables. And then we're going to ask the
user to fill out the data for those variables.
And then after that, we need to
initialize whoops, and knit story.
And then after we initialize our story,
then we simply just need to print our story.
And for parts, our program will be done.
Simple, easy and to the point. And now
let's just do that same thing in Python, do
a comment, and then a net variables and then
get oops get input from user. And then after that,
we're going to end our story. And then after that,
we need to print story. Easy as that. Next
thing I'll do real quick is just beautify our
script. I'm just going to add spaces between
all the comments, it just helps me read it
and understand the different processes that
need to take place. Perfect. Alright, moving
on. Now before we can do anything over here,
C sharp on the left, we kind of need our story
because everything depends on our story, really.
So I'm going to paste in a quote from the matrix.
I'm just gonna highlight all this real quick
and hit Tab a couple times to beautify it,
make it easier for me to read. But you are welcome
to make up your own story. You're welcome to grab
anything from the internet. Whatever you want to
use as your Mad Libs story is completely fine. I
even put the story in the description if you
want to use it as well. But there we have it.
This is the story they want to use for C sharp.
And now I'm going to do the same for Python.
just paste in that story string, same exact thing
just in a Python format. Next thing I'm going to
do is simply just print out story. And in C sharp,
you're going to want to do console dot write line.
And then ad lib story, Mad Libs story, boom, semi
colon, done. And in Python, we're going to want to
wait, I'm gonna change this to say Madlib
story just so that it's the same mother story
perfect. And in Python, it's really simple. You
simply just type prints, and then Madlib story,
boom. So next what we want to do is get input
from user. But we can't really get any input
from the user because we have no variables
to pass to the user to collect data from.
And so what our next actual step is, we have to
initialize our variable so that we can pass it
to the user. And to initialize our variables.
Well, we need to turn our Mad Libs story into
a bunch of variables. And we can do that quite
simply, if you're at all familiar with the game,
Mad Libs thing, you know, the whole fun of the
game is that you have some story or some text
or something like that. And you replace all
the verbs, the nouns, the adjectives, etc,
with words that are similar context, hopefully,
but not exactly. And it makes for like,
really funny, interesting stories. And so what
we want to do is want to scroll through our text
and essentially replace verbs, nouns, adjectives,
with variables, and the first one I'm going to do
is the matrix, I'm just going to put curly braces
around this, oh, yeah, I need to make this into
an interpolated string. I'm gonna do that for all
of these strings. And this needs to be a variable,
which is one word, the matrix boom. And so
I'm simply going to come to a new variables,
I'm going to initialize the string data type,
and put the matrix in there. And now the matrix
is a variable that we can ask the user for,
and they can change to whatever they want.
And I kind of did this ahead of time, I went
through the text and picked a lotta verbs, nouns,
adjectives that I thought would be interesting to
change. So I'm just gonna go through and do that,
for example, system is another one, I'm going to
change system to variables can add that to this
list. And I'm just going to do that for the entire
text. I'm going to skip it though, cuz it's not
that fun to watch. Alright, so I went through my
story and replaced all of the interesting verbs,
nouns, adjectives, etc, with variables so that
we can pass that to the user, and they can put
whatever words they want there. But now I want
to show you your first optimization trick.
If you look at this line here, the sentence
as businessmen, teachers, lawyers, carpenters,
these are all professions, that's what that's what
they all have in common. And at the fact that they
go back to back to back, we can do is really cool
trick. Well, we will initialize a string array,
and we'll call them profession. And then back
up to initialize equals new string array of how
many are there 1234, a four. And so now we can
do this really cool trick where we come in here,
and just make this an interpolated string.
And overload case that just for good practice,
businessmen, and Oops, sorry, that's not
what I want to do, I want to do profession,
zero, because we're gonna do a for loop, which
I'll get into in a second. I'm gonna copy this,
because I'm lazy. And I'm going to paste this
here, and increment it, and then we'll paste
this here. And then I'm going to increment
it to two. And then the final profession,
increments this to three, already start on zero,
simple into the point. And so now what we can
do is when we get input from user, since there
are four professions, they're all back to back,
we can simply just write a simple for loop and ask
the user for four different different professions,
one after another. And I'll show you how to do
that in a bit. But there's also two additives
down here that also do this with so I'm just
going to initialize a new string array, call
this additive AJ, DJ sharp additive equals new
string array of two, there's only two in there.
And so here, turn this into an interpolated
stream, is gonna be a D j, zero.
And I'm gonna copy this because I am lazy
in this is the second adjective. I'm just
going to increment. And there you have
it, we now have our two string arrays.
And final note, if you look down here, you'll see
a bunch of errors for unassigned local variables.
And that's only because we have not assigned these
variables to anything yet. I believe they're there
no at the moment, which is Your program does not
like but we will be assigning the variables when
we get the input from user. And over in Python
on the right, it's a lot of the same. First,
let's turn all of our strings into interpolated
strings. And it's just like C sharp, except
it's an F instead of $1 sign. So I'm just gonna
add an F to all the strings. Perfect. And let's
pop out this variable right here, the matrix, or
rather, let's turn this into a variable called
the matrix. And then let's initialize it up here
and do the matrix equals empty string. All right,
and then let's do system next interpolated string
system. And then system like this paste equals
empty string. And I'm gonna go through
and do this for all the interesting verbs,
adjectives and nouns in this text. Alright, so
I pulled out all the interesting words and turn
them into variables. And now I'm going to show you
how to do that optimization trick over in Python.
So again, we have these four professions, and we
want to turn that into a string array. And to do
that in Python was going to do profession equals
brackets, and therefore rooms are going to empty
string, empty string, empty string, empty
string for empty strings. And there we have
a, an array with four strings in it, that we
can pass the user and then they can change the
beer or whatever they want. And it's the same
as C sharp doesn't use interpolated string,
professions zero, I'm lazy, I'm a copy
this and paste it here, increment it,
paste it here, incremented pasted here, increment
it, oops, yeah, it is three. And then we also want
our adjective array, which is only two.
So I'm gonna do brackets, empty string,
and then another empty string to empty strings.
And then that goes here, which is a edge,
zero, I'm going to copy this because I'm lazy,
and then paste it on dependent, and then increment
that, and bada boom, now the scripts are
in the same exact state. For All right,
the final stretch, let's get that input from the
user. So first of all, there are two functions
that we need to familiarize herself with. One
we've already went over, and that is console
dot write line. This is where we're going
to use to print something to the console.
And the second one is console dot read
line. This is where we're going to use Well,
there's no input parameters. But this is going
to return to us a string that we can set our
string variables to. And this comes whatever the
user types into the console presses enter. That's
what's going to be returned with console dot
read line. So for example, we can do the matrix
equals console dot readline. Easy as that.
So let's get started. I kind of ahead of time
crafted a little interesting story that the user
can have with the terminal just to make sure I'm
not Stumbling on this part. But let's start off
with console dot write line. Let's just do like,
welcome. user, welcome user. And then we can
go down to another one, console dot write line.
And then let's say let's play,
let's play a game of Mad Libs.
And then after that, we can
get their name. So we can say,
let's do another console dot write line.
And then please share with me your name.
And then here is where the terminal is going
to stop and allow them to put in some input.
so here we can do Neo, since that's
the name of the character in the text,
equals and we can do console dot read
line. And whatever they returned here
is what the variable Neo is going to be set
as. And just in case you don't believe me,
let's actually run this program and see that
being printed on the screen. First thing we
need to do though, is with all these errors,
it won't allow us to actually run the program.
So let's just comment out this and Tired thing,
whoops, hold on a second, I need to do that and
comment this out, come with that one all the
way down the line. So this doesn't get compiled.
And then let's replace this for now with, with
Neil. So whatever name that we pass to the
terminal, it's just going to spit that right
back at us. And that's going to prove to you
that we're able to set variables this way. So
I'm gonna come up here to the top and hit start.
And my window actually goes out of frame. I'll
bring it on screen. So as we put Hello, welcome
user, let's play me mad libs, share with me your
name, and I'm going to put my name to bring this
up. Of course, it's going to exit because we
also didn't tell it to pause. So let's Um,
I think we need to cancel that wait for that,
let's do another read key concept that read key
that's gonna wait for a key press and then it's
going to exit the terminal. So run it again.
Bring it back on screen. Welcome user. Let's
play a game with Mad Libs, please share with us
your name, I'm going to put bros and their prints
right back to us the same variable that we put in,
which is lets you know that it's actually working.
So now I'm just going to revert back to its
original state. And we can do z Ctrl, z Ctrl Z
Ctrl, z Ctrl Z. So a bunch of times, and we are
back woke at semi colon, and we are back to our
original state. And if you don't have control Z,
I think on Apple, it's Apple z, I believe.
But if you don't have either those buttons,
you can come up to edit and then hit undo up here.
And that will do the same thing that I did with my
shortcut on the keyboard. Also real quick, let's
add at the very end of our process, let's add
console, console dot read key. This will make sure
that it pauses the application before quits. Okay,
so now over in Python, let's start to get input
from users. So what we want to do here is instead
of writing console dot write line, again, it's as
simple as prints. And we can do print, welcome,
user, come down to another print. Let's play a
game of Mad Libs, and then another print and say,
Please, please share with me your name. And
then we can simply do Neo equals inputs.
Well, technically, technically, we can add this
string into input, and it will be the same exact
thing. So we can do this, and it will print and
then whatever the next line is, it will get that
input. However, we do need to add a line break
here. Otherwise, it's going to, it's going to
allow you to type right after the question mark,
we want to go to a new line, just to make it a
bit more cleaner. And so now the cool thing is now
that we have our actual name set in the variable,
Neo, we can use that with our printing function.
So if we do console dot write line, for example.
Let's interpolate the string and do Hello. And
then we can do here, Neo. And then exclamation
point. And then let's say something like, are you
ready? Are you ready? And then what is something
you want to know more what running out of
space? So I'm gonna go to next line more about.
He learned how to spell more about.
And then next line, when they answer what they
want to know more about, we can put that into the
matrix. So I forgot my semicolon. So we can
do the matrix equals console dot read line.
Easy as that. And over in Python, it's pretty
much the same exact deal. We'll do print.
What is it when interpolate the string with F?
Hello. And then this will be Neil. Whoops, Neil.
And then are you ready? Are you ready? And then
actually, I'm going to break this off. Whoops,
I'm going to break this up into another print.
Actually, I want to make this an input. input.
And then this is what is something you
want to know, oops, to know more about.
And of course, we need to do the matrix variable
equals whatever they want to know more about.
So just to make sure that you're still with me,
just remember that the only thing we're currently
working on is get input from user. That's this
section right here, everything else we are not
focused on. And within this section, there are
only two functions that we're using. The first one
is called to that read line, which is just simply
printing some string to the user. And a second is
console dot read line, which will return to us
whatever that user inputted into their console,
that we can then assign a variable to it. That's
it. Nothing more complex than that. So continuing
along with our little storytelling, we can have
a lot of fun. And do console dot write line, and
then interpolated string, and do
something like, ooh, and then we can put
you want to know more about, and then the
matrix Ha. You know, just have fun with it.
And then we can do another line console,
dot write line, interpolated string.
Let's see. Next we want to do is we want
to get the variable system. And so we need
to give them a bit of a context. So we can
do something like, first, let's see first.
Okay, please bear with me. Okay, well,
first, tell me what you already already know
about the matrix. And then let's do one final
one, which gives them a bit of instruction,
because this is madlibs. After all,
we're gonna do let's see what now
would you categorize the matrix as, and then
we can add like a little semi colon here.
And then finally, finally, we can do
system equals console dot readline.
And yeah, pretty straightforward. Again, I'm just
trying to have fun with this Mad Libs as we're
getting the data, the information, the input from
the user. And so, you know, you also want to give,
you know, this is all mad libs clues right now.
But you also want to give the user like some sort
of hint as to what word they're replacing. So I
simply just asked what noun would you categorize
the matrix as, and he's just trying to have fun
with it over in Python, not much really changes,
we're just going to print out the same exact
strings. So so Oh, oh, you want to know more about
that? I mean, you put the matrix and then print
another line. And this is going to say, Okay,
well first, tell me, oops, tell me
what you already know about the matrix
to another line. We're in df and then what now?
Would you cat TIG Gore, right? Then matrix.
Actually, I forget this is Python. So we can
actually make this our input, and then do system
equals this input. And just to prove to you
that we're just trying to craft the story here,
nothing more complex than that. I'm going to
initialize all of these remaining variables
as empty strings just so that that error clears
up. Because empty string equals empty string,
equals empty string equals empty string. And
now we can actually print out this story. Even
though most of the words most of the very roles
are going to be whoops, equals empty string are
going to be empty strings. We can print this
out. My console goes over to the left. So
what is my name to Brill's? And then, as we
wrote, hello jimbros gave us her name. Are
you ready? What is something Do you want to know
more about? There's a typo there. We can fix that.
I want to know more about pizza, for example.
Oh, you want to know more about pizza? Okay.
Well, first, tell me what you already know about
pizza. What noun? Would you categorize pizza as
I categorize pizza as pie. And then that's as
far as we've gotten our code. So now it does
the Mad Libs, it replaces the variables within the
actual Madlib story. And they get we gives us this
pizza is a pie two Bros. That pie is our and then
it's all empty strings from there. But as you see,
this is this is all we're doing at the moment
is this part of the terminal script, we're just
crafting this story. That's all there is to it.
Hopefully at this point, I've convinced you that
we aren't doing anything complex. With this stage,
we're just printing out a story to the console
and asking for variables. That that's all. So
let's just finish off our story by moving on.
So next thing that I want to do here is of
course, we're gonna do console dot write line.
And we're gonna interpolate a string. And
what I want to put next is, let's see. Give me
me in opposing, opposing now,
to system, right, because the next word we're
going to get is enemy, we're going to try and
replace enemy ever again, we're just trying to
give them some sort of hint for a good noun to
replace. So that should work. So then we're
gonna do enemy equals console. dot read line.
All right, so hopefully, this string that I
printing that I'm printing to the console,
is enough to give them a hint. On a good
words, replace enemy with moving on,
we're going to do another console dot write
line. And what are we getting next? Next,
we are going to get the word inside. So
let's see. What hint Can I give for inside
I don't know relaxing. Now, let's say now give me
any relaxing. Now, in of course, this needs to be
in the present tense, present tense. And then we
can do inside equals console dot read line again.
And we just keep on going down the line, we're
not going to get caught up to speed in Python.
So last left off was system.
So we need to print let's see,
interpolate a string. Let's do what is it give
me me an opposing now to system. I always forget
this is Python so we don't have to print and
then do a read line. We can just do input.
Let's see what's the variables enemy,
right? Yeah, enemy equals input.
Cool. And then we can do the same thing
with inside equals input. And then I'm gonna
interpolate the string. And then let's do now.
Now give me any relaxing. Now, present tense.
All right, oops, no, semi colon, none Python.
Cool. And we are all caught up. Now next up is the
interesting part that we kind of set up a little
earlier in the video. Now we need to actually use
our for loop for our string arrays. And so we can
go about doing that really simply just create a
for loop for int i equals zero. i is less than
profession, dot length, semi colon i plus plus,
and then come down here sort of brackets. And
so this for loop is just going to go through
the professions which is next up in the text
prompt, and we can simply just asked. Let's
see. I guess before that though, we need to alert
the user say console dot write line and say Okay.
Now I need for professions,
professions, professions relating to
what is this relaying to system
and interpolate the string here,
boom. So we let that alert the
user what's about to happen,
I need for professional building systems. And
then here we can do console dot write line.
And we're gonna do a course interpolated
string here. And let's do profession.
If I have any typos, I apologize, profession,
plural. Because, again, we're doing businessmen,
I don't remember them originally, businessman
mckellan, something like that. But they're an
employee rural. And then we can just simply
let them know where they're at, by doing i plus
one, because is going to be zero starts at zero.
So we can do that plus one to get it started
at one. And then simply profession dot length.
Right, so what this does, let me just walk you
through this thing is a bit vague. So what this
does, simply, as we're going through our for
loop, there are four different professions,
it's going to write to the console, give me a
profession, plural, and it's going to print out
what number profession they're currently filling
out. That's all it is. And then it's divided
by the length is how many professions we need.
And I'll show you this example a bit later. But
once we do that, then after every single time, we
print that to the console, we want to read line
and assign profession of AI to that, and that will
pretty much populate our entire profession string
array. All right, and to get caught up in Python,
it's not too difficult, of course, we need
to write out our print. And we are currently
alerting the player that a for loop is about to
happen for the most part. So okay, now I need four
pro fish ones relating to system. Right. And then
we got to do our for loop. And for loops in Python
are they're a bit different. So we're gonna do
for i in range, length of profession. And then
we'll do our colon and the next line will do the
profession of AI equals inputs. And then here,
what do we put we put profession, which is
definitely a typo in the C sharp profession.
And then plural. And then here, we're going to do
i plus one, hope this is not interpolated string,
and add an F to make an interpolated
string, divided by length, oops, come on,
come on. There it is length of profession. And
there we have it. They are now currently up to
speed. Now this point, I'm pretty sure that
you could finish this program on your own
because we're just essentially gonna do the same
exact stuff we've been doing. And once you fill
out the remainder, what is it like three or four
variables, the application is done. However,
I want to take a second to pause because I often
don't go this long without leaving comments. It's
always nice to leave comments for yourself in the
future. Or if you're going to send this off to a
friend, or if you're going to upload it to GitHub
for you know, other developers is trying to take
apart and learn from it's always good and nice
leave comments. So let's do that. Just to explain
what's happening here. I'm just going to say we
are getting the matrix variable a variable from
user it's going to be a lot of those comments
getting system variable variable from user
forgetting enemy variable from User where I didn't
even add system, system variable from user sorry,
getting what is this inside variable?
variable from user. And then this is arms and
say commencing for loop. No way, commencing.
Now I'm going to say that I'm going to
say getting getting all professions.
From user. Also, I know that I have a typo
here. So I'm going to fix that profession. Yes.
Cool. I'm actually going to combine these not not.
And yeah, this really helps me out personally.
Oftentimes, when I'm reading code,
I'll often look for the green,
or like, where the comments are, whatever color
the comments are, in the language, often look for
those as like kind of like markers. So I can kind
of fill out the code and know exactly what's going
on where. So it's always good practice to leave
comments in Python and do the exact same. And
leave a comment here, getting the matrix variable.
From user. I apologize, if I have typos, I'm
not terribly concerned about that
getting getting system variable
from user, and then this is going to
be getting enemy variable from user.
And this is getting inside variable from
user. And this is getting all profession.
variable from user was going to change his
profession. I guess that doesn't really matter.
Cool, a bit redundant, but it always helps.
Alright, so I went and did you a favor and
pretty much wrote out the rest of the logic
for the rest of the variables, because
it probably got a bit too mundane if
I were to record it on the screen,
but we can walk through it anyway. So
right after the profession's for loop,
we are essentially getting the same variable. And
we do that by writing to the console, give me a
hero related verb in the present tense. Again,
this is just hints for the user. So they kind of
have an idea on what we're they're replacing. And
then we will save whatever string they returned
to us into the Save variable. And then we get
the unplugged variable, which we do that by
writing to the console. Now give me a verb that
makes you think about relief in the past tense.
Again, just another hint, you can see how mundane
it probably would have been. And then whatever
string they returned to us with counselor reline
we will save that into the unplugged variable.
And then after that we need to get our adjectives
are two of them. So we first warn the user say,
lastly, I need to dystopian adjectives. And then
we do a for loop. And simply, we will tell them
that they are currently filling out an adjective.
And we'll let them know what number they're on
out of the total number. And then we will save
that to their respective adjective variables,
whatever string they're returned to us. And then
lastly, we just need to get the fight variable.
And we just say, Hey, we need a verb on the
console. And then whatever string they returned to
us, we will save that into the fight variable. And
that's pretty much it on the Python side of things
is the exact same just in Python syntax, you know,
get the same variable, get the unplugged variable,
get the two adjectives to a for loop,
and then get the fight variable.
And we're done. Great work guys are madlibs
application is pretty much done. I mean,
there's nothing left to do. Except there's one
thing that I want to do on Python. So the input
function is a bit different than the console dot
read line, the constant read line function will
always go to a new line, the input does not. So
with that, let's kind of format this a bit. I'm
going to do with all the inputs, semi colon, and
then a space. So whatever question we asked them,
they can input that right after our
question. So I'm gonna do that again.
I'm actually going to remove the question
mark because it might get a bit confusing
with that syntax anymore. So there's some
added space there. And then input here I'll do
colon space. Here I'll do colon space.
Where else here I'll do colon space.
And this is the input space, there's
input space. Here, space input here,
space, and boom. Alright, and that's just
going to look a lot more cleaner when we're
actually playing the game in the terminal.
So all that's left is to play it and let's,
let's actually play it. I'm going to run C
sharp first. I'm going to bring this over here
and it says welcome user. Let's play a game
of madlibs. Please share with me your name.
My name is jabril Hello, jabril. Are you ready?
What is something you want to know more about?
I want to know more about pizza. Oh, you
want to know more about pizza? Ha. Okay,
well first, tell me what you already know about
pizza. What now? Would you categorize pizza as
I'd say pizza is a pie. Give me an imposing noun
to pie. Hmm, maybe cake. Now give us a relaxing
noun. Present tense. I guess sleeping is a relaxed
noun and present tense. Okay, now I need four
professions relating to pie. Ooh, I don't know.
Baker. Cook. Chef. I don't know. I don't know.
What's the last one? I'm just
gonna say butcher. I don't know.
Give me a hero. Related verb in present tense.
Here are related verb in present tense. Let's see.
Save. That's all I can think of. I know that's
the actual word, but it's all I can think of.
Now, give me a verb that
makes you think about relief.
Massage. Massage in past tense massage. Yeah.
Is that a verb? Something to do? I guess I don't
know. Lastly, I need to dystopian adjectives
describing words. I don't know birds, I guess.
And what's another one? I'm dirty. And the
verb, a verb is what you do, let's say,
um, what you do, kick. Let's see what we got
here. Pizza is a pie two rows. That pie is our
cake. But when you're sleeping, you look around.
What do you see? Baker, cook, Chef, butcher, oops,
I didn't listen to instructions socially plural,
very minds of the people we are trying to save.
But until we do, these people are still part of
that pie. And that makes them our cake very deep.
You have to understand, most of these
people are not ready to be massaged.
And many of them are so burnt, so helplessly dirty
on the pie that they will kick to protect it.
Art, absolute art. And now let's play in Python.
Real quick. Not sure how I missed this. But we
need to put input at the bottom so the console
will stay open. But it's a bit different to
actually play it with Python. Go up to here up the
top where your project file name is right click
and then do reveal an explorer. And then wherever
your fault your file is just double click it and
a terminal should pop up. It should look pretty
much the exact same, just with a slight Python
syntax difference that we did. And so please share
with me your name? My name is what am I gonna say?
My name is fajita. I'm cool this time. Hello
Vegito Are you ready? What is something you want
to know more about? I want to know more about
Um, let's see. Not pizza. Oh, no more about
Skittles. Skittles huh? Okay, well first tell me
what's your I know about skills? What now? Once
you category Skittles, as I'd say it's candy. Give
me an imposing noun to candy. Ooh, veggies. Now
give me any relaxing noun in the present tense,
relaxing noun. Person place or thing? That's
actually probably incorrect, but I understand what
it's asking. Relaxing now. I don't know. Relaxing
itself. Okay, so now I need for professionals
relating to candy. Let's see. Baker. Down Mama.
Clerk. I don't know. Supposed to be plural. I
keep forgetting associate plural clerks. Baker.
I don't what do you call it candy make
candy makers candy. Make Here's chocolate
chocalate factory owners. Let's see, give me
a hero relating verb in the present tense.
What do heroes do they save. They fight
crime. The verb Fight, fight crime.
fight crime. I don't know. Now, give me
a verb that makes you think about relief.
coding. That's what you do in past tense
coded. Lastly, I need to dystopian.
Let's do dystopian, let's do, empty, I
guess. And let's do dark and a verb, a verb.
Slide. Let's see what we got here.
Skittles is a candy fajita? That candy
is our veggies. But when you're relaxing,
you look around when you see bakers, clerks,
candy makers, chocolate factory owners, the very
minds of people, we are trying to fight crime.
But until we do, these people are still a part
of that candy. And that makes them more veggies
very deep. That is so deep. You have to
understand, most of these people are not
ready to be coded. And many of them are
so empty. So hopelessly dark on the candy
that they will slide to protect it. Wow. Wow.
So that's poetry. And there you have it, guys,
congratulations on creating your first ever
program. You did it. Congrats, everyone. Believe
it or not, you just written an actual usable
program, you can go right now and play this
with your friends and loved ones and impress them
with your new skills. But if you're still lost,
you should feel really lucky. Because this
video is part of a programming course that I
put together to teach you everything that you need
to know to start programming. And I promise by the
end of it, this application will be very easy
for you to understand even without my help. I
envy all the knowledge that you get to learn. So
maybe there's some things that you understood and
others that confused you. Well, I designed this
course that you only have to take the lessons that
you want to take no prior lessons required to make
your own curriculum. So what are you waiting for?
Now, if you want to be a good programmer, it's
very important that you get a solid understanding
on data types. So let's talk a bit about them
and get you familiar with the basics of them.
On the most fundamental level, let's say you have
some data that is stored in a variable. Well,
this data has some sort of type that's associated
with it. There are a good number of different data
types, and they all have different instructions
and rules. And this is sort of computer knows what
it can and can't do with the variable. Now there
are six main data types that are shared across
most languages. bool, which stands for Boolean
named after the 19th century mathematician George
Boole whose work popularized it char, which
stands for character string, which stands for
string of characters int, which stands for integer
float, which stands for floating point value,
and array, which isn't actually a type of
data. It's a data structure. But by definition,
it's an ordered series or an arrangement of
similar types of data. And no, there are more
data types that exists out there. But if you
want to learn more about these in particular,
I've a lesson on each and every one of them, check
the link in the description, because this lesson,
we're only briefly go over them. Now, again,
every single one of these have their own unique
set of rules and instructions. For instance,
let's take a look at the integer data type,
which are a type of data for whole numbers. Let's
say that you have an integer that equals 11.
And you want to minus one from it,
well, you'd write off this operation,
send it to the computer to perform. And guess what
your computer will take a look at this operation,
then we'll look to see if it has the instructions
for doing that operation, then we'll go Yeah,
I know how to subtract an integer from an integer,
the computer will then subtract one from 11
and then send back to you a 10. all well and good.
everything checks out. But now let's take a look
at a string data type, which again, is a string
of characters. If you were to have the string 11,
and you want to subtract the integer one from
the string 11. Well, you send this operation
to your computer, your computer would take a
look at its operation, then check to see if it
has instructions on how to do that or not, then it
would realize what you sent it makes absolutely no
sense. It has no instructions on how to subtract
integers from strings. This is no different from
telling your computer to subtract one from the
word hello. How do you do So your computer will
just send back to an error letting me know that
the operation you're trying to do makes no sense.
What specifically in this case is a type error.
Now, let's do the same operation, but instead
make both of them strings. What do you think will
happen? Well, we get attending in but as a string,
maybe we'll get another error. Well, if you again
have the string 11, and you send the operation to
your computer to subtract the string one from the
string 11, your computer will look its operation,
then again, realize it has no instructions on
how to do this, thus, returning back to you
in air. But you may find this next part quite
interesting. If you instead tell your computer
to take the string 11 and plus the string
one to it, it will look at this operation,
then check to see if it has any instructions
on how to do this or not. And then say,
Yeah, actually, I can do that for you, then it'll
send back to you a string of 111 simply because
since the string one and the string 11 are both
strings, all it has to do is add an extra one to
the 11th string, just for example. And there you
have it for data types. That is why understanding
data types is really important, you will have a
very hard time trying to write programs without
knowing the difference between a number as an int,
float, or string. Check out the lessons LinkedIn
description to learn more about each data type
individually. But in conclusion, just remember
that data types are different types of data with
different rules and instructions. And depending on
the data type of your variable, there are certain
operations that you can and can't do with it,
which will become very important to grasp
and understand as you start using them.
So let's talk about bulls bull is short for
Boolean. If you hear bull or Boolean, they mean
the same exact thing. And it was introduced by
George Boole in his book The mathematical analysis
of logic in 1847. But what is a Boolean in terms
of programming? Well, a Boolean is a data type
that can only be assigned one of two different
values, either a true value or false value. And
that's it, it honestly doesn't get any more
complex than that. And what might take you
by surprise is that bullions are the most
fundamental building block for programming,
most of your code will simply just check
if something is true or not. And complexity
is added by combining a bunch of volumes. But
we'll get into that in just a bit. But for now,
let's get into the nitty gritty on how you go
about using volumes. And we're going to do this
by using two different languages. Because I think
it can be really helpful for you to learn how they
compare and contrast. And plus, you'll pretty much
learn two languages at once. So on the left is
language C sharp using the it Visual Studio, which
should interest you if you want to do windows
development, or if you want to make games using
a popular game engine called a unity. And on the
right is the language Python three using the ID
Visual Studio code, which should interest you if
you want to get into general programming or data
science. Alright, so here I have two brand new
console projects. And if you don't how to make a
new console project in either C sharp or Python or
both, be sure to check out the video in the
description. It's called How to install an ad.
And at the end of that video, I'll show you how
to do that. Alright, so the first thing I want to
get into today is just some basic Boolean syntax.
So first thing I'm gonna do is just delete these
two lines don't need them, they come standard with
every new C sharp project. And then I'm going to
cast a boolean data type, bowl, and then I'm
gonna create a variable called pizza time them
assign it to be true. Now, the first thing that
you know about Boolean is that they only have
two states, they can either be true, or they can
be false. That is about the only flexibility that
a bullying has when it comes to assigning it.
But over in Python bullions have just a little
bit more flexibility. So I'm going to create
a new variable, and we'll call it pizza time,
of course, I'm gonna assign a true value to it.
And now it knows that this is a Boolean, but I
can also assign a false value to it. Or I can also
say, assign a one value to it, that equals true.
And lastly, I can assign a zero value to it, and
that equals false. And just to prove it to you,
I'm going to show you all the different cases.
So we'll do true here. And then to check it,
we need an if statement. So I'm gonna say if pizza
time, then we need to print pizza, or a string
pizza. Like that, I'm gonna hit the play button
and you'll see that it prints out pizza. Next,
I'm going to change the false value, and it should
print out nothing. If we hit the play button.
You see nothing was printed just as we expected.
And now I'm going to change this to be a one value
and hit the play button. You'll see that again we
get pizza pretty nice. And lastly, I'm just going
to say pizza time equals zero save it hit the play
button and you see that we get nothing printed.
So what's going on here because Clearly the pizza
time variable is an integer. And we're saying if
zero, then print pizza time. That doesn't make
any sense, right. And that's one of the benefits
to Python being an interpreted language, it
allows you to pass in integers in a conditional
statement. And if it's zero, then it's going to
convert that into a false value. But if it's one,
it's going to convert that into a true value.
In fact, any numeric value that is not zero, and
it's being used as a conditional statement will
return a true value. So Pete's time equals nine,
save hit play, you'll see that it prints out
pizza, pizza time equals negative three, hit save,
hit play, still prints out pizza is in this isn't
only limited to integers, you can also use floats.
So if we say pizza time equals point 0000001, hit
save, you'll see here pizza time is now a float,
we hit play, and still it will print
out pizza. And this is unique to Python,
we can't even think to do that in C sharp, if we
weren't even tried, we get all sorts of errors.
So that's just one extra flexibility you have
with using the language, Python, font and crease.
So now I want to get into the many, many,
many operators that bullions have, which
is just a testament to how
powerful these things are.
But let's start with the equality operator.
Now, let's say that you want to create some
like user login system, right. So I'm just
going to create a couple of strings here.
I'm going to say string, password type some su p T
stands for password typed, I'm going to say equals
ABC 123. And then let's do another string of semi
colon Of course, and then do another string. And
this is going to be P A for password actual.
And we're going to say equals, again, ABC 123.
Okay, so let's say that this is the user's
actual password PA, ABC 123. And what they typed
is ABC 123. So how can we check to see if they
match? Well, we'd have to use something that's
called the equality equal operator. And the
equality equal operator looks like this. pt,
equals PA. And that's all it's to it. Now, I know
what you're thinking, this looks really confusing.
And I've been programming for about 13 years now.
And I agree with you. So one thing that I usually
like to do with my bullions is first and foremost,
I like to put parentheses around whatever is like
the Boolean then I'm checking for, it just makes
it a lot easier to read when I'm scanning lines of
code. But to explain to you what's going on here,
again, equals equals that's two equals back to
back is what we call inequality equals Operator,
do not get confused with one equal one equal is
simply just the assignment operator, it means
that you want to assign something to a variable
to equals, again, is checking if two things equal
each other. So if we were to read this full line,
we're simply just initializing a boolean variable
called pizza time. And we're assigning the value
true or false to it with this Boolean operation
here. And what this Boolean operation simply does
is it just checks if p t is equal to PA.
If it is then pizza time will equal true.
But if it's not, it's going to return a false
and piece of time will equal false. I mean,
pretty simple, right? We just asked if two things
equal each other. If it is, then give us a true if
it doesn't give us a false. And as simple as this
is, if you've ever logged in to anything before,
this is pretty much all they're doing with
maybe a couple extra checks on top of that.
All right, I think I beat that horse well
enough. But I keep on hammering this in
because it's really important that you understand
this step. If you understand what's going on here,
then I think a lot of programming is going to
be really easy for you to understand, because
this is like one of the staples to programming.
Moving on. Just to prove to you that this works,
as I am saying that it does, we're gonna come down
here and do a console dot write line, just print
this to the console, pizza time. And then we also
need a console dot read key. This just makes sure
that the console doesn't immediately close when we
run it, hit the start button up here. And then I'm
going to bring the console on screen. And as you
can see, it returns a true value. But if we make
one of these slightly off, if I turn this to be
one to four instead, and we hit the start button,
you can see that whatever returns to us is a false
value. So it is not pizza time because they do not
match they are not equal. And now over in Python,
I'm just gonna quickly recreate the same scenario.
It's time equals, well, we need some
for that we need p t equals A b, c 123
p p A equals equals a string, ABC
123. And then pizza time equals
P t equals P oops, p a, like that go on to
add the prince, let's do print pizza time
here. And then I'm gonna hit the play button
and return to True Value perfect. And of course,
I can make one of these slightly off, and then
hit the play button and returns a false value.
Now, I really hope that all that made sense,
because if it did everything from this point on,
it's gonna be really easy to understand. But next,
let's move on to our next operator, which is the
equality not equal operator. And how the equality
not equal operator works is, let's say that you
want to check for like, some bad word, right?
So we're gonna change pa to be bad word, right.
And so instead of checking if they are the same,
you're going to check if they are not the same,
and not is going to be indicated by a exclamation
point. Now, what this is saying is, if they do
not equal each other, then I want you to return a
true value. However, if they do equal each other,
then I want you to return a false value, it
pretty much just flips the Boolean operation,
which again, is what we want in this scenario,
because we're trying to filter out bad word,
if what you typed is bad word, then it's not
pizza time. And just to prove to you that this
will return to true because they do not equal each
other, I'm just gonna hit the play button up here,
and then bring the console on screen,
you can see that it returns a true value.
So that's pretty much everything that you need
to know about the equality operators. Next,
let's get into the relation operator, starting
with the greater than operator. So imagine
that you have some login system, and you want to
limit the amount of times that a user can log in,
Well, one thing you can do is use
one of the relational operators,
let's just start with a greater than. So first
thing, let's just ignore these two variables
for now and create new ones, we're gonna make an
integer, I'm gonna call it a log attempts, equals,
let's just say it's three. And then let's make
another integer and call it log max equals five,
for instance, right, so what we can do
is come down to our pizza time Boolean,
and we can replace this with log Max is greater
than log attempts. And what this is doing is it's
essentially checking if log Max is greater than
log attempt. And seeing as log Max is five in log
10 plus three, this is going to return a true
value for our pizza time Boolean variable. And
just to prove to you that this is correct, I'm
gonna hit the start button, bring the console
where you can see that we have a true value. So
that's the greater than operator, we could also
use the less than operator, which is going to
check if logged Max is less than log attempts
return a true value if that is true or false value
if that is false. But there's also a greater than
equals to operator, which just checks both if it's
either greater than or equal to the log attempts.
And finally, of course, there is the less than
and equal to operator that will check if log Max
is less than or equal to log attempt. And over
in Python, these operators don't change at all,
I'm just going to get up to speed
I'm gonna do log attempt equals three
and log max equals five and then come down
to our pizza time go in and do log Max
is greater than log attempt. And then I'm going
to run that just to prove this works the same.
And voila. And the last operators I want
to go over are the end and or operators.
So here is where you really can be able to see the
power of bullions being demonstrated. Alright, so
let's bring back our old scenario. So we're going
to change this back to ABC 1234, past actual,
and then our past typed is also ABC 123. And let's
replace this Boolean operation with P t equals
equals that is our equality equal operator equals
P a. So what if you want to check if the password
is a match, and they're under a certain number of
login attempts? Well, we can use our and operator
and in C sharp It's done like this, you just type
the an ampersand, and then another and an percent.
And that is the end operator. And then after that
you can do, you can write out another Boolean
operation. So we're gonna write log attempt is
less than log max. And so what this full Boolean
is asking, it's just pretty much asking, do our
password typed in a password actual do they match,
and the two ampersands. And are we under is the
our log attempts less than our log max. If true,
if both of these are true, then return a true
value for a pizza time. But if either of them
are false, doesn't matter which one, then return a
false value for our pizza time. And just to prove
to you that that is how this operation is done,
I'm going to press the start button top and bring
the console and open, you can see that we have a
true value here. And all it takes, all it takes
is for one of these to be false. And I'm just
going to change this to be passed, or ABC 124.
And then we hit save, and then I'm going to hit
the start button and bring the constant window
over here. And you can see that we have a false,
even though one is true, we're asking for n. And
that means they both have to be true in order for
pizza time to be true. And just a quick side note,
I generally like to use a lot of parentheses
as many as possible. When it comes to Boolean
operations like this, I like the segment because
it just makes it a lot easier for me to read,
when I'm just going through lines of code,
parentheses like me know, okay, this Boolean
operation here, I see that and I know there's
another one, it just makes it a lot easier for me,
even sometimes I'll do like an overall
parentheses over the entire Boolean operation.
It just helps me read it a lot easier.
I don't know if helps you or not. But
that's a tip that you could use. And over in
Python, the syntax is just a little different.
So I'm just going to get up to speed going
to change this back to pass 123 or just
not pass is it as ABC 123. Sorry, ABC
123. And then we'll change this to be P t
equals equals p a, or did you not tell since
for me, and the way that we do in an in Python
is you literally just typed out the word
and, and log attempt is less than log Max,
boy, that has became a really small
window, maybe I should send out just a bit.
Cool. So now I'm just gonna prove this by hitting
the play button. And you can see we got a true
value. But yet again, all it takes is one of
these Boolean operations to be false. And they the
entire thing becomes false. And I'm proving that
we'll change this to four, hit the play button,
and we got a false value returned to us. But what
if you want him to be a merciful social media
developer, right, where you don't care if they get
one or the other wrong, as long as you get one of
them wrong. First of all, don't ever do this. But
if you want it to do this, you would simply just
change the AND operator into an OR operator,
and then C sharp This is done by replacing
the two ampersands. With two vertical lines.
I'm not sure what these characters are called.
But you replace it with two vertical lines, it's
on the same key that the backslash key is on just
looked it up, I guess it's called the vertical
bar character never knew that been anyhow,
this will now check if either one were true,
which we know that one of them is false,
because p t does not equal PA. But the second one
is true because log attempts is less than the log
max. And to prove that this will return true
because one of them is true, I'm going to hit
the start button and then bring the window over
you can see that we have a true value returned.
And over in Python, the OR operator is just a bit
different, just as you write out and for the an
operator in Python, you have to write out or for
the OR operator in Python. And now over in Python,
the OR operator is just a bit different, just like
how you had to write out an for the an operator,
you have to write out or for the OR operator in
Python. And of course, just to prove that this
works, I'm gonna hit the play button up here.
And you'll see we get a true value returned. So
I hope you can see what makes Boolean so
powerful in the world of programming. Just
from this simple example alone, we already have a
Boolean that checks for the log attempts next to
you know, the actual password typed. And then we
can take this Boolean and embed that into another
Boolean and just keep on adding complexity and
complexity. Billions are incredibly powerful and
and they're really important to understand.
And yeah, there you have it, guys. That is
pretty much everything that you need. To get
started programming in regards to billions.
So strings strings are one of the most important
ingredients to almost every program you'll ever
make. Why? Well, the odds are likely that at some
point in deployment or even during development,
some human will have to interface with your
application. And with that, your program needs
to communicate with them somehow. And it's highly
likely that using strings will be how you go about
doing that strings on the most basic level are
a string of characters together in a series,
hence the name string, you can write any word in
any language, you can write any number, or even
any code slang key, you name it, making strings,
incredibly powerful. And that's pretty much all
that's the strings, they're really easy to get
your head around. And there are a few things that
are really good to know while using them. So let's
take a look at a few examples. Now we're gonna
do these examples using two different languages,
because I think it can be really helpful for you
to see how they compare and contrast. And plus,
you'll pretty much learn two languages at once.
So on the left is the language C sharp using the
it Visual Studio, which should interest you if
you're gonna do windows development, or if you
want to make games using a popular game engine
called unity. And on the right is the language
Python three using the ID Visual Studio code,
which should interest you if you want to get into
more general programming or data science. Alright,
so here I have two brand new console projects.
And if you don't how to make a new console
project and either C sharp or Python, or both, be
sure to check out the video in the description.
It's called How to install an ad. And at the
end of that video, I'll show you how to do that.
Alright, so the first thing I want to get
into is some basic string syntax. So first,
I'm going to delete these lines, they come
stock with your brand new C sharp project.
And then I'm going to initialize a string, we'll
call it a just for example. And then if you want
to assign a value to a string, you have to use
double quotes. And then you can type in whatever
string you want, and then semi colon at the end.
And as far as C sharp string syntax is concerned,
that's all you will need to worry about just the
double quotes, make sure they are double quotes.
Now over in Python, we have just a little
bit more freedom. So I'm going to initialize
a string here. And then I'm going to
assign hello to it. And as you can see,
I use a double quotes just like we did in C sharp,
but you can also initialize a string and assign
Hello, with the single quotes as well, both of
these will be counted as a string within Python.
And just to prove that I'm going to do print a
and then B. Here we go. And there you have it,
hello, and Hello, both are counted as strings.
In fact, today, you're going to find that this
freedom right here, the double quotes in single
quotes can be assigned to a string is quite nice,
Yossi. And so the next thing I want to talk
about is the fact that strings are arrays of
characters. And to demonstrate that in C sharp
over here on the left, we're simply going to do
a console dot write line. And then I'm going to
do a and I'm going to use the brackets and just
put a zero in between them. This, this is an
element within the A array. Again, strings are
an array of characters. So I'm just asking for
the zeroeth element from the A string array,
which this is zero, this is one, this is 234.
Arrays always start on zero in pretty much every
programming language. And so now just to prove
that, I'm going to hit the start button up here
to run it in Africa, I always forget to do console
dot read key, this just makes sure that the
terminal stays open until we press a key and hit
start. And then bring this over here and you see
that we have the zeroeth element in the A array
that is again a string of characters, which is
H. And it's quite flexible, we can put any that
we want in here as the exercise. So if we want
to get zero, we can still be count this is zero,
and then he is 1234. So if we put four in here,
then when we hit the start button, you'll see that
it prints out in Oh, in fact, this technique is
what a lot of game developers use when they're
trying to create some chat system that pops up
one character at a time, they will pretty much
write out the entire dialogue here like Hello,
welcome. Welcome to my store. And then they will
write some function that will take in a string
and then we'll grab every single character and
then we'll print one out with a pause near like
a second pause probably a lot less than that, like
a 10th of a second pause, then print the next 1/10
the seven second pause, print the next one, so
on and so forth. Just A little add on there, and
over in Python, I'm gonna get rid of the B, we're
just going to keep the double quotes convention to
match with C sharp, given the B here, and then
I'm actually just going to do a print. Let's do
zero first, hit the play button, you'll see
we get an H. And again, we're going to do a
four. So we can get the O hit the play button,
and Oh, I forgot to save it, and then hit the
play button. And then we have Oh, right there,
pretty much the same in both languages. Again,
just remember that all strings are just a array
of characters. Next thing I want to talk about
is using the addition operator with strings.
And to demonstrate that over here in the left,
when C sharp is going to remove this Bechtel, we
had it, remove this from the right, and I'm just
going to come down here and do a plus equals oops,
plus equals, that's the addition operator, these
two right here, when you see plus equals, that is
an addition operator, plus equals and then just
add a character exclamation mark to it. And then
I'm going to print that, and you'll just see that
it's gonna be Hello, and then I'm just gonna add
a little exclamation at the end. Start that up,
bring it over here, and voila. Now one cool thing
about this process is because at the fact that the
string a is just an array of characters, using the
addition operator pretty much just says, Take that
string of characters and add this character
to the end of it. However, the cool thing is,
you aren't limited to only adding characters.
Again, the single quotes denotes a character
double quotes, and that denotes a string. So we
could add to the end of this world, for example.
Now, of course, we have to change these
single quotes or double quotes to let C
sharp know that this is now a string. And what
this is going to do is, it's now going to add
every single character in this, this character
array, or this string is going to add every
single character to this string. And just
to prove that, I'm gonna hit start, and then
we'll bring this over and voila, hello, world.
Alright, now over in Python, I'm just going to
restore this back to its original state, then do
a plus equals exclamation mark. Now, of course,
this is just going to take the Hello string,
the A string, add an exclamation point to it,
and is going to print that out with the play
button to confirm come down. And that exactly
what we got. Now, I want to again reiterate that
Python doesn't care if you use double quotes or
single quotes for characters or strings. So unlike
C sharp, we could just put world right in between
of two single quotes, and it will we hit play,
it will print out for us without giving us any
errors or any problems whatsoever. That's just one
of the benefits to using an interpreted language.
If you want to use single quotes or double quotes,
that's pretty much up to you your own discretion.
But just to keep everything consistent, we're
going to use double quotes for strings as well,
for this lesson, not before we move on, you might
be wondering, oh, well, if we can do addition
operator, what if we use like a multiplication
operator or subtraction operator, a division
operator? Well, unfortunately, the addition
operator is the only arithmetic operators that you
can use on strings. So don't get too happy. Now,
escape characters are actual characters, so I'm
not gonna go too deep into them for this lesson.
But they're pretty important to string sing as
strings are an array of characters. But let's
just look at a few of them real quick. So I'm just
going to add a few of them here. I'm going to do
backslash in. And then I'm gonna do backslash T,
I'm gonna do backslash, single quote, backslash
double quote, and then backslash, backslash.
Now these are, what is that five are the most
popular escape characters. The first one, this is
new line, this is a tab. This is single quote,
this is double quote, and this is backslash.
And I'm going to just print out this to show you
that what they do, hit the start button, and then
bring this over. And so you have a new line, which
is the backslash, N, and then a tab, which is
backslash, T. And then you have the single quote,
which is backslash single, quote, double quote,
which is backslash, double quote, then you
have backslash, which is backslash, backslash.
And these bad boys are handy because they help
you do some things that are probably not intuitive
when you first start coding, for example, like how
do you press Enter when you have just strings or
how do you use double quotes of strings required
double quotes to initialize right so for example,
I'm just gonna get rid of all these. Just
give you a quick example. I'm going to use
the escape character, double quote at the end
and it looks good. Kill character double quote
at the beginning. And this is going to look like
hello in quotes, I'm gonna hit the star button,
and then bring this over. And there you go,
you've escaped from the syntax of strings by using
the escape character. Again, I went over this
pretty briefly in this lesson. But if you want
to know more about that, check out the lesson I
did on characters, and I go a bit more in depth
about them. So I'm just going to restore this
back to how it was before I move on to Python.
Now over in Python, the syntax for the escape
characters are the exact same, I'm just gonna
get rid of this line. And then just add them just
as we have in C sharp, backslash t backslash,
single, quote, backslash double quote, and then
backslash backslash. Make sure to add that double
quote back. And yeah, there you have it. One cool
thing about this is actually a Visual Studio Code
addition is that it will change the color of
the escape characters in your string. So that's
pretty handy. I'm just going to print that out,
we should get similar results. And there you have
it. Alright, so the next thing I want to get into
is interpolated strings. Now, there is no reason
for a man to have so much love for a syntax, but
I absolutely love interpolated strings. And here,
you'll love it too. here's, here's what's
going on. Okay, so say we wanted to deliver
some message, right? I'm gonna get rid of all this
and do like Hello, name. How are you? Right. Now,
let's say you didn't want to have actual name
here. You want to have like some user input name,
right? So let's create a new string for that name.
initialize string make it name equals job Brill's.
Right. So how you would do this normally is you
would segment this string, you would do this
and you would delete this here and you would do
plus, plus name, and then plus the string again,
right, so you have three different strings, but
you have to break it apart to put the the string
variable here, and then you stitch it back
together by plussing the last half of the string.
I mean, listen, it works, it'll get the job done.
But when you have to write a lot of strings like
this, over time, it just gets really tiring
and easy to get frustrated. But that is where
interpolated strings come into play. First, just
to prove to you that this works, I'm just going
to hit the start button. And then we're going
to bring the screen over here and bada boom,
it works fine. But with interpolated strings, now
we no longer have to segment the strings anymore,
we can bring this back together as one string, and
then simply come to the beginning of our string
and add the dollar sign. This dollar sign denotes
that the string is now interpolated. And what that
allows you to do is in the middle of strings, you
can add brackets, and inside of those brackets,
you can add variables. And so now when I print
this out, check this out. This is so exciting.
Now you have the same exact thing, it's just
that you didn't have to break up your string,
I love interpolated strings. So you can imagine if
you have like a really long text or something like
that, and you have a lot of variables that you
need to inject into that text, you can simply just
turn a string into an interpolated string, and
just you know, add the brackets and your variables
all over the place. And it saves so much time.
And it's just beautiful. I love it. No run Python,
it's pretty much the same thing. I'm just going
to set this up and say hello name. How are you?
And the only difference in Python though, is
instead of $1 sign, you're going to use an
F for interpolated strings. And so now we
have the creator initializer name variable.
This is going to be jabril Rose. And so now we can
do the same thing use the brackets and bada boom,
hit play just to prove it to you, and hello to
Brill's How are you so beautiful, I love it.
And so the final thing I want to go over is just
a few handy functions that come with the string
data type. And to demonstrate these handy
functions, I'm going to get rid of this line,
it's no longer needed. And the first one I'm
going to show you is a lower casing function.
So we can just do name equals name dots to lower
end C sharp to lowers the method and use call
that add the semicolon. Then we come down here and
then just print out the name. And what's going to
happen is it's going to take the name and then
it's going to do it's going to lowercase every
single character within the name. It starts to
prove that bring the window over here and you'll
see that it has turned this into all lowercase
letters. This can be quite handy when Perhaps
you're creating like a database of users or
something like that and you don't want duplicates,
then no matter what name they pass in to your
database, you'll lowercase it every single time
and then just do a match against those. That's one
of the most common use cases for that function.
But it's always good to know just in case you need
it. Next, I want to show you the reverse of that,
which is an upper casing function. And
instead of starting over completely,
I'm just going to add on to our console
logging. So under the first write line,
I'm just going to do reset name back to equal
to Brill's. And then we're gonna do name equals
name.to to upper is the function in C sharp. And
then I'm just going to copy this Ctrl C Ctrl V.
And now it's going to first print to the console
it and all lower, and then all upper and approve
that I'll hit the start button, and bring it
over. And voila. Next up a really, really,
really useful function that comes with the string
data type is the split function. So I'm going to
reset name, I'm gonna say name equals I'm
do a little bit different this time, though.
jabril is what the comma in the middle because
we're going to use that as our character that
we're going to use to split the string apart. So
with this, we because we're splitting the string
into two, we need to have an array instead. So
I'm gonna say, string, and then add the brackets,
let a note, let the C sharp know that it's an
array, and we'll call it name to equals, and then
this we're going to name dot split, and then we'll
pass in the character, we want to use the split as
gonna be the comma. And then we can simply just
come down here and do console dot write line,
and name to. And then we want to do the first
element of that array, which is zero. And that
is the copy and paste. And then we're going to
print the second array element from that array,
which is one, and approve that it is going to
split this I'm going to hit start here. And then
I'm going to bring the window over and you see
that it's split the name based on the comma, jab,
reals, beautiful. And the final handy function
I want to show you is the contains function.
So I'm just going to do name equals,
I like the spaceship. I don't know,
I like the spaceship. And then we need a
Boolean because contained returns a Boolean.
So Boolean, we'll just say does,
and that equals name, dot contains,
and then we need to pass in a string
here. And then we're gonna say the does
this contain the word the in it and then simply we
just do console dot write line does. And then just
to prove that this does return a true value, if
it returns, if it has the word the, in the string,
I'm going to hit start, and then bring the
wind over. And you see the last right here
it was returned a true and yeah, contains is just
another really powerful function that comes with
the string data type. Really good use cases for
that, and always good to know. And over in Python,
it's just a little different than how they do it
in C sharp. So we ever named here we're gonna do
name equals whoops, equals name, dots. Lower. Huh.
And we're gonna do print name here. We're gonna
print that out, press the play button, show you
that it lowercase is the name, just as we expect.
And then the next one, I'm going to do name again
equals to Brill's, and name equals name dot upper
function, and then print name again. I'm going
to print that out. And you'll see that we have
all lowercase and then all uppercase. And now
this next string function is going to really
demonstrate how Python has a bit of an edge over
C sharp in this regard. So we're going to do name
equals the same jab and then rails. And then
here, all we have to do is name equals name,
dot split, we're just reassigned name and it will
instantly turn this into an array. That easy,
reassign it and then all we have to do then is
just to print name and to prove them and hit the
play button. And there you have it jab rails.
Yeah, personally, this is one of my favorite
reasons for using Python is because of the
ease of doing stuff. Like this versus over in C
sharp how we had to have our string name, we had
to initialize a new string array to hold the new
string array we're about to make and then printing
them out one at a time. This is just like three
lines of code. easy, simple. One of the advantages
that I love using Python, and the final one is the
contains function. So it doesn't do name equals I
like the space ship. And then come on down here,
and then do does initialize a Boolean called
does. And then we're going to do name dots.
Contains, I'll explain why this looks weird in
the second, and then the, and then we can print
does, alright, and just to prove that
works can press play, and it does not work.
And that is because of course, I forgot to save
it. So hit save, and then hit play, come on down,
and there you have it true value, I really just
want to pause for a second here and emphasize that
Python really doesn't care if you use
double quotes or single quotes. As you see,
we're using double quotes here for the name and
single quotes for the string that it contains.
And it still returns true, it just interprets.
Now, the reason why this part looks so ugly,
is because this is what's called a wrapper
method, or a method wrapper rather, and it's not
important for you understand what that term
is yet, in your early days of programming, but
essentially what this is, the Python doesn't want
you to use this way. How they prefer you to use it
is if you were to go if and then the in name. So
if the string the is a name, then we'll do print
does. Python really prides itself on you
know, being a language is kind of close
to how we actually, you know, use language as
humans. So this is how I prefer for you to use
this, this, this, this method rather. And just
to prove that we're gonna hit play, we'll make
sure it's saved and hit play, and we should see
two trues, which we do and that doesn't guys,
that's pretty much everything that you need to
get started with programming in terms of strings.
char data types are pretty easy to grasp. char
is short for character. And if you know how to
read and write in any language, then you know
what a character is. first letter, your name,
character letter, you gotten math class character,
that hashtag symbol that you overuse on social
media care, reg dir, any letter from any language,
any single digit number, any sign or symbol, even
some glyphs like the yin and yang sign or a single
character. But that's a bit beyond the scope for
this course, just keep this in the back of your
mind for when you want to learn more about them.
But for now, just know that characters are very
important in the world of programming this year,
a lot of overlap with a string data type, because
a string of characters is what makes up a string.
In fact, way back in the early days of programming
language, language, C strings didn't even exist
as a data type, you instead had to create an
array of characters, but strings like desktop
downloads c colon backslash program files
that all your applications are installed in
are all a series of characters that computers use
on a daily basis to make your computer experience
as smooth as possible. Characters play an
essential role for computers being able to
communicate and relay information to us. And
that's pretty much all there is to it. Now
from here, there's not really much to go over. But
let's have a quick look at how we go about using
characters in two different languages. Because
I think it can be really helpful to see how they
compare and contrast. And plus, you'll pretty much
learn two languages at once. So on the left, it's
a language C sharp using it Visual Studio, which
should interest you if you want to do windows
development or want to make games using a popular
engine called unity. And on the right is language
Python three using the ID Visual Studio code,
which should interest you if you want to get into
more general programming or data science. Alright,
so here I have two brand new console projects. And
if you don't know how to make a new console
project, neither C sharp or Python or both,
be sure to check out the video in the description.
It's called How to install an ad. And at the end
of that video, I'll show you how to do that. So
first things first, let's look at some basic char
syntax. So over here on the left, and C sharp
is going to remove that that come standard with
your blank console project. And then I'm going
to write char which is casting our data type.
And then we're call our variable a, and I'm going
to assign a z character to it. Now, this is how
you write a character a character in C sharp must
always be in the middle of two single quotes.
And it's really as simple as that we can put any
character we want in here we can put a we can put
j we can put eight, we can put the dollar assign
any character you want can go in between these two
single quotes, and there you have a char.
Now over in Python assigning chars is just a
little bit different. So we can do just as we
do in C sharp, we can do a equal single quote z.
However, we can also do a equals double
quote, and z. And Python will set either one,
and it will figure out that these are both a char.
But you'll see if we go back into C sharp, and
then change these from a single quote, to a double
quote z, you'll see that we'll get a type error.
The in C sharp, it specifically uses double
quotes for strings, and single quotes for
chars. But again, in Python, it's pretty smart,
we're figuring out you know, if it's a char,
or a string, one of the benefits to an interpreted
language. And just to prove to you that this is
the case, I'm going to actually change this to
variable b. And then we're going to do Print
A, and then we're gonna do print B. And
we're going to hit the play button up
here in the corner, and you'll see down here
in the output, it prints both of them. Zizi,
no problem. I'm gonna change this
back to single quotes real quick.
Right? Okay, so now with the basic char syntax out
of the way, let's talk about escape characters.
Now, what are escape characters, there will
undoubtedly come a time where maybe you're writing
out some story or creating like a list of names or
something like that. And you will undoubtedly come
across the question, How do I press Enter? Or hit
tab or insert quotes? How do I do these things?
Well, that is where escape characters come into
play. Alright, so now let's initialize an escape
character, I'm just going to cast a new variable
as a char. And then inside my character, I'm going
to hit backslash. Now technically backslash
is the escape character like to escape the
syntax of characters. But I like to call the
whole character as an escape character. It's
in, it's up for debate. But I'm going to
hit backslash in which is one of the most
common escape characters called new line. Now, I
really want you to understand how important escape
characters are. If I were to, for example, replace
the backslash with forward slash, for example,
you see, they will get an error down here for
too many characters and character literal.
Everything within the single quotes is what's
called the character literal. And you can only
put one character per character literal, these
count is two. But when you put the backslash,
that counts as one character literal, which,
again, this is a new line escape character. And
just to prove to you that it actually does what
I claimed that it does, we're going to do console
dot write line, this is just going to print up the
terminal for us, I'm gonna do a print A, which is
a variable that has z in there, and then we're
gonna do another woman to A, B, and then I'm
just copy and paste Ctrl C Ctrl, V, and then
we're gonna do another a, so what we should see
is in a print out z, and then new line, and
then another z, I'm just going to run that.
And it's off screen. Oops, I forgot I have to
also do console dot read key, otherwise, the
console will not stay open. So hit start, it's off
screen here, I'm going to bring it on the screen.
And you'll see that we have exactly what we should
expect. Now, I know there's some y'all out there
probably going Wait a second jabril. That is not
what I expect. There are two spaces in between
the Z's. And let's just pause here for a second
and really examine the logic of our program.
So the reason that we're getting two lines in
between a B and A when you probably expect no no
lines in between them, is because the function
right line itself, it does a new line for us.
So it prints out z equals z will print out z, and
they'll go to a new line, and then I'll print out
a new line and then go to a new line and then
print out z, then go to new line. And I'm
going to just run that one more time. Just confirm
that's what happens prints out a goes to new
line prints out new line goes the new line, then
prints out z and goes to new line word ends there.
So it's doing exactly as as you as we want it to
do. It just looks a little weird in this context,
because the right line function adds a new line
without really telling us it Yeah. Alright, so
now with that out of the way, let's check out our
escape characters in Python over here on the left,
I was going to change our B variable to be single
quotes. I'm just gonna use single quotes because
it's easier convention between the two, and we're
going to do a new line. And I have that backwards
supposed to do backslash. And you can see in
Visual Studio code, it'll actually slightly
tint the escape characters yellow for you to help
you give a little more assistance, which is nice.
Visual Studio regular doesn't want to do that,
anyhow, new line, and then we're going to print
out a and then we're going to print out B, and
then I'm going to copy and paste one more a. And
then let's run this by hitting the play button.
And you'll see that we have the same exact result
that we have in C sharp and you already know why
there are two lines there. Moving right along,
let's take a look at concatenating characters
concatenating, it just simply means taking a few
different things and putting them together.
So if you have three different characters,
for example, you can concatenate them, and they
become one word or one phrase, what have you.
That's all to concatenate means so to concatenate
characters, you would think it would be as easy as
you know, a new character c equals a plus a. But
it's not that simple. In C sharp, when you add two
characters together, the character data type takes
the addition operator in turns the characters into
intz. In fact, every single character under the
hood actually has an integer value assigned to it.
And we take a look at this chart here, which
is this is the ASCII chart part of Unicode,
you can see that every single character has some
sort of decimal value assigned to it. So we could
take the character two, for example, and do two
plus two. And that will get us 100, which is a
lowercase D character. But just know There aren't
too many use cases, for operations like that, just
know that this is how it works under the hood,
it's interesting stuff to know. But let's move
on. So what you want to do is you actually
want to turn your characters into a stream,
just like that, and then you'll get an error.
Because again, when you use the addition operator
on characters, they get turned ence and you're
trying to assign an integer to a string. So
way to override that is simply just right to
double quotes, and then just plus to it, it's
like a shortcut to quickly convert whatever the
assignment is to a string. The assignment, again,
is everything that's on the right side of the
variable. And so now we can just add all of our
characters, the string C. And so I'm just going to
do a plus b plus a, which is z plus new line plus
C. And then I can delete two of these right lines.
And then I'm going to add c instead of a, and then
I'm gonna hit play. Don't bring this over. And
you can see here that it's a bit different now.
Now, why is that? Well, let's take a look. Again,
right line, every time you call this function,
it will return to a new line, however, we use a
string and only one write line. So there are no
new breaks other than the one that we coated in.
So it's literally does print z, go to new line,
and then print another z, as you see here, print
z go to new line, then print z. So that's what's
going on there. Everything with programming, it's
always really basic logic that you have to follow.
And, yeah, now in Python, because Python is an
interpreted language, it makes doing stuff like
this really easy. All we have to do really is
just do c equals, then we can do a plus b plus
a simple as that, come down to our prints, we
don't need two of them. So I'll delete two of
them. And instead replace a with C, and then save
that hit the play button in the corner. And you
can see that we have the same exact result. It
prints out an A goes to new line, I'm sorry, it
prints out a z goes to new line, and then prints
to another z, as you see here. Simple, easy.
God bless Python. So that's pretty much all that's
to concatenating characters. Let's now take a look
finally, at the remainder of the most important
escape characters. So your you know backslash in
or the new line escape character. There's another
pretty important one that you should know as well.
And that is backslash, R. This is the return
character. So what the return character does,
it returns back to the beginning of the line. Now,
back in the old days, this was really important
to us, because you would go to a new line, but
it wouldn't return back to the beginning. Just
wherever you left off in the previous sentence, it
would just go to new line at that same exact spot.
So you had to call the return escape characters
to make it go back to the beginning of the line.
So what happens if we were to run this in
the console? Let's hit start the play button.
I'm going to bring it over and you'll see that
we just have one character. And that z. Even
though we have z return z, what's happening is
that it's printing out z within, it's going back
to the beginning of the line and printing z again.
And just to prove this, we can change this to why.
And then just just for extra proof,
we can change, we can add a plus u,
and hit start play button. And you'll
see what happens is it prints out z,
but then the return character returns to x and
get in line, and then it prints out a y. And
then it prints out a you essentially overriding
our first character, which is z. Now in the new
modern age, you're not really going to use the
return character too much. However, I bring it
up because it is good to know there might be
some scenarios in which you might be using an
older terminal or, or an older engine or something
like that. And you're losing your mind that you're
using the new line escape character, but it's
not returning to the beginning sentence. Here,
this is the return character use that it will all
your problems will disappear. Furthermore, in most
new modern programs in terminals, next y&z the
new line is actually it actually looks like this,
and also looks like new line and then return. And
we can demonstrate that, interestingly enough,
if we come over to Python and replace the new line
shape character with a returning escape character,
hit save, then play, you'll see that what we get
is not what we expect, it actually is a new line,
instead of a return. And the reason for this is
because what we're using to interpret the code
is something called code runner. And the
way that code runner interprets a return
escape character is likely like this, I
can't verify it. But this is likely how
it interprets just a regular return character,
thus, while we have a new line and a return.
And furthermore, if you really want to
see the difference between code runner and
you know, the terminal PowerShell that
ships with Microsoft Windows, you can hit
right click on the name of the Python script
reveal in Explorer, and then just double
click on this to run the Python script. Oh,
wait, I'm sorry, we have to add input here.
input, we'll keep the term open, double click
on the Python script. And there you have it,
we have exactly what we expect. That is just
the difference between two different terminals
interpreting interp breading sorry, code.
Okay, I hope that wasn't too confusing. Again,
you won't really have to worry about, you know,
using characters in this manner. Oftentimes, most
people don't even you interface with characters
this low level, but it is good stuff to know
when you're dealing with strings all the time. And
yeah, let's move along. The next escape character
is backslash t, which is a tab character.
I'm going to turn this back into our simple,
simple string. And then I'm going to hit
the start button and bring the console over
and you can see that is z, tab z. Simple
as that Python, it's the same, just do a
backslash T. And we hit the play button, you see
that z, tab z? Easy. So the next escape characters
we're gonna look at are the, quote, escape
characters. So at some point, you might want to
add the character single quote, or something
like that. And you go to do that you're like,
Okay, cool, single quote. Wait a second, that
how do I do that? Well, of course, simply put,
just add the escape character, backslash,
and then single quote. So this right here,
these two pieces, the backslash, and the single
quote is the single quote, escape character.
And of course, you can do the same thing with
that four string. So let's say you want to write
out some code or something, you can do backslash,
and then a double quote. And that is the double,
quote, escape character. So now if we just
run this program, hit the start button,
you can see that we get some really weird string
with the double quotes. The single quote z
is just a demonstration to show you how you can
use quotes if you really need to. And now in
Python, it's actually a little bit different. So
we can still do the same. Use the backslash, whoa,
I'm going to replace that backslash and then
single quote, to get our escape character
single quote, for example, you can hit play.
Oh, and saying sorry, running. Oh, of course,
I have to stop code on right click on the output,
and then do stop. Code run if you have input,
just a quick caveat, because you won't be able to
hit that play button anymore. But I'm gonna hit
play. And you'll see that we have our sin called
escape character, I replace with double quote,
same deal, right, hit the play, you
see that? Oh, wait, I have to save it,
sorry. And then hit play. And you'll see they
have a double quote, no big deal, right? Now,
how Python is a little more special a little
different is that we can use either single quotes
or double quotes for a character literal. So we
can, you know, if we want to use a double quote,
we just use single quotes on the outside.
And then I'm gonna save that and hit play.
And it's the same exact thing. But if only is the
same, quote, I can change the outside quotes to
be double quotes, like so. And just put a single
quote in the middle, and then save that hit play.
And you see that we have a single quote in the
middle of twosies. So that's another benefit to
an interpreted language. It might save you a bit
of time there. But it's just yeah, it is what it
is. And the last important escape character is
actually the backslash itself. At this point,
you already know where I'm going with this. But
if you want to write a backslash escape character,
you have to do backslash to escape out, and then
another backslash. So two backslashes will get
you one. And just to prove that, I'm gonna remove
this right there, and then I'm gonna hit the start
button, bring this over, and voila, z, backslash,
z. And over in Python, it's the same exact thing,
you just have to do backslash to escape out,
and then another backslash. And I'm just gonna
save it play. Come on, down. And there you go, z,
backslash, z. And there you have it, guys. That's
pretty much everything you need to know to get
started with programming in terms of characters.
Let's talk about floats, floats sent for floating
point values, or floating point numbers, both are
pretty much the same thing in which you could
think as numbers or values that float somewhere
in between integers. So if both one and two are
integers, with two coming right after one, then a
float makes up all the numbers in between one and
two 1.1 1.2 1.3 1.4 1.5 all the way to 1.9. But
make no mistake about it floats aren't limited to
just one decimal place value. Pi, for instance, is
a float, it's most commonly represented as 3.14.
But we have no idea how many actual decimal points
pi has, as it stands, researchers have calculated
the two quadrillion digit for pie, and are still
researching how to calculate even more digits. So
in short, the floating point values in between two
integers are infinite. And that is pretty much the
basic two floats, they can honestly take a little
work to understand them in their entirety. But for
now, all you need to know is that they are values
in between integers. So now let's take a look at
a few examples on how to use floats with code.
And we're going to do this by using two different
languages because I think it can be really helpful
to see how they compare and contrast. And plus,
you will pretty much learn two languages at once.
So on the left is the language C sharp using the
ID Visual Studio, which should interest you if
you want to do windows development, or if you want
to make games using a popular game engine called
unity. And on the right is language Python three
using the Add Visual Studio code, which should
interest you if you want to get into more general
programming or data science. Alright, so here I
have two brand new console projects. And if you
don't know how to make a new console project,
neither C sharp or Python, or both, be sure to
check out the video in the description. It's
called How to install an ID. And at the end of
that video, I'll show you how to do that. Alright,
so the first thing I want to get into floats is
the different operators. If you're familiar at
all with the operators, the integers use, then
you'll be quite familiar with the operators that
floats use as well. Why? Because they are the same
exact operators. So jumping right into it in C
sharp here on the left, I'm just going to get rid
of these two lines that don't need them anymore.
They come standard with every single new console
project. And I'm just gonna initialize a float.
So I'm gonna type out float. And then I'm gonna
call it a just for an example. And I'm assign
zero to it. Actually, that's no fun because
zero is integer. So let's assign, let's assign
7.77. That sounds fun. Now actually, before
we get into talking about operators, let's
touch a bit on the syntax between Python and C
sharp. There's not really much to the differences
between the syntax of floats. However, in
C sharp you do have to clarify that your
numeric value is a float by adding an F at the
end of the numeric value. This is just further
instructions to tell the compiler on how they
should go about handling this numeric value.
Simply meaning when your code is turned
into instructions for a computer to do,
when it gets to this line right here, it reads
the flow. And it knows without any confusion
that this is a floating point value. However,
there is a caveat. Even though this variable A
is a float variable, you don't always have to add
the float to the end of your values. For example,
if you instead just say float a is an integer
seven floats automatically can convert themselves
from integers to floats, therefore, you don't have
to add the F. Now while in C sharp, you have to
add the F at the end of floating point values. In
Python, you don't have to do that, all you have to
do is just type out whatever value that you want
to do 7.77. And Python will take care of the rest
for you. And Python is able to do this because
it's a type of language called an interpreted
language, where all you have to do is assign
a value to a variable. And it will interpret
what data type that variable should have, which
in a lot of cases is pretty nice, because you
don't have to worry about the differences
between floating point values are integers,
you can just do sums and multiplication division,
and not have to worry about any of that stuff. But
now let's get into some operators starting with
the increment operator. So an increment operator
does exactly what it describes it increments and
the syntax for that goes like this, a plus plus,
that's it. If we were to come down here and do a
console dot write line, that just will print to
the console for us. And then we also need to
console dot read key for C sharp so that the
console doesn't close on us. And I'm gonna hit the
start button and bring the console window over,
you can see that it just increments it by one
plus one to 7.77 gives us 8.77. And that is the
increment operator. Now in my experiences, it's
not like a terribly good, handy tool. But it can
save you some times oftentimes, if you just want
to add one to something, instead of having to do
like full out. Other operators need to do you
know the variable plus plus and you're done.
And to do the increment operator in Python, you
actually can't do an increment operator in Python,
if we were to type out a plus plus, you can see
that our ID shows that it's red to let us know
that this is not a thing in Python, every language
is different. And Python just doesn't care about
the increment operator, I guess. So now imagine
that you want to add more than one to your float?
How would you go about doing that? Well, that is
where our next operator, the addition operator
comes into play the syntax for the addition
operator goes like so. So you want to do a or your
variable, your float plus equals and then whatever
value so we can do plus equals one to do another
way to do an increment operator. Or we can pass in
a flow we can do, for example 3.33, F, and again,
I added an F to the end of this value because it
is a floating point value. And if we were to run
this hit the start button, bring the window over,
you can see that we got 11.1. Now just the minor
note just to make sure we're covering all bases,
you can see that it does not pronounce 11.1 F. And
the reason for that is because the F is something
that only the computer needs. Once the computer
sees the code reads to F and sees that it's a
floating point value, there's no point to return
that back to us because we're humans, and we're
smart. And we know the difference between a float.
And just by looking at it moving a long to use the
addition operator in Python, it's absolutely no
different syntax wise, you do your variable in our
case, a plus equals 3.33. And again, we don't need
add f because it's Python in Python doesn't care
about F's far to come down here and write print
a and then save it and hit the play button
you can see down here that we will get
11.1. And as far as adding is concerned, the final
way that you can add value to your float is by
doing something that I like to call a modified
assignment. Now this isn't a technical term.
I'm not sure if it has one or not. But I like
to distinguish this from regular assignments.
So what we're going to do is just get rid
of all this just to clear up confusion.
And then we can do a equals a plus 3.33 F.
And there you have a modified assignment. Now
Whoa, what's going on here looks a
little bit confusing. Well, don't worry,
let me walk you through it. First thing you need
to know is that this is the assignment operator.
And everything that is on the right side of an
assignment operator is calculated first. So the
whatever the state of A is, which in this case
is 7.77 is going to be added to 3.33. And once
that result is calculated, then it's going
to throw that result to the left side of the
assignment which is again In a sauna, since we're
assigning a to equal what it currently equals,
plus some extra value, we're just updating it
really just a few different ways to do the same
thing. But you, as a developer have the choice
to go with whatever best fits your programming
styles. And just to prove to you that this is
the exact same result on hit the start button,
bring the window over, you can see that again,
we have 11.1. And over in Python to do a modified
assignment is the same exact syntax. So I'm going
to remove this lines to clear confusion start over
and we can do a equals itself, plus 3.33. And just
to prove to you it's the same exact result, I made
the play button, you can see boom, another 11.1.
Next up, we have a few operators for subtracting.
And the first one is the decrement. operator.
Well, you already know what the increment operator
does. So guessing what the decrement operator does
should be a no brainer. Yes, you guessed it is
simply just minuses one from your float. And just
like the increment operator is plus plus, well,
the decrement operator is minus minus, that's all
there is to it. And to prove to you that it does
what I say it does, I'm going to hit the start
button, bring the wind over. And you can see,
we have 6.77, because 7.77 minus one is, of course
6.77. And again, from my experience is not the
most helpful operator out there, it can help you
save some time writing code here and there. But
it is what it is. And also again in Python, just
as they don't have the increment operator, well,
they also don't have the decrement operator, I can
type out a minus minus and you can see turns red,
then it's know that this is not a thing in this
language. And so if you want to subtract more than
one from your float, you can use what's called
the subtraction operator. And the syntax for
that is probably just as you expect, minus equals
and then your float value, or your integer value,
whatever numeric value, and just to prove to
omit the Start button and bring the window over.
And as you can see, 7.77 minus 3.33 equals 4.44.
And over in Python, the subtraction operator is
the same exact syntax, we're going to get rid
of this start over a minus equals and then your
value. And just to prove that to you met the
play button, and you can see that we have
4.43999999. Now some of you are probably going
what's up this discrepancy, C sharp said 4.44.
But Python says 4.43999 bla bla bla bla,
well, I'm just going to give it to straight
floating point values is something made by the
devil, it's important to remember that floating
points are the values in between integers.
And that space in between any two integers
is infinite, and anything dealing with infinity.
But long story short, if you're just starting out,
you don't have to concern yourself with things
like this at the moment, at some point in time,
perhaps he might dig into some project that
requires like really precise floating point
precision. And at that point, you can pull your
hair out. But for now, just know the reason why
you're seeing this is because in C sharp floats
around to nearest digit, there are more accurate
data types. But that's beyond the scope for this,
this course. And for almost all your applications,
two to three point floating precision is
oftentimes good enough, you don't need to worry
yourself with this kind of accuracy. It's part of
the reason why we have calculated about I think
the quadrillion digit of pi, but we often just
round it off to 3.14. Because oftentimes, that's
a good enough precision estimate. Moving on, the
final way that we can subtract is of course, by
using a modified assignment. And to do a modified
assignment for subtracting all we do is get rid of
this and we do a equals itself minus 3.33 F. And
just to prove to you that works, just as I say it
does, I'm hit the play button, bring it over, and
you can see that we have 4.44. And over in Python,
the syntax is no different than C sharp, we
can do a equals itself minus 3.33. I'm gonna
save hit the play button, and you can see that we
got 4.43999. Next up the multiplication operator,
whenever you want to do multiplication to
your floats, you simply just have to use the
multiplication operator. And the syntax for that
goes like this A times equals two, for example,
and when you run this, it's simply just going to
take your float a and times it by two and prove
that to you. I'm at the start button and bring the
window over you can see that 7.77 times two equals
15 point 54 and of course what you times your
float by doesn't have to be an integer, it can be
a floating point. But of course it just has to be
some numeric value. And over in Python, the syntax
is the same exact as it is in C sharp A times
equals to prove that to you hit the play button,
and you see that we have 15 point 54. And of
course, another way we can do multiplication is
if we do a modified assignment and the syntax
for that, of course, you already know it is a
equals a times to prove that to you, I hit the
start button and bring the wind over. And again,
we have 15 point 54. And in Python, the syntax
is no different. We can do a equals a times two,
and then press play and show it to you that again,
we have 15 point 54. Now one thing that you didn't
see me do is like something like a times times,
and the reason for that is unlike subtraction or
addition, there is no sort of incrementing
multiplication. What does that even mean,
really. And so moving on, the final operator is
the division operator, which the syntax for that
goes as follows a divided by equals to Alice make
an interesting, let's say, 2.15. And of course,
what this is going to do is going to take
our a float, and it's going to divide it by
2.15. and prove that to you, I'm gonna hit the
start button and bring the window over a, we see
that we have 3.613953, that's gonna be fun to say
over and over. And over in Python, the division
operator is the same exact syntax. So we can do a
divided by equals 2.15. And to prove that to you,
I'm gonna hit the play button. And you can see
that Python is a lot worse, we have 3.613953.
And it goes on and on. I know that I'm kind of
demonizing the long decimal points with Python,
but it's actually a good thing that they give
you this precision right out the box. And the
final way we can divide is by using a modified
assignment, which the syntax for that looks like
this, I'm just gonna start over to make it a
bit less confusing. A equals A divided by 2.15,
F. And just to prove that to you, I'm at
the start button and bring the window over,
you can see again, we have 3.613953. And yeah,
there you have it. floats are pretty useful in
the world of programming. They're used for a
lot of different applications. And don't let me
scare you with the whole floating point precision
talk. It's very, very rare that you'll have to be
in this world floating points. Usually, you
won't go no further than like two or three point
precision, which at that precision, everything's
really simple to understand. But that's pretty
much everything you need to know to get started
with programming in regards to floats. It's time
to talk about arrays. Now, arrays are most often
used with loops, but they can use in almost any
context. So what is an array? Well, you can think
of an array as essentially a container that holds
a fixed number of variables that all have the
same data type. So the fact that they're just
containers that hold variables, you can use
these variables independently. in any context.
Say you want to update an array full of
names with a couple of lines of code,
or maybe easily save an array of 100 emails to a
file without having to copy and paste and change
the variable here and there. Well, arrays make
doing things like this really easy to do. But
instead of going on and on with examples about how
arrays are the coolest thing since sliced bread,
let's just jump right into looking at a few
examples and use cases to learn how do we go
about using arrays with code. And we're going to
do this using two different languages because I
think it can be really helpful for you to see how
they compare and contrast. And plus, you'll pretty
much learn two languages at once. So on the left
is language C sharp using the it Visual Studio,
which should interest you if you want to into
Windows development, or make games using a popular
game engine called unity. And on the right is the
language Python three using the it Visual Studio
code, which should interest you you're going into
more general programming or data science. Alright,
so here I have two brand new console projects. And
if you don't how to make a new console project,
neither C sharp or Python or both, be sure to
check out the video in the description. It's
called How to install an ID. And at the end of
that video, I'll show you how to do that. Alright,
so let's get a bit into arrays. So arrays
are simply just a data structure, meaning
it's a certain way in which you can structure
your different data types. So I won't get into
too much in how to use arrays. Otherwise, this
video returns just like a long list of examples.
But let's jump into this. So the first thing
I want to touch on is the different syntax for
arrays in both C sharp and Python. But before we
do that, I want you to imagine that you're making
some sort of four player game, let's say and every
single player starts with the same amount of HP.
So let's create those variables first over
here in the lesson C sharp and get rid of
these two lines. Because I don't need them
to come standard with every console project,
and I'm going to initialize an integer, I'm
gonna call it HP one, I'm assign that to be 100.
And then I'm gonna do it again, assign another, HP
to equals 100. And then int, HP three equals 100.
And then finally, ant HP four equals 100. Great.
So we have four different integers for four
different players. But with the raise, there's no
need for four different variables, we can simply
come up here and initialize a new integer array.
And the syntax for that goes as follows. First,
we want to type out the data type that we want to
put into an array, which of course, in our case,
is an integer. And if you want to denote that this
is an array, you simply just add a start bracket.
And in bracket, this right here is how you
denote an integer array data structure. And
so after that, we just type out our variable name,
which I'm going to call it hp. And then we have to
assign to it a new integer array. And then within
the brackets here, you have to specifies the size
of your array, which we have four players, so the
size is four at a semi-colon, and you're done.
So now that we have our integer array with
the size of four, we can now assign values to
what's called the elements of that array. And
to do that, I'm just going to come down here,
and I'm going to say HP, and then at the bring
back the starting bracket and then typing the
element number. Again, it's the size of four.
So we're going to start with zero. All right, so
you probably just got a little confused
on why I started on zero instead of one.
Well, in most programming languages, arrays
always start on zero. Why you ask? Well, zero
is a number two and in computing, zero
is actually the first number, not the
biggest deal. But a really simple fact that it's
important to remember because if you start on one,
you might get a lot of errors and might want to
pull your hair out. So just remember with arrays,
zeros always first Anywho, we have the HP integer
array at element zero. And what we want to do
is assign 100 to it. And now we just want to do
this for all four elements, I'm going to do HP
of element one, assign another 100 to
it, the HP of element two if I can type,
and then assign 100 to it. And then finally HP
element three and assign 100. to it. Again, quick
note, you can see that we ended on the element
three, although we initialized an integer array
with the size of four. But if you were to count
them, you can see that we have four elements here,
012, and three. And of course, the reason
for this offset is because in computing,
we always start on zero, it can trip you up a
lot at the beginning, but it's something that
you'll get used to eventually. Now I know if this
is your first time learning about arrays, it can
be quite difficult to get a conceptual grasp on
what's going on here. And so I'm going to walk you
through a quick visual. So what we have here is an
array with the length of 901234567 and eight, this
bottom row right here is the index or the element.
They're both interchangeable. But for this course,
I'm going to be calling it the element and this
top row is the value at that element. And so if
this were our HP integer array, it would end right
here, right at the third element. And after we
initialize the integer array, it was filled with
all zeros in the value spots. And so what we did
in the code is we simply went through and assigned
100 to every single element in that array.
And that conceptually is what's going on with the
race. And that's not just for integers, it's for
every single type of array, if you have a string
array, a float array, a character array, what have
you. Now with that out the way we no longer need
these variables, we can delete those. And then
to prove to you that these work, as I say they
do, I'm going to write a console dot write line.
So that we can print this to the console and
I'll do HP zero, and then semi colon, I'm just
going to hit Ctrl C Ctrl V copy paste a few times
and simply just change elements zero to one, two,
and three, we're also going to need a console dot
read key. This is so that the terminal doesn't
close when we run it. And now I'm just going to
come up here to the start, hit the start button,
and then bring the console window over to show you
that we have four players with 100 Hp initialized.
Now last thing I want to mention on this is that
if you try to assign a value to an element that
is outside of the range for that array, then you
will get an error and to demonstrate that if I
come here and do HP of element four and assign 100
to it, hit the Save button then play and you can
see that it gives us an exception Saying pretty
much that we don't have an array of this size,
therefore you can't assign to the fourth element.
So just be mindful of the size of your race. Now
over in Python, the syntax for arrays are a bit
different. And Python actually doesn't even use
arrays, they actually use a type of data structure
called a list. And you can initialize a list in
Python in two different ways. But the syntax for
the first one goes as follows. First, we're going
to write out the name of our variable, which of
course is HP, and then we're going to do equal
and then start bracket. And then you just type
out whatever values you want in here. So again,
we have a four player game with four different
players with 100 hp each. So I'm simply just
going to write 104 times with a comma separating
each of them. And there you have it, that's done.
And then to prove it to you, I'm just going to
write print and then pass in the whole array,
HP, hit the play button, and you can see that it
prints out an array with four elements. As you
can already see, Python has a huge leg up when it
comes to doing this type of stuff. In Python, we
really wanted to do two lines of code in C sharp,
we had to do what eight 910, about nine different
lines of code. Big difference. And the reason for
this you might ask is just the design philosophies
with the languages. Python is more designed to
be really easy to use and do a lot of data stuff.
And C sharp was kind of piggybacked off of the C
language. So that did carry over a lot of stuff
the C was already doing. But yeah, you get to
pick and choose, there are pros and cons with both
of them. So that was the first way that you can
initialize a list in Python. And here's the second
way, I'm going to come down here and do HP equals
empty array. And then it's as easy as HP dot
append, and then your new parentheses because it's
a function. And then you want to append whatever
you want. So I'll pin 200 for the first player,
and then I'll append again, another 100 for the
second player, HP dot a pin, the third player
and at last HP dot append for the last player.
And just to prove to you that does exactly what
I say it does, I'm going to do print, again, HP,
come up here to the topic, the play button,
and you can see that we print out 100
100 100 102 times now this function is one of the
benefits to using lists over array is that you can
initialize the empty list and just add to that
list. And C sharp has one too, but it's a bit
beyond the scope for this video. Okay, so let's
now talk about the real thing that makes a race
so powerful. And that's array iteration. Alright,
so this is cool. Now we have all of our player HP
in one variable. But what if instead of four
players with hp, you had 100 players with hp,
this would get old quick haven't read this out 100
times. Well, that is where four loops come into
play. Now, arrays and for loops are like burgers
and fries, they're just a perfect combo. So now
let's bring in a for loop so that we can easily
assign a value to the elements in our array.
So I'm just going to come up here above our
variables here. And I'm just going to write out
the for loop syntax. So for and then int i equals
zero, and then semi colon, and then if i is less
than we have four elements, so four, and then
we're going to do i plus plus if that is true,
and then we need to add our code block here.
And then we simply just need to write our
variable. And two here, so I'm not going to
go too much into the for loop on how it works,
because I have a full episode about that. So check
that out if you're confused, but essentially,
on a very layman's level, the for loop, it's
simply just assigns zero to our integer here,
and then if it's less than four, then we're
just going to add to it every single update.
And we can then use the eye as a location
within the for loop. And so with that, if
this four loop is less than four, then they will
increment meaning it's going to stop at three,
which is exactly what we need, because our element
also stops at three. And so what that means is
that now we can change this zero element two
I element, and we no longer need these because
they will be set with the for loop. In addition to
that, because we're also using the array element
for printing. We could even come down here and do
console dot write line, and then HP of I elements,
meaning we no longer need these lines either.
And so now just the proof to this works. I'm
hit the start button, and then I'm going to
bring the window over you can see that we have
four For 100. So now back to the scenario I set
up, say instead of four players you wanted 100,
well, we simply will come to our array size
here. And we'll change the array size to 100.
And we also need to change the iteration for our
for loop, one to stop at 100. And to prove that
to you, I can just hit the play button, and then
bring the wind over here and there is 100 100.
It's a bit hard to tell. But there's, there's
100, hundreds here and over in Python.
Again, the syntax for this is a bit different.
So I'm just going to get rid of these lines,
because let's just start over. But again, we
do have two ways we can go about doing this.
And the first way is really, really simple.
All you got to do is do HP and then assign a an
array of 100, but times that by 100. and
prove that to you, I'm gonna do print
HP, and then hit the play button. And you can see
that we have 100 A hundreds in an array. Simple,
easy into the point God love Python. And for
the second way, it's a bit more involved, um,
come down here and initialize an empty array. And
then we're gonna do a for loop. The syntax is a
bit different in Python, for i in range of 100,
and then oops, and then I'm going to come down
here. And because it's an empty, I said empty
array, but it's actually empty list, we're not
going to get like the element of anything, we're
simply just going to do HP dot append, and 100.
So then down here, all you got to do is print hp.
And we should get two arrays of 100. Hundreds,
which probably is going to be a bit
confusing, but let's do it anyway, hit play.
And yeah, there is the second one. And there's
the first one completely identical. Two ways to
go about doing it, you as developer, you have the
choice on which one you want to use. And so yeah,
that's pretty much the basics, all you need
to know to go about using this data structure.
Anything from this point on would just be me
listening out a million different examples on,
you know, different use cases. But if pretty
much from this point on, it's up to you,
as a developer to get creative and apply this
data structure in different ways. And hopefully,
you are starting to think of some different
creative ways on how you might be able to use
arrays or arrays and for loops together. But
that is everything that you need to know to get
started with programming in regards to a race.
Okay, let's talk about the big bad variables
without even talking about programming.
What does variable mean variable defined
by dictionary calm is something that has the
ability to vary or change him believe it or not,
it means the same exact thing in programming as
well. A variable is something used to store data,
you can think of it as a container, but what you
put in this container can be changed and updated,
giving it the name variable. Now there is one very
important thing that requires understanding when
talking about variables. And that is data types.
If you can grasp this thing about variables,
I think you'll save yourself a log of
annoying errors, especially in the beginning,
when you create a variable. all languages need to
know the data type of your variable and to again,
thinking about a variable as a container. Imagine
that we have two data types that we want to store
into a container. Let's just say one data type
is reptiles and the others fish, well, you can't
store these two data types in the same container
fish need to be surrounded by water in order to
breathe. And reptiles need land in often hot, dry
climate in order to stay comfortable and alive.
So what happens if you drop a reptile into a
containment for fish? That's right, you'll get a
type error, just as if you create a variable meant
for billions and try and assign a string to it.
So how do we actually go about using variables
with the different data types and etc? Well, it's
quite simple actually, let's take a look at some
examples using two different languages because I
think it can be really helpful for you to see how
they compare and contrast. And plus, you'll pretty
much learn two languages at once. So on the left
is language C sharp using it Visual Studio, which
should interest you if you want to do windows
development or want to make games using a popular
game engine called unity. And on the right is
language Python three using the Add Visual Studio
code which interests you if you want to get into
more general programming or data science. Alright,
so here I have two brand new console projects. And
if you don't how to make a new console project and
either C sharp or Python or both. Be sure to check
out the video in the description. It's called How
to install an ID. And at the end of that video,
I'll show you how to do that. Alright, let's start
off by looking at initializing some variables and
the syntax of that between C sharp and Python.
So over here on the left and C sharp I'm going to
start by getting rid of these two lines because I
don't need them. They come standard with it. The
new console project. And now let's take a look
at the five main data types. First, we have
bullions. And you can initialize a Boolean,
like so, just type out the word bool. And then
whatever name for your variable. In this case,
we'll just do a. And now let's initialize our
next data type, which is a char. So you do that
by typing out the type of data, which again, is
char, and the name your variable. Let's just keep
in alphabetical order going here, and I'll just
name it B. And now the char has been initialized,
let's initialize our next data type, which is a
string. And we do that by typing out the type of
data which is a string, and then keeping the
alphabetical order, we'll just name it a C,
I think you can get the pattern at this point,
we're gonna initialize the next data type,
which is an int, just type of the type of data and
then name, the variable, we'll keep, we'll call it
a D keep the order convention going. Now, the last
data type is a float, which we'll call an E. And
there you have it, initializing your variables in
C sharp is pretty straightforward. You just type
out whatever type of data you want to initialize,
and then name that variable. And that's for all
data types. However, this isn't the only way that
you can initialize variables, you can also assign
something to those variables when you initialize
them. And to assign something to variables, you
have to use what's called the assignment operator,
which don't let that scare you, because it's as
simply as just typing equals, equals here, this
sign is what's called the assignment operator,
it allows you to assign something to a variable.
And for this Boolean, let's just assign it to be
true. So let's go through and assign something to
all of our variables. So for our char variable,
let's assign the letter J to it. And then
for our string, let's assign the string candy
to it our integer, let's assign the number
13. And then for our flow, let's assign a
7.77. f, that's, that's a good number. And there
you have it, that is a another way that you can
initialize a variable. But heads up, it's always
best practice to initialize your variables with
an assignment like true j, for example, these are
assignments. And the reason for that is because
like the previous example, if you initialize them
without any assignments, sometimes they can return
No. And if you're using that variable, you might
come up with some weird edge cases, and you'll get
errors. So it's always best practice to just
assign a value to your variables whenever you
initialize them. Now to initialize variables in
Python, it's a lot simpler with a slight caveat.
So Python does away with the idea of having
to cast your variables. So like over here,
in C sharp, we have to cast that our a variable is
a bool datatype cast that our B variables a char
data type, typing the type of data next to it is
what's called Data casting. And then Python, you
don't have to do that, all we have to do instead
is simply type out the name of our variable and
assign something to it. So if we want to make a
Boolean, we just assign a true value to it. The
Python language is a type of language classified
as an interpreted language. And what that means is
Python interprets the data type of your variables
depending on what you assigned to it. So at
the fact that we assigned a true value to the a
variable, when you go to run your Python script,
Python will know that the a variable has
a boolean data type, because we assign a
boolean value to it. And this goes for all
variables. For example, if we just copy what
we did in C sharp, b equals j, and C equals candy,
and then d equals 13, and then equals 7.77, Python
will interpret all of these variables into their
appropriate data type. And there are benefits
to this. And to examine that, let's go back to C
sharp for a second. Now at the fact that you have
to explicitly cast your data type in C sharp,
the moment that you initialize that variable,
it is stuck with that data type. For example,
if I wanted to come down here, and let's say,
I don't want a to be a char actually wants to
be a bull. Well, I couldn't do bool b equals
true. For example, it will tell us that this
variable has already been defined. So we can't
recast data types of variables. Well, can we
just reassign the tab a different type of data?
And the answer is no, it will tell you that you
cannot convert it from its original data type to
new data type is pretty much saying this variable
already has a data type. However, in Python,
because it's an interpreted language, we can
do whatever we want with our variables. So for
example, we can come down here and say like, I
want B to equal true and it'll give you no error.
whatsoever. And to prove this, I'm just going to
write out a print function here, print a, whoops,
A, B, C, D, E, and you will see that we will get
two trues for a and b. Let's save and hit the
play button. And Wallah. Now, although this data
type free syntax seems pretty cool and whatnot,
and don't get me wrong, it is really cool. It is a
lot of flexibility, especially if you know how to
use it, right. But it can also cause some problems
if you're not careful. A lot of the common issues
that I was finding myself in in the early days of
learning Python with this data type free syntax
was that I was never really sure what data
type some variables were. And I was trying
to use them in certain contexts, and it was
just really messing me up. Another issue is
that there's nothing preventing you from easily
reassigning a variable, when you didn't mean to
end C sharp, for example, they'll tell you
if you already have a variable with that name
in your script. And it will also tell you for
trying to change the data type for that variable,
which both kind of act as a sort of security,
if you will, but either way both have their own
pros and cons, it's up to you decide which one is
best for you moving along, one thing that I think
is really important to touch on is assigning your
variables after initialization. So in C sharp, you
only have to cast the data type of your variable
one time. In fact, you can only cast the data type
of your variable one time to demonstrate this,
I'm just going to get rid of this line because
I don't need it. And let's try and reinitialize
our a variable as a bowl with a false value.
So I'm going to cast our data type, I'm
gonna do bool, and then a equals false.
And you can see here that it tells us that
this variable has already been initialized.
Essentially, that's what it's saying. And of
course, what you're assigning to that variable has
to be a value that is accepted by that data type.
For example, Boolean only except true or false,
for example, and of course, in Python, because
it's an interpreted language, this is no problem,
we can simply just do a equals false. And we could
also do b equals false if we wanted to C equals
false. And why stop there, we can do d equals
false as well. And we can even do c equals false.
Because this will all be interpreted when we run
our script, which is now I made the play button
up at the top and you'll see we get all false
and a 777. Because I didn't do II here sorry,
equals false save, hit the play button. And there
you go all falses it was interpreted as soon as
you run the script. And so that is the gist of
variables, they're really easy to get your mind
around, it's just you have to remember that these
are pretty much containers that have some sort of
data in them with a specific data type. So lastly,
I'm just going to leave you with a simple example.
So that you can kind of get a better idea on how
variables are applied and how they're useful.
So imagine you're making some sort of game
with the boss battle. And this boss can only
take damage, when it's either hurt, flashing
or dizzy. It has to be in some sort of state.
So I'm just gonna create the scenario. Remove
all these lines, don't need them start over.
First initialize an int, I'm gonna call it enemy
hp. For example, that equals 50. And then get a
Boolean there recall this hurt. And let's just
say that it's already hurt. So hurt equals true.
Get another Boolean, we'll call it a flashing,
flashing equals true. And then let's do
ball. dizzy, let's say dizzy. And let's just say
that it's not dizzy. It's not really important.
I'm just gonna use if statements to create
those states. If hurt, then we're going to do
enemy HP minus equals four, for example.
And then if I'm going off screen here,
if I'm what else is there, flashing? Oops. If
it's flashing, then enemy HP minus equals four.
And lastly, sorry, see if what dizzy. Then
also enemy HP minus equals four. Alright,
so just to explain what's going on here. It's just
as I said, we have, let's say you're making some
game with the boss battle. And the only way that
the boss can take damage as if it's either hurt,
flashing, or dizzy. Now, none of this is really
important to the example that I wanted to create.
But it at least gives you an idea of a scenario.
So now imagine that you did some testing on your
game and you figured out that for is not enough
damage to make the game fun. You need that damage
to be higher. Well, you would have to go back into
your script and change enemy HP minus equals you
know, let's just say seven enemy HP minus equals
seven again In any HP minus equals seven. And
let's say that you had this reference to damage
like all over your scripts, you have to do this
as many times as you as you have that reference.
And this is a use case where variables are very
useful. So instead of having to do this, as many
times as you make the reference in your script,
you could simply just come up to your variables up
here and just initialize let's say, a new integer,
call it damage and set it to seven. And then all
you have to do is go throughout your script, and
just add a reference to that the integer you just
initialized. So my sequel stat, whoops, damage,
damage and damage. So now let's say that you
retested your game again, and you're like, Oh,
wait, On second thought, seven is a bit
too high, I need to bring it down a bit.
Well, instead of having to go again, through all
of your scripts, and changing wherever you make
a reference to HP minus damage, all you have
to do is now change one variable to you know,
a lower number, let's say six. And now all
of these references are updated. And so
now that your damage value is a variable, you now
have a lot more power with it, you can come down,
for example, so your dizzy state and say like,
just for example, if he's dizzy, then what I want
to do is damage equals three, for example, I want
to make it a lot weaker if it's dizzy, and this
will be updated whenever it's flashing, and you
do this line, or you do this line. And of course,
I'll just quickly do this example in Python, it's
going to get rid of everything, I don't need it.
I'm going to do enemy, HP enemy HP
equals 50. And then hertz equals true
and flashing equals false and then dizzy. equals
false. I got that backwards, this is actually
true. And then we have to do if hertz, then enemy,
HP minus equals damage, I guess we need to damage
them just go straight for the actual example minus
equals six. And then if, if what is it flashing,
then enemy HP minus equals damage. And if dizzy,
whoops, dizzy, then damage equals three. And why
not just for fun, we can run this I'll do at the
end of it all print and PHP, just see what we get.
I did not pre calculate this, we get 38. Very
nice. And then if we print this in C sharp, we
should get the same result. I'm going to console
dot write line. And then what is this enemy hp.
And then oops, similar icon then we also need
a console dot read line. So the console doesn't
close on us when we run it. I'm at the start
button up here and then bring the console over
and you see that again, we have 38 Very nice. And
there you have it. Again, variables are pretty
easy to conceptually understand, but they get a
lot more powerful and a bit more complex when you
start using different data structures like arrays
and whatnot. But that's pretty much everything
that you need to know to get started with
programming and regards to variables. Alright,
so in if statement is a type of conditional
statement in programming, meaning it checks if
a certain condition is met an if statement in the
most simplest terms is if this than that, in fact,
if statements in programming are actually
shorthand for If This Then That statements,
one of the greatest lessons on fact that most
people don't even realize with if statements is
that if statements are essentially just bullions
they activate if something is true, and don't if
something is false. Now remember that because
understanding that fact can save you a lot of
headache when trying to debug your if statements,
you simply just have to look at your if statement
and ask is this returning a true or false value?
And honestly, it doesn't get any more complex than
that. If you've ever asked when an IF question,
you understand if statements Now let's look at
how to write an if statement with code. And we're
going to do this by using two different languages
because I think it can be really helpful for you
to see how they compare and contrast. And plus,
you'll pretty much learn two languages at once. So
on the left is the language C sharp using the it
Visual Studio, which should interest you if you
want to do windows development or want to make
games using a popular game engine called unity.
And on the right is the language Python three
using the IDA Visual Studio code which should
interest you if you want to get more into general
programming or data science. Alright, so here I
have two brand new console projects and if you
don't have To make a new console project, neither
C sharp or Python or both, be sure to check out
the video in the description. It's called How
to install an ID. And at the end of that video,
I'll show you how to do that. Alright, so today's
lab is going to be really simple and really easy,
because once I show you the Boolean secret with
if statements, you're going to get it right away,
and you're not gonna have any problems with if
statements moving forward. So just as I mentioned,
the secret that most people don't even realize
with if statements is that they're really just
bullying that will run some code block if their
value is true. But before we dig into that,
let's first look at some of the syntax differences
between C sharp and Python. Alright, so starting
with C sharp over here on the left, I'm just
gonna get rid of these two lines, because I
do not need them, they come standard with any new
console project. And I'm going to write out an if
statement. And to do that in C sharp, first thing
you need to do is just write out the word if,
and then you want to add parentheses, and
then inside these parentheses are where you
want to put your Boolean, so I'm going to put
true in C sharp, the true value is lowercase.
And then under it, I'm just going to write
out a start brace. And then in brace,
this is the code block that will run if our if
statement is true. And there you have it. This
is how you write an if statement in C sharp From
here, you can write any commands that you want in
here. So you can do like, I don't know console dot
write line if you want to. And then we can put Hi,
for example, you can put whatever you want.
And so long as this returns true, this Boolean
within the if statement in parentheses is
true, then this block of code will be ran.
Now, before we move on to Python, I just want to
mention one really important thing. If statements
in C sharp, they have to have the parentheses, and
the Boolean has to go inside of the parentheses.
If you were to remove this, you can see that we
will get a syntax error because if statements
in C sharp again have to encompass the boolean
value in parentheses. Now over in Python, the
way that the if statement works is the exact same
however, the syntax is a bit different. To write
an if statement in Python, we want to first write
out the word if, and then simply just put true.
And the true value in Python is capitalized. So
don't forget that. And then at the end, we have
to end it with the semi colon, I just want to
pause here and make this distinction. While Yes,
Python doesn't use parentheses, it uses instead
a colon. And this colon is what tells Python that
the Boolean for your if statement, it has been
completed. And so moving along to do the code
block for your if statement in Python, it's a bit
different than how C sharp does it again, the way
that we indicate a code block in C sharp is we use
the two braces starting in and we put all of our
commands in the middle of those two braces, all
which are under the if statement. But in Python,
instead, we have to go to the new line.
And we use indentations instead of braces.
So let's give an example. and here we
can just do like print. And then Hi.
And there you have it. And so the
next natural question to ask is, well,
how do I add more commands to my if statement?
Well, the answer is pretty easy. Actually,
anything that is under the if statement and is
indented in will count within that if statements
code block. So for example, I'm just going to
hit Ctrl C Ctrl V, just to give you an example.
So here are four different print functions that
are all within this if statements code block,
because they all are indented in and they're all
under this if statement. And so the next natural
question to ask is probably something like, Well,
how do I exit this code block? I mean, I don't
want my whole entire program to be dependent on
this if statement. And the answer is in Python,
indentation rules over everything. So for example,
if you want to exit out of this code block, all
you would have to do is just come down and then
return back to the regular regular indentation,
and just do print them out. For example. And just
to prove to you that this works, as I say it does,
I'm gonna hit the play button right here. And
you'll see that we get high high high amount. And
then I'm just going to set this to false to let
you to let you see that we set this to false, this
code block will not run, you weren't going to get
printed, I'm out hit the play button. And right
there all we have is I'm out. And another question
you might have is well what about if statements
within if statements like nesting if statements,
I think in C sharp, it's pretty obvious how you do
that you would just write in if another f within
an F and do another code block and you can do
another if you want to. And this can go on forever
and ever until you get tired. But in Python,
it's probably not as obvious for so I'll show
you so you just right within That code block
which again, is indented one indentation out, you
just do another if statement. True, for example,
colon, and then just another indentation.
And you just keep this format going,
as long as you need to. And here we'll do
another if statement. Hmm. Print another high.
And that's all there is to it. And here's the
very last thing that I'm going to leave you with.
So in C sharp, I'm just going to get rid of
all this just so it's a lot less confusing.
In C sharp, when you have a code block, you
can leave that code block empty, if you want,
you have no errors, no problems. C
sharp won't complain, you'll be fine.
But in Python, you can't do that.
So if I remove all of these lines,
and just have our if statement, and then we
will return in the notation after the statement.
You can see if we go to our problems here,
you see that we get an error for that.
This is not allowed, you have to put at least
something in there. So you know, if you just want
to write some if statement, just to fill it out
later. For example, you can just put a if you want
to, which does absolutely nothing. And yeah, there
you have it, guys, that's if statements for you.
I just want you to remember our little secret, the
condition that if statements checks for they're
only a Boolean, and again, the code block will run
if the Boolean returns true, and it will not run
if the Boolean returns false. And so with that,
you can create some pretty intricate and complex
bullions and then just put that Boolean right here
in the if condition from the most simplest program
to the most complex program. That is pretty
much how every program works under the hood. If
you want to learn how to better use if statements
I highly suggest you check out the Boolean lesson
that I did in that lesson I go over more detail on
how to use bullions in some real world situations
and then once you create that Boolean you can
just embed it in an if statement like this.
And yeah, that's pretty much everything you need
to know to get started programming in regards to
if statements. So at the fact that you're watching
a video on elf statements, I'm going to assume
that you know what an if statement is, or in other
words, If This Then That statement in disguise,
but if statements alone are very limited, for
example, say you build a robot to get lunch for
you, and you tell it if they have spicy jackasses,
Delia's Give me one your robot goes to get lunch,
they don't have any spicy jack case to deal us.
And so it returns not giving you anything. Now
you can't get mad at your robot because it
did exactly what you instructed it to do.
Very literally computers are very literal, but
that is where an if statements partner in crime,
the L statement comes in. Let's start with
what is an elf statement? Well, in the most
layman's definition possible, an L statement is a
conditional statement that will run if the initial
condition is not met, and they're very important
to programming. Going back to our example, an L
statement would be the equivalent to telling your
robot if they are spicy jack case, and Delia's
barmy one else give me anything, your robot
again goes get lunch, they don't have any spicy
jack case and dalias that initial condition is not
met. And so it gets you anything. And honestly,
elf statements don't get any more complex than
that. They are pretty simple concepts to get
your mind around. Now let's look at how to use the
L statement properly with code. And we're going to
do this by using two different languages because
I think it can be really helpful to see how they
compare and contrast. And plus, you'll pretty much
learn two languages at once. So on the left is the
language C sharp using the ID Visual Studio,
which should interest you if you want to do
windows development or want to make games using
a popular game engine called unity. And on the
right is the language Python three using the ID
Visual Studio code which should interest you if
you want to get into more general programming or
data science. Alright, so here I have two brand
new console projects. And if you don't how to make
a new console project neither C sharp or Python
or both. Be sure to check out the video in the
description. It's called How to install an ID. And
at the end of that video, I'll show you how to do
that. Alright, so just like the if statement lab,
this else lab is gonna be pretty quick and
easy because there's not much to it. So how
do we use an L statement? Well, the first thing
that's important to know is that l statements
are completely useless without an if statement.
They are 100% dependent on an if statement. To
demonstrate this over on the left and C sharp, I'm
just going to get rid of these two lines because I
don't need them. They come standard with every new
console project. And then I'm just gonna write out
else and then our code blocks. But you can see
that we have an error, but syntactically we did
everything right as far as syntax is concerned.
So what do we do wrong? Well, again, l statements
by themselves are completely useless. They need
an F statement to depend upon. So to fix this,
I'm just gonna come above the else statement
and write if and then let's actually do false
and then our code blocks. And then there you have
it fixed. As you can see, we're getting no errors,
we have no issues, everything is fine and dandy.
So let me explain this relationship that we have
going on here. So you have your if statement right
here, and this code block is only going to be ran
if the Boolean inside the parentheses is true,
but at the fact that it's we set it to false,
it's going to go down and do this elf statement.
So in other words, if this statement is true, that
means whatever is inside this parentheses, if this
returns true, then run this block of code, else,
run this block of code. As simple as that. And
to demonstrate this, I'm going to write to the
console. So I want to use console dot write
line. And then here, I'm going to put a plan
A, and then I'm going to come down here in the
L OS, and then write console dot write line. And
I'm gonna do Plan B. And then of course, I need
to add a console dot read key, just so that the
terminal doesn't close on us until we press a key.
Hmm. And then just for demonstration purposes,
I'm going to change this to be a true
value, then I hit the start button up here,
and bring the window over right here. And you
can see that it prints out a plan A, and again,
very intuitive. The reason is, because we said
If true, which if this whatever is inside the
parentheses is true, which we said is true, then
it's going to print out this, and at the fact that
it's true, it ignores everything after that. Now,
let's say that our if statement, Boolean returns
a false value instead, well, remember the logic,
this is checking if whatever's in this parentheses
returns true, then run this code, else. If it
doesn't, then run this code. And you can see
that Visual Studio, the ID is giving us a little
heads up that this is not going to be reachable,
because it's kind of kind of put the alpha down a
bit, it's a bit darker than the rest of the code,
which is a nice little heads up from the ID and
just demonstrate that this works. Let me hit
the start button and bring the console window
over. And you can see that it prints out plan
B, just as we expect. And now over in Python,
the L statement works the exact same however,
of course, the syntax is a bit different. And
just like the L statement in C sharp, we can't
just write an L statement by itself in Python
either. So just for example, I'm gonna put a zero
and then hit the play button. And you can see
that it returns a syntax error. And again,
the reason for this is that l statements need to
depend on an if statement. And so I'm just going
to come above the O statement and then write an
if statement, I'm going to say if false. And then
I'm going to print out what I'll just do one, yes.
And then you can see that I use the wrong false
that is false for C sharps false in Python, and
true in Python are both capitalized, trips me up
all the time. But there we fixed our l statement
error. And just to make this look just like
the program that we did in C sharp, I'm gonna
write Plan A here. And then I'm gonna write Plan
B there. And again, you can use single or double
quotes for Python, and doesn't really matter.
But just make it look cleaner, I'm gonna
use double quotes for both. And of course,
if I change this to a true value, then it's
going to give us plan A, when I hit play,
Oh, I got of course do from print. Plenty. My
mistake, let me just change this real quick
print, Plan A, and then hit play. And you see
that we get Plan A and not Plan B. And of course,
if we change this back to false, and then
hit save, and then hit the play button,
you'll see that we get Plan B instead. Because
again, it checks if this statement is true.
Do this block of code. Else do this block of
code. Simple as that. And the final thing that I
want to leave you with is that you can only have
one l statement per if statement. For example,
if you come down here in C sharp and do if
this statement, run this block of code else
from this block of code, and then we chained
to another else. You can see instantly we get
a syntax error. Because even if you think about
logic, this makes absolutely no sense. You're
saying if this is true, then run this is true. Or
else just run this and then or else run this that
it just logically doesn't even make any sense.
So that's why you can't do it. And of course
in Python, we can't do two l statements back to
back either was going to type l 's and then print
plan. gosh dang it, Plan C save hit run
See that we get a syntax here because it
makes absolutely no sense. And yeah, there
you have it. l statements are pretty handy
when paired with if statements and of
course your if statements are just regular
if statements in Jag bullions in there and
make some really powerful logical operations.
And there is everything that you need to know
to start programming in regards to L statements.
Alright, so you have if statements and you
have Elif statements, but you also have
else if statements. So starting with the first
obvious question, what is an else if statement,
so you build a robot to get lunch for you, and you
tell it if they have spicy jack case, and dalias
Give me one else give me anything,
your robot goes to get you lunch,
they don't have any spicy jack case, Delia's and
sort of returns with getting you a cheeseburger,
but you realize that the restaurant doesn't
serve french fries and now you wish that you had
something different because what's a cheeseburger
without fries and soda? Correct something like
this. You can bring in if statements other
partner in crime the else if statement. So how
does it work? Going back to our example, using the
elsif statement, you can tell your robot if they
are spicy jackasses do is give me one else, if
they serve french fries, give me a cheeseburger,
else give me anything. And with this program, you
can send your robot to any restaurant and be sure
it'll get you what you want if the conditions are
right, because if statements are pretty much just
bullions they're essentially like backup if
statements. And that's pretty much all this
to an else if statement. Now let's look at how to
use elsif statements properly with code. And we're
going to do this by using two different languages.
Because I think it can be really helpful for you
to see how they compare and contrast. And plus,
you'll pretty much learn two languages at once.
So on the left is language C sharp using it
Visual Studio, which should interest you if
you're in the windows development or want to make
games using a popular game engine called unity.
And on the right is language Python three using
the ID Visual Studio code which interests you if
you want to get into more general programming or
data science. Alright, so here I have two brand
new console projects. And if you don't how to make
a new console project and either C sharp or Python
or both, be sure to check out the video in the
description. It's called How to install an ID. And
at the end of that video, I'll show you how to do
that. Alright, so just like the L slab, the elsif
Lab is going to be pretty quick and easy. Because
again, there's not really too much to this.
So how do we use an else if statement? Well,
just like an L statement, if elsif statement is
completely dependent on an if statement without an
if statement in elsif statement is just completely
useless. And to demonstrate this over here in
the left in C sharp, I'm just going to remove
these two lines because I don't need them, they
come standard with any new console project.
And I'm just gonna write else. And then if and
then true, and then my code block. And as you
can see, we get an error because this is invalid
syntax, again, elsif statements are completely
useless without an if statement. And over in
Python, it's the same exact thing, except for the
syntax for elsif statements, it's just a little
different. So instead of else if typing that out
explicitly, you just type e L, i f, else if it's
shorten, and then you can just put true here,
and then your colon and then your logic. But even
if I were to put some logic here, let's just say
I'm gonna put zero, you can see that we get an
error, I'm going to hit play. And it tells us
that this is invalid syntax. Again, the elsif
statement by itself is completely useless. And
so to fix this, I'm just gonna come right above
our elsif statement and add an if statement to
that. So if true, then we go on to do console dot
write line. And then we're going to say Plan A,
and then I'm going to come down here and do the
same console dot write line, and then plan spell
Plan B, semi colon, who's going to do the same
thing in Python so that they are on the same spot.
Let's see true, then we want to do print planning.
Remember, indentation is really important. So
we're going to come back down here. And then
it also if that's true, they want to print
Plan B. And so what is all this same? Well,
this is saying if this statement is true,
then run this block of code. Else. If this
statement is not true, but this statement is true,
then run this block of code. And over in Python,
it works the same exact way. So we have if this
statement is true, then run this block of code
here. Else if this statement is not true, but
if this statement is true, then run this block of
code, one difference on a point output To for the
elsif statement, it's a minimal difference.
But Python really prides itself in being
like optimized in every way possible. And that
includes like how many characters you have to type
for elsif. This is only four verses over in C
sharp, you have to type seven, including the
space. Again, it's minimal, but differences or
differences. Now here is where the real power
of elsif statements comes into play. What makes
elsif statement so useful is that you can add
as many else if statements as you want, there are
no limits. So if I come over here, and just grab
this, and then hit copy, and then paste and then
paste, and then paste, you can see that we have no
errors, there's no problems, no issues, you can
do this as many times as you want. In Python,
there's no difference, you can grab this copy
and paste for example. And oops, and do this as
many times as you want. They'll do be careful with
your indentation, make sure that your indentation
is always correct. And so with that, I think it's
important to touch on the order of operation and
how important that is. So with any if statement
tree, it always will first check the first one,
if the first one is not true, then it'll go to the
next one. If the next one's not true, then it will
go to the next one, it'll keep on going blonde
down the line until it gets one that is true. So
say, for instance, this one is true, then it's
going to run this block of code, and it's going
to exit out, it's never going to even touch this
elsif statement right there. And I can demonstrate
this for you. I'll just change this to plan C
plan changes a plan D changes, plan E. And let's
say that the Boolean check here returns a false.
And then let's say this one also returns a false,
and so does this one right here? Well, what we
should expect is that it's going to check this
one, get a false elsif, check that one get a
false L. So check that one, get a false, Elsa,
check this one and get a true, and then we'll run
this block of code and should print out plan D.
And just to prove that I'm
going to hit the start button.
And then I'm going to bring oops, we forgot
to add a console. Console dot read key so that
the terminal doesn't close until we press a
button. And then I'm going to hit the start
and then bring crossover and Wallah, we have
plan D just as we expected. Now, of course,
this also works in Python, and I can prove that
to you just going to change this to see the E
did I mess up a B, C, D E is m a one over here,
either way, e f, and then we can set this one to
false. And then we can set this to
false. And we should expect again to get
to print out plan D going to hit the play
button and we see a plan D. And the last bit of
information I think will be useful for you to know
is how to incorporate the actual elf statement.
So let's say that you have some variable,
right? You have like a money variable. And you
have this first statements like if I have over,
I don't know $1,000, then do this block of
code. Else. If I have over, let's say $750,
then run this block code. If I have over 500,
run this one, if I have over 250 for example,
run this one. If I have over 100 then run this
one. And let's say that you have to print to
the console something, right? Well, if you do
all these checks, and you have $0 and you'll
never print anything, but that's where the else
statement comes back into play. All you have
to do at the very end of your if statement tree
is just simply add else. I want to do a console
dot write line. plan what is f Plan F and
that is all you got to do. Now take note
your elf statement has to be at the end of your
if statement tree. It can't be anywhere else. But
at the very end. I mean even if you think about it
logically, that's the only thing that makes sense.
And that's pretty much everything else if
statements. The final thing maybe to note is that
else if statements are no different than if
statements like this, and this are the same
exact thing. The only difference is that an else
if statement is dependent on an if statement.
You remember that simple rule and you'll have
no trouble using elsif statements and that is
everything that you need to get started
programming in regards to else if statements.
For loops, it's time to learn all about for loops.
Now, these are a very essential thing for any
programmer to know. So what is a for loop? Well,
simply put a for loop is a shortcut to run a block
of code a certain number of times. So say you have
four phone numbers, for example, and you want to
add an area code to each of them. Well, instead of
hard coding this four times phone number one plus
equals area code, phone number two plus equals
area code, phone number three plus equals area
code, etc, etc, you can just use a for loop and
write up the logic one time to get the same job
done in less lines of code. And for loops are
very powerful in this regard, because they scale
quite well. So for phone numbers isn't that bad,
you can write out phone number 1234 plus equals
area code pretty quickly. But now imagine, instead
of four phone numbers shown at area code two,
imagine that you had 4000 phone numbers, you can
imagine how redundant it would be to have to write
out phone number 1234567, all the way to 4000 plus
equals area code 4000 times. So let's take a look
at how we can use for loops to do amazing things
like this. And we're going to do so by using two
different languages because I think it can be
really helpful for you to see how they compare
and contrast. And plus, you'll pretty much learn
two languages at once. So on the left is the
language C sharp using the ID Visual Studio, which
should interest you if you're interested in doing
windows development or want to make games using
a popular game engine called unity. And on the
right is the language Python three using the IDE,
a Visual Studio code which should interest you if
you want to get into more general programming or
data science. Alright, so here I have two brand
new console projects. And if you don't know how
to make a new console, project new, the C sharp or
Python or both, be sure to check out the video in
the description. It's called How to install an ID.
And at the end of that video, I'll show you
how to do that. Alright, so for loops, for
loops are extremely useful tools in programming.
So let's jump into it starting with some syntax.
Now the syntax for for loops in C sharp can be
a bit tricky to remember. But it's not terribly
hard, you only have to remember these three
things. But first, I'm going to remove these two
lines because I don't need them that come standard
with every new console project in C sharp,
so we can just get rid of them. And this is what
you have to remember, I'm gonna write this in a
comment just so that it's easier to remember. So
a couple forward slashes for that. And so first
you write the word for, and then parentheses. And
now in these parentheses, this for loop happens
in three steps. So let's segment in by adding two
semi colons. And that last, the first thing yet
memorize is to initialize your variables variable.
I'll just shorten this to initialize because we
were going to quickly run out of room. And then
the second thing you have to remember to do is to
set your condition. And the final thing you have
to do is give a command. So long as you remember,
these three things for loops will be really easy
for you to remember. So now let's walk through an
example on how to initialize a for loop for real,
I'm just going to come down here to the next line,
and I'm gonna write out the word for. And then the
first thing I need to do is initialize a variable.
Now, the most common variable that most people
initialize at this step is actually an integer
variable called I. And you'll assign usually zero
to it. But you can assign whatever you want to it.
Actually, you can initialize any variable of any
data type that you want here, but we'll come back
to that in a bit. And so the next thing we have to
add here is the condition, which simply just asks,
How long do we want this for loop to run. And
this condition here in this space is actually
just expecting a Boolean. And so let's write a
Boolean in here. Let's say that we want to run
so long as is less than 10. Sounds good enough
to us. And then the final thing we need to add
is the command and what the command,
we simply just instruct our computer
to do something. So if we initialize an integer
named I and assign zero to it, and we're saying
that we want this for loop to run so long as is
less than 10. Then here, we can say, We want i
for every time the loop finishes to simply
just add one, using the increment operator,
it just adds one to whatever variable we added
the increment operator to. And then at last,
we just come down here and add our code block for
the for loop. And now every single time that this
loop goes through, it's going to run everything
within the code blocks, which again is every thing
that we add within these two braces, and then
at the end of it is just going to come back to
the top and then when it comes back to the top,
it's simply going to check our condition here,
it's going to ask is i less than 10? If
true, then it's going to exit here. It's
no longer gonna run this this loop anymore
and go to whatever line is right after that,
but if false Then it's going to do our command
here. And then it's going to again, run this block
of code and continue that until when it checks
here, and this is false, then again, it's going
to exit and run whatever line comes after the
for loop. And so now to do a for loop in Python,
it's actually a lot different. Python doesn't
have this syntax where you initialize a variable,
and then you set a condition and then you give
a command. It's actually, in fact, probably a
lot more simpler. But the syntax for it goes as
follows. First you want to type out the word for,
and then you want to type out I, for i in and then
you need to define a range. And let's just say
10, we're gonna use the same 10. And then you
write your colon here to start your code block.
And then here, you can put whatever commands you
want in there. Now, that's how you initialize a
for loop in both C sharp and Python. However, I
want to go back to the C sharp initialization real
quick and point out something really interesting.
Now, I think in most cases, for for loops with
this syntax, you'll find that most developers
will first initialize an int called I, and then
assign it to be zero and then do like, if and if
i is less than a certain number, then we're just
going to use the increment operator on it. But I
want to relinquish your mind early in development,
because this right here is the actual rules for a
for loop. But to understand where I'm about to go,
I think I need to first show you what's going
on with a traditional for loops. So I'm gonna do
console dot write line here. And I'm just going
to print out the value of i. And then of course,
down here, I need to write a console dot read key,
so that the terminal doesn't close on us. As soon
as we run it, I was gonna come up here, hit the
start button. And then I'm bringing the console
window overseeing see we have going on here. So
as you see, I is initialized and assigned to zero,
and then we increment increment all the way until
I is no longer less than 10. And then we exit out
the for loop. Pretty simple. But again, here it
says initialize. So we can initialize whatever
we want. Actually, this doesn't have to be an
end, we can initialize a float if you want to
run it again. And you can see that we have
the same exact result. But why stop there,
instead of using the increment operator, we can do
plus equals point five, we want to hit the start
just to show would that result and you see that we
zero then we increment plus five and then another
plus five all the way to 9.5. And of course,
that's not all, we can initialize a string if
we want to and assign that to equal empty string.
And then here our condition as long as I and then
we can grab the length by hitting dot length
of the string is less than 10. Let's just say,
then we want to do i plus equals, let's say z, for
example. And then we can run this for loop here.
Start button, bring the window over. And we can
see that it creates this interesting for loop,
the sky's the limit, so long as you follow this
convention right here. And because Python doesn't
have the syntax, you can still achieve it, but
you'd have to achieve it in other creative ways.
Also, I didn't prove it to you that this
works in Python. So I'll do that really fast.
I'm gonna do print, and then I and then I will run
this when the play button, you see that it prints
out all the digits in the range of 10. Now that's
pretty much how you go about using for loops.
Now as far as how you go about applying for loops,
that's your own creative problem solving endeavor
that I'll let you figure out on your own. However,
I will leave you with one use case. So I went
ahead and wrote out the program for our scenario,
because otherwise, it would have been a long
silence watching me type this out. But I'll walk
you through it. But first, imagine that you've
collected 700 files with a bunch of candy data on
it. And now that you have this data, you need to
get it all in one place. Now you could open up one
text file and manually add it to the other then
open up another text file and manually added and
the next and then add in next and add but that's
even exhausting for me just saying it verbally,
you could instead write a program with a for loop
to do this for you. And so first we initialize
a few variables. First one is a string array
with all the file names on it. And then
the next we have the master data string,
which we're going to compile all of our data to
and over in Python and we do the same exact thing.
We initialize a string array called filename with
700 files that can fit on there, and then our
master data string that will compile all of our
data onto and then we come down to our for loop in
which we initialize an integer named I assigned
zero to it. And then we have a condition here,
which pretty much just says so long as
I which is location in our for loop,
as long as that is less than the amount of
files that we have in the file name string
array. Then we want Want to continue looping.
And then of course, our command, we just want to
increment the integer I, and then down here in
the code block. All of this is kind of fake,
I just made it up for the scenario. But there's a
huge assumption happening here, I'm assuming that
you as the data collector, you are really good at
naming your data files. And so every single data
file that you have is named candy, space, data
space, and then whatever number of data file that
is dot txt, very important, because if your data
files are named something a bit more chaotic, then
we lose the power to use a for loop by and so
let's just say that this is you're really good
at naming your files like this. Oh, and just to
clarify, this dollar sign means that this string
is interpolated. This is an interpolated string.
If that's confusing, check out my string lesson,
I go all in depth into it Anywho, what we're
doing here is we are taking the file name array
at the element of AI, which is where we're at
in the loop. And then we're just going to assign
this file name to that location, or that element
in the file name array. And then on the next line,
I made a fake function here, where it
takes in the name of the file name, and
it's supposed to read data. But down here doesn't
do anything, but just return. So like some string
with the actual data name, but this is a real
function. It exists in a lot of libraries. But
I it's beyond the scope of this video. So just
know that this, this, this right here represents
something that really does happen. And so we
pass the file name to the read data function,
the read data function will open up the text
file rewear was on there. And then we will add
that to our master data string. And then over in
Python, we do the same exact thing. We have a for
loop here for i in range length of filename, just
to break apart what this means really quick. So
length function, it returns a number of items
in a container. And so this file name is a list
with 700 items in it. So when we run length of
filename, it's going to return 700. So for i
in range of 700, will be our for loop. And then we
come on down into our code block. And here, again,
we have our file naming convention that we're just
going to assume that you're good at labeling data.
Every file is named Kenny data, and then whatever
the number is, but it doesn't start at zero,
it starts at one, so we have to add one to
our I because I does start at zero dot txt.
And then we just assign that to our filename list
at the element of AI, again, that lives from zero
all the way to 700. And this is going to match
up because they're both using eyes here and here.
And then finally, we made a fake function called
read data, it doesn't really do anything except
for return Kenny data from and then whatever
the name of the file is, but we will run that
function pass in the file name. And let's say
this was a real world scenario, then this would
open up whatever that txt file is grab the data
from that. And then we would add that to our
master data string. And then finally, we come down
here, and then we'll print the master data. And
just to prove that these work, I'm going to come
up here and hit the start button, C sharp, and
bring the window over and you can see that we have
all this candy data. Look at all that candy data.
Wow. Then I'm come up here in Python and hit
the play button and error. Oh, right, right.
So Visual Studio code has a really weird, well,
it's not weird, it's helpful. But if you have
something selected and you hit the play button,
then it's just going to run that. So almost like
nothing and then hit the play button. And there
you go. You can see that a generates all that
data. Wow. And yeah, there you have it. This is
one creative use case in which for loops can be
really helpful. But there are a ton of different
for loop use cases. But it would take me all day
to sit here and list out a bunch of different
ones, but you now know how to write your own
four loops. So now you can think of really
interesting ways yourself to apply for loops. And
that is everything that you need to know to get
started with programming in regards to for loops.
Let's talk about while loops. while loops are a
type of loop obviously, and they share a lot with
a for loop except instead of running a block
of code a number of times it runs a block of
code while a certain condition is true, hence the
name while loop you'll find that while loops are
a lot less common for loops, but every once in
a while you'll find the perfect use for a while
loop. So for for loops. For instance, when I make
any sort of robotics project I find while loops
very handy to use anywho. Let's take a look at how
to use while loops with code. And we're going to
do this using two different languages because I
think it can be really helpful for you to see how
they compare and contrast and plus, you'll pretty
much learn two different languages at once. So
on the left is language C sharp using the ID e
Visual Studio which should interest you if you
want to do windows development or want to make
games using a popular game engine called unity
and on the right is the English Python three
using the ID Visual Studio code, which should
interest you if you want to get more into general
programming or data science. Alright, so here I
have two brand new console projects. And if you
don't know how to make a new console project,
neither C sharp or Python or both, be sure to
check out the video in the description. It's
called How to install an ID. And at the end of
that video, I'll show you how to do that. Alright,
so while loops, Now today's labs can be pretty
short, because there's not really a lot to while
loops. But let's start by looking at the syntax
for a while loop in C sharp over here on the left,
I'm going to get rid of these two lines because I
don't need them. And they come standard with every
new console project. And I'm simply going to write
out while and then in parentheses true. And then
our code block. This is the syntax for a while
loop in C sharp, you essentially just write
while and then you have to pass in a Boolean
here. And then you ever code blocks and where
you can put all of your demands that will continue
running over and over and over. While this Boolean
is true. And over in Python, a while
loop looks like this while and then true.
And then I'm just going to put pass here in
our code block past just pretty much means
don't do anything. And this is the syntax for
a while loop in Python. Pretty simple. Now one
extremely important thing that you need to know
about while loops is that while a while loop is
running, whatever comes after the while loop. So
if I come down here, for example, into a console,
console dot write line, for
example. And then reach,
for example, anything that comes after a while
loop will not be reached until the while loop
has been completed. And again, the reason for
this is because when you run a while loop,
it just runs whatever the code is in its code
blocks over and over and over however many lines
there are, it goes one by one by one. And then
once it reaches the end, it starts over the top
and continues going until this boolean value
here is no longer true. Once this is false,
then it will stop doing this loop and then go
to the next lines after the while loop. And
this process also happens in Python. If I just
come down here and do print and then reached,
for example, this while loop will keep on doing
every single line in this code block until this
condition here is false. And if it's never false,
then guess what this code right here will never be
reached. And I can prove that. But first I need
to set up a couple of variables, I'm going to
come up here and then I'm going to initialize an
integer. Let's just call it a why not, and also
t equals zero. And so within this boolean value,
all we have to do is say if a is less than 100,
then we want you to run and then every
single time to run, we can simply just do a
plus plus, use the increment operator.
And then let's also do a console
dot write line. And just just print out the actual
integer value. And so what's going to happen here
is that when our main program is ran, it's going
to go down the line and then hit our while loop.
And because A is less than 100, it's going to
run this block of code one time, you know plus to
a and then write it out. And then it's going to
reach the end and do it again. And then again
100 times until a is no longer less than 100.
Once it's greater than 100 or equal to then
this will no longer run and then they'll go
to our right line reached right here. And we can
print it out. And I can prove it to you. But first
I need come down here and do a console dot read
key. So the terminal doesn't close on us when we
hit the start button up here. And I'll
bring the window over. And as you can see,
we get results that we expect to get the while
loop will run over and over and over until it's
Boolean condition is no longer true. And once
it's false, then finally the while loop will
exit it goes to the next line. And then on that
that line after it we have the printout reached
which there it is at the end of the while loop.
And over in Python. This is done the same exact
way just in the Python syntax. So to set that up,
I'm simply going to come up here. Oops, what did
I just do? Oops, I think I Yep, collapse that.
Okay, come up here I'm gonna do a equals zero.
And then while a is less than 100, and then
instead of pass, we're gonna print just whatever
A equals and so not approve that they work the
same. I'm hit the play button up here. And as
you can see, we have Oh, we forgot to increment,
right? I'm simply going to increment a up here
to a plus equals one. And now our code should
be fixed, I hit the play button, and bada boom,
there you have it, same exact scenario as in C
sharp. And finally, there's one more way that you
can go about stopping a while loop. And that's by
using the break statement. So first question, what
is the break statement? Well, the break statement
is a statement that can only be used with loops,
like for loops, and while loops. And when you use
the break statement, all it does is just breaks
that loop moving on to the next line after the
loop. So to demonstrate this, I'm going to replace
this Boolean right here with just a regular
Boolean, true value. And then I'm going to go into
here and write an if statement. So now I'm
gonna say if a is greater than or equal to 100,
then what we want to do is break. And to prove
this works, I'm coming here to the play button,
hit start, and then bring the window over.
And you can see that it works exactly the same
as the other method. And to do this method
in Python, I'm simply going to replace this
Boolean with the true boolean value. And then I'm
going to come down here and do if A is, is greater
than or equal to 100, oops, 100, then we want to
break, gonna hit that play button up here to prove
that it works. And you see that we have the same
exact thing, probably didn't even notice that it
changed. And that's why it was for you. They can
be handy in certain situations. But to be honest,
you will probably more often be using for loops.
And there you have it. That is everything that you
need to know to get started with programming in
regards to while loops. It's finally time to talk
about methods. So methods are amazing programming
tools that simply put allow you to not have to
repeat code over and over and over. And to be able
to get a better grasp on your code. For instance,
say you have some inventory class. And in this
inventory class, you have a few things that
can happen, you can close the inventory, you can
open the inventory, you can empty the inventory,
just to give a few examples. And instead of
having to change a list of inventory variables,
every time you want to do these things, you can
just wrap all this code into a method and just
call that method whenever you want to do it saving
you a lot of time from writing the same code over
and over and saving you from future headache.
So now let's take a look at how to use methods
with code. And we're going to do this using two
different languages. Because I think it can be
really helpful for you to see how they compare
and contrast. And plus, you'll pretty much learn
two languages at once. And so on the left is
language C sharp using the IDE, a Visual Studio,
which should interest you if you want to do
windows development or want to make games
using a popular game engine called unity. And on
the right is the language Python three using the
it Visual Studio code, which should interest you
if you want to get into general programming or
data science. Alright, so here I have two brand
new console projects. And if you don't how to
make a new console project and either C sharp or
Python or both, be sure to check out the video in
the description. It's called How to install an
ad. And at the end of that video, I'll show you
how to do that. So before we can use methods,
we first have to learn how to initialize them.
So let's take a look at their syntax first over
on the left and C sharp, I'm just going to get
rid of these two lines because I don't need them.
And then I'm going to come down here so that we
can initialize a new method and the syntax for
that goes as follows. You simply just type out
void, and then whatever name you want for your
method, I'll just call it ABC, for example. And
then you need to put a start in parentheses. And
then finally, is simply just add a code block.
And now you can put whatever commands you want
within this code block. For example, I'm just
going to put console dot write line, and pizza,
because pizza is the best. And there we have
initialized a method. Now to do this in Python,
it's just a little different, but the concept
is still the same. So to initialize a method in
Python, you want to type out instead of void,
you want to type out def, def, and then whatever
name for your method or isn't called again, ABC.
And then you're gonna do your start in
parentheses, this convention stays the same.
But instead of going to a new line and doing code
blocks using the braces, you simply just use a
colon here, and then go to next line and make
sure that it's indented. I'm using the Visual
Studio Code ID, which automatically adds an indent
for me when I go to next line. Well now just like
in C sharp, I can add whatever commands I want in
this code block. So I'm going to write out prints.
And then again, pizza, because pizza is the
best. So that's how you initialize a method
in most C sharp and Python. But without more
context, I don't think they're that helpful.
So let's take a step back and examine a scenario.
So imagine that you're writing some sort of
program with an inventory system that has three
spaces, and this program requires you to swap out
what's in those three spaces quite a lot. So just
to make is less confusing, I'm going to get rid of
our initial examples on both Python and C sharp.
And now I'm just going to pretty much set up that
scenario with some variables. So I went ahead and
wrote the scenario off screen, because otherwise
it probably would have been about five minutes of
silence. But I'll walk you through it. So up here,
we have all of our string variables. This is
our inventory standing for I envy slot, one,
two, and three Python as the same. And we first
set them all to be empty. And then we have a
couple of items we can pick up under the variable
name, pickup, one, two, the first one is pizza,
because pizza is the best. And then we have candy.
And of course, Python has the same exact thing
going on there. Next, we just have a couple of if
statements to kind of simulate an event happening,
let's say that you want to pick up some items.
Well, first, you want to check to see if it's
empty. And then if it's empty, then you pick it
up. Same thing happening here in Python. Okay,
so we have our scenario all set up, I'm just
going to come down here and add a console
dot write line, so we can print out the
results here. Let's print out first in Vin one.
And then I'm lazy, I'm just gonna do Ctrl C
Ctrl, V, copy paste a couple more times, and
print out also in Vin two and inven. Three. And
I'm, of course, gonna come over here and Python
do the same exact thing, except for the syntax a
bit easier. In Python, I can just do inven, one,
there, and then comma, and one, two, and comma in
vim three, a much more simplistic print function
Python has now before we run it, what should we
expect? Well, again, all of our inventory, slots,
stuff is empty. And then we come down here and
do a check if the first slot is empty, then we're
going to assign the pickup one to Inventory Slot
one, which is pizza. And then we do another check.
If Inventory Slot three is empty, then we'll
assign the pickup to to it, which is candy. So
all we should expect is pizza, empty candy. Let's
see if we get that just gonna come up here and hit
the start button. Oh, that's going to close on us.
I forgot to add, of course, console dot read key.
Alright, so again, I'm just gonna come up here and
hit the start button and bring the window over.
And you can see that we have an Inventory Slot
one pizza, slot two empty and slot three candy.
Perfect. Gonna run that in Python as well hit the
play button up here. And you see we got pizza,
empty candy. Perfect. Okay, so this isn't
bad. This is pretty straightforward,
does exactly what we want. But now
imagine this scenario where when you
assign a new item in your inventory, it doesn't
only just change that item slot. Maybe also,
you know, it does some UI stuff
here. And then it does like some
special effects was that I'm saying v effects,
and then maybe like updates, other like update.
slot one, for example, Inventory Slot
one also updates inventory, slot two,
slot two, for example. And this does this happens
for every time that you want to do this, right.
So I'm gonna copy this and bring this down here.
And you can see that our code is starting to get
long and kind of strenuous. Now, this is where one
of the use cases for methods come back into play.
The first advantage to using methods is having
the ability to compress your code. Now, why would
we want to do that? Well, everything within the
code blocks have this main function right here
is our main program. And over in Python, just
for comparison, every line in the script counts
as your main program. But as you add more code
in the main program gets longer and longer,
it can become more and more confusing and
difficult to read and understand. And so instead
of having this chunk of code or this chunk of
code, we can convert that into a method and just
call that method in our main program. And so let's
do that. And to do that, I'm first going to come
over to our first chunk of code, and essentially
encapsulated inside of a method. So right above
it, I'm going to add a start brace comes to the
bottom of it at an end brace and Visual Studio
automatically reformats to it for me, thank you
Visual Studio, and then I can simply add our void.
And then we can now get to the hardest part in all
of programming. Now, we have to name our method,
which thankfully, I thought of all this ahead
of time, so you don't have to watch me struggle,
but I'm gonna call it pick up pizza. I won. And
then of course, our parentheses, close it out.
We already did our code block ahead of time.
And there you go, we have converted this to
a method successfully. Now I'm just gonna do
the same thing for our second chunk of code.
Just a bit different in my process
here, pick up what is this candy
and i three that do that. Oops. We're going to
get rid of this. And then we'll use the bottom
automatically formats. Thank you. Visual co
And there we have it. And over in Python again,
let's say that when you pick up something,
you also do like some UI stuff and
some visual effects. And you also do, you know,
you update whatever information you need update
and slot, one of your inventory, you also
update whatever's going on. And slide two,
for example, so on and so forth. I'm just gonna
copy this and bring this down to this one as well
fixed the format a bit. And you can see the
script got a lot longer. So let's convert those
into methods. Now, you already know the syntax
for methods in Python, we simply just replace
void with def, and then we name our
variable is going to be pick up pizza,
Inventory Slot, one, starting in parentheses, and
then our semi colon. And then we have come down to
all of this and then hit the tab button so that
this counts as a code block for that method. And
let's do the same exact thing for our second
chunk of code. def, what is it pick up candy,
inventory, three, starting in parentheses, and
then our colon, and then come down to all these
lines and indent the man. So they count as a
code block for this method. Now, we need to
pause if you take a look at our inventory, three
variable, and even our inventory one variable,
they are underlined red, which means that we have
a problem, it would come down to our console and
press problem, we see that word is telling
us that these variables are not assigned.
What's going on here? Well, this has to do
with something called scoping. And Python
is very peculiar about your scoping to simplify,
this block of code is self contained only within
this method, pick up pizza inventory one, he
doesn't have any reference to anything outside
of this code block. And of course, same goes for
this code block as well. So one simple thing we
can do to let these code blocks know that there is
a variable called iron v one outside of its scope,
which again, is this, we can simply just come at
the top of it, and then type global and then I
N v one. Same down here, we can type global,
and then type ion v three, and you can see our
problems are gone. Problem solved. What we can
do now to compress our code is grab all of these
lines here, which contained both of our methods.
And I'm going to hit Ctrl x or cuts. And I'm
going to now move this to the bottom of our
entire program at the very end, and D realize
what just happened, pretty much our program
ends here. So everything before that is our actual
program, look how much shorter that is. And over
in Python, we can do the same exact thing. I'm
going to select all these lines that have our
two methods here, hit Ctrl, x or cuts. And then
I'm going to move that up. And then underneath
our print function, I'm going to hit Ctrl V
or paste and put that underneath. And again,
right here, our program ends here, much, much
shorter. However, our code is now compressed. Yes,
but we aren't completely done yet. Over in
C sharp and the left, you can see that if I
hit the start button up here on top and
bring the window over, you can see that
our entire inventory is still empty. And the
same goes for Python, if I hit the play button,
you can see that we have empty, empty, empty. And
the reason for that is because at no point did we
call our methods. And to do that in C sharp over
here on the left, all you have to do is simply
just write out the name of your method. So our
first one, we want to do pick up pizza for one.
And then you also need to include your Start
and End parentheses. This is what denotes that
it's a method. And then we need to do pick up
candy inventory, i three started in parentheses,
and then our semi colon. And to prove to you that
this works, like I say it does, I'm gonna hit the
start button, and then bring the window over
and you can see that they have now been set,
check that out. Now over in Python, it's actually
quite different, although the concept is still
the same. So earlier, I moved off our methods
to the bottom of our Python script. But if we
were to come into the middle of our program,
and then type out, pick up, what is it pizza
item one, and then start in parentheses and then
run our program, you'll see that we get an error
because pizza pickup pizza item one is not defined
yet, or inventory one rather, is not defined yet.
And so a truth about Python is revealed. using
methods in this context isn't really all that
useful because the order of operation is extremely
important in Python. So to use our methods,
we have to initialize them before we call them For
the first time in our scripts, but also after we
initialize the variables that we're using within
them. And where's that sweet spot you ask? Well,
it's right here. And so I'm just going to select
all these lines that contain our methods. And
then I'm gonna hit Ctrl, X to cut and then Ctrl
V to paste. And there you have it. And just to
prove that everything is exactly what it needs
to be, I'm gonna hit the play button up here in
Visual Studio code. And you can see that we get
pizza, empty, empty, hold on, That's not right.
Of course, the reason for that is we have to
call the second pickup as well pick up candy
I three star in parentheses at the save the play
button, and voila, we got pizza, empty candy.
Okay, so that was one use case for methods. But I
want to show you another one, I'm gonna start by
removing all the code that we did, and C sharp and
Python so that we can set up a new scenario. By
now imagine that you have some program with some
sort of boss battle in it. And every time that
you successfully hit the boss, two things or more
happen, so I'm just going to quickly code up this
scenario. Alright, so I went ahead and code up
the scenario off screen, because otherwise would
have been another couple of minutes of silence,
but I'll walk you through it. So here we have a
few integers initialize, we have my HP the enemy
HP and some money, then we have some Boolean to
check if we hit legs, arms or head, set them
all to be true. And then we simply have some
if statements to check for those volumes. And if
any of them are true, then we simply will minus HP
from the boss and then add some money to our bank
account. And Python does the same exact thing.
Same variables might be in PHP and money, and then
some hit legs, hit arm and hit head bullions. And
we simply check those blades. And if they're true,
then again, we're going to minus HP from the enemy
and add some money to our bank account. And that's
all it's to it. And so the next advantage that
methods could give you is reducing repetition, if
you haven't already observed, and both scripts,
we have this chunk of code right here, enemy HP
minus equals one, and money plus equals five. And
this is repeated over and over three times each
on both scripts. And I mean, that's fine. In all,
I mean, this will do exactly what you expect it
to do. However, we have this rule in programming,
and it goes as follows. never write the same
code twice. In addition, imagine that you want to
add something else to these hit events. Like for
example, let's say that you wanted to take your HP
and add a little healing for every successful hit,
right. So you would come down here and do my HP
plus equals two, for example. But the problem
is that you now have to write this for every
single hit event. So my HP plus equals to
go to the next one, again, my HP whoops,
my HP plus two equals two. Now there is a clear
pattern here. And there's no reason for you to
repeat this over and over and over again. And
so let's bring back methods, all we have to do
at the end of our main function here is write out
void and then name our function, let's call it
I'll just call it hit event. Sounds good
enough to me open starting in parentheses,
and then come down here and your code block.
And let's just write all this out. Any PHP
minus equals one, perfect money, plus equals
five, and then my HP plus equals two. And
so now all we have to do is simply just remove
all of these and replace them with hit events.
Starting in parentheses, semi colon, and bottom
being do that for all other spaces as well.
And do hit events. Start in parentheses,
semi colon, oops, get rid of that line.
And then of course here as well hits
events about bomba bomb and bada bing.
And there you have it, we have greatly
reduced our repetition. And of course,
just to prove to you that all this works,
and we come to the end of our script here,
which again, ends right before our method is
called. So in script, and then I'm going to add a
console dot write line. And we really just want
to know all of our variables, so enemy HP, and
then I'm lazy. So I'm gonna hit Ctrl, C Ctrl, v
a couple times and then replace this with money.
And then replace this with my HP. Come up here,
hit the start button. Up, it's going to close
Of course, we have to hit console that read key
always forget this. Probably a bit. So use the
Python, hit play, bring the window over and you
can see that we have our calculations. I mean,
there's not going to confirm that they're what
they are, but trust me, it's working and now over
in Python, this technique has a lot of benefits,
but it's still limited to the order of operation.
And so again, to implement this in Python, we
simply just go after our variables that we're
using are initialized. But before we call it,
which that sweet spot is right here, and so we can
do def, what do we call it? I forget hit event,
hit events, and then start in parentheses there.
And then I forgot some, just regular colon. In our
code block, we can just bring in this right here,
I'm lazy. So I'm just copy and pasted by being and
then we can replace all of these with hit events.
And then I'm going to copy this because I am
lazy and copy this as well, because I'm lazy. And
you can see that we have our issue again, and
you can see that we have our scoping issue again.
And you can see that we have our scoping issue
again. And you can see that we have our scoping
issue again. And to fix this, all we have to do is
just again, add our global, and then we need what
enemy, HP and money. Perfect. And so now to prove
all this works, I'm just simply going to repeat
what we did in C sharp and do print and PHP. And
then we also want to print our money. And then
we also want to print our my HP. I boom, except
for the HP Of course, because we didn't add that.
But it's a lot easier to add things. Now, instead
of having to go through every single event, we
just go to the actual hit event method. And then
we can do my HP plus equals to I believe it was
I'm just double check here. Yes, it was too. And
we need to set that as a global as well to grab
that from our scripts. And then I can hit
play again. And you can see that we have the
same exact variables 2715 and 16. And there you
have it for reducing repetition with methods.
Now, I just want to show you one last technique
with methods and that is returning values. To do
this. Again, I'm just going to get rid of all
the code that we did already sing with Python.
And now imagine this scenario. And so I went
ahead and wrote this scenario of code off camera,
because otherwise, this probably would have
been about a 10 minute silence. But as always,
I'll walk you through it First, consider the
scenario that you're developing some app or some
social media or something like that. And you want
to generate a user ranking for all of your users.
Now, what's going on in our program isn't really
important at all, honestly. But here we have our
user rank variable. And let's say that we want
to generate this user rank using these variables
here. Well, I just came down here and just made
a pretty big tree, and did a bunch of checks.
So if guests then minus something if page, plus
something else. Plus, if this is all arbitrary,
I just want to make a really big tree to
demonstrate this next example. So let's just say
that all of this right here, actually starting
here, all this right here is like an algorithm
that you and your social media your app team has
developed. And you guys have concluded that it's
a very accurate way to assess the user ranking of
your users. Well, instead of having this algorithm
hard coded for a single variable, we can convert
this algorithm into a method and have that method
return a value. And so to do that, we only need to
do two things. First, let's convert this algorithm
into a method. Now, this is still hard coding our
user rank variable. This is no different than just
a regular method. So what we need to do next is
we need to create a temporary variable and we'll
call it actually temp, and then let's set its
equals zero. And then we need to change all the
user ranks to be timps. Or the temp variable, my
apologies. So I must say temp here, use a rank.
I'm gonna go right here temp and then use rank
here is also temp. And then use rank here is also
temp and then use rank here is also Tim
Hahn this user rank is temp is well.
And this final one is to at last No, we have to
do is come to the end of our method, and then do
return tip. Now, you'll see that we will get an
error here. And the reason for this, it requires
a bit of explanation. So when you initialize
methods, you are also casting its data type.
And so if we check out our score method, you can
see the data type for our score method is a void,
which is essentially data type lists. So our score
made through essentially just go through its code
block, run that and then exit out but if we wanted
to return data of some type, all we have to do is
replace this with that data. Type. And seeing that
our use rank is a float, we're going to replace
this with a float. And you see our error has
disappeared. And so what does that allow us to do?
Well, I'm going to do our convention, our
program ends here. And then I'm gonna go
down and find these two things, and then Ctrl X to
cut them, and then put them before programmings.
And now all we have to do is just assign a score
to our user rank variable. Isn't that nice? And
let's say that we have another user rank that
we want to calculate, right? This is easier rank
two equals zero. Well, all we have to do
now is just go user rank two equals score.
And nowhere in Python, we can do the same
exact thing, just first wrap our algorithm here
into a method was called score. And do that and
then now we need to select the entire algorithm,
and then hit the tab button. So that is all within
the code block for a score. And then because
it's a method, hopefully something broke here,
what broke here. Now I'm not entirely sure what
happened here. But to fix this, we simply just add
a tab fix the syntax, error disappears. Perfect.
Next, we'll add back in our temp variable.
Let's just initialized this temp equals zero.
And then was replace all the user ranks with
temp. I'm just gonna copy and paste because I am
pretty lazy right now. temp, temp, temp, temp,
temp, to temp. And then at last we just come
out I think this is it. Return tip seven double
check, this is the right place to put it. Yes,
it is. Now again, because this is Python,
this method isn't that useful for compression,
again as to be in that sweet spot. But we can get
our user ranking simply by calling user rank and
then assigning score to it. And so now to prove
to you that these do exactly as I say they do,
over here in C sharp and left, I'm just gonna
copy and paste this right line, because I'm lazy,
then added to there. And then we have read key. So
now I'm gonna hit the start button. And then I'm
gonna bring the window over. And you can see that
we have 49 and 49. And to prove the same thing to
you in Python, I'm just gonna initialize a
new user rank here, use rank two, and that
also equals score two. So we have the same exact
scenario. And then we're praying user rank two.
And then I'm gonna hit the play button up
here, you see we have 49, and 49. And yeah,
there you have it. If you want to learn more
about methods, I think the best thing that you
can do is just to start using them more, because
you'll learn more about them in the process.
But that is everything that you need to get
started with programming in regards to methods,
functions functions, let's step into the wonderful
world of functions. Now I'll just go on record
saying this functions are hands down the most
valuable tool to program. Now, why is that? Well,
functions share a lot of commonality with methods
for they allow you to be able to reuse code giving
you the ability to write more neat and nice
code, which in effect makes it easier to read
giving you a better grasp on your code. But the
advantage that functions have over methods is
that you can pass in data and slightly alter
the code that is ran within a function making
them extremely powerful. So for example, say you
have an inventory class that can hold four items
and you want to remove the items. Well, instead of
creating four different methods that you can call
to remove the for various items, inventory dot
remove item one, inventory dot remove item two,
so on and so forth. That will all run the same
exact code minus may be a variable or two with
functions you can pass in, for example,
the item number and using the same code
can remove that item. Now talking about
the theory of functions is great and all
but let's take a look at how to use functions
practically with code because I promise this will
become so much easier to understand. And we're
going to do this using two different languages
because I think it can be really helpful for you
to see how they compare and contrast. And plus,
you'll pretty much learn two languages at once.
So on the left is the language C sharp using the
ID Visual Studio, which should interest you if
you want to do windows development or make games
using a popular game engine called unity. And on
the right is language Python three using the IEEE
Visual Studio code which should interest you if
you want to get into more general programming or
data science. Alright, so here I have two brand
new console projects and if you don't how to make
a new console project and either C sharp or Python
or both. Be sure to check out the video in the
description. And it's called How to install an ad.
And at the end of that video, I'll show you how to
do that Paul Wright, who's ready to have some fun
with some functions. Now before we can do that, we
need to go over the syntax for functions in both
C sharp and Python over on the left and C sharp,
I'm going to get rid of these two lines, they
come standard with every new console project,
but I don't need them. And then in this code
block, I'm going to initialize a function,
which, if you're familiar at all, with methods,
this is going to seem very familiar to you,
I'm just going to type out void, and then the
name of our function, which is called F for now,
and then start in parentheses. Now, if you're
familiar at all, with methods, you're probably
looking at this and you're like, Wait a second,
that's just the method what's going on here. And
yes, you're right methods and functions have a
lot of overlap. But what makes functions super
cool and extremely useful is that you can pass
in some input. So if I type in right here, if I
initialize an int, and then I'm a call this x, for
f of x, that's a standard notation for functions,
I can now make my code block here. And we can do
something with this input within the code block.
For example, let's say that we want to take our
input x, and we simply just want to times it by
two. So I'll use the multiplication operator and
then times it by two. And then to see this change,
let's come down here and add a console dot write
line just to print to the console. And then we're
going to put in here our x variable. Well, now
we can do something cool with this function,
if I just come to the beginning of the script,
and then I'm going to initialize an integer,
I'm going to call it, I don't know my number,
for example. And then let's make it nine. And
so now I just want to call F and then pass in my
number, which is nine. And what it's going to do
is it's going to take my number in this function,
and then here is just going to times by two and
printed out. And to prove that to you, I'm going
to come right underneath our function and add a
console dot read key, so that the terminal doesn't
close on us. As soon as we run it, hit the start
button, and our terminals over here. And you see
that nine times two does in fact, equal weighting.
Now in Python, the syntax is a bit different. I'm
just gonna start off by initializing our integer,
my num, assign a nine to it. And then our, our
function has to come before we actually call it.
So I'm going to initialize that, first,
I'm gonna say def, with the name F,
and then we're in past nine input x, and then I'm
using a colon here, go down into the code block,
and then I'm going to do X times equals to
no different than what we did in C sharp,
and then simply just print out whatever x is,
then lastly, we can just call our f function
by saying F and then passing in my
num, knowing my num when I do my num,
and there you have it, I'm gonna press the
play button just to prove to you this works.
And bada boom, you see the web 18. Now, we just
barely scratched the surface with functions.
But hopefully, you can already see how much power
we have with just this very simple example. Allow
me to show you one more example. Before we move
on. Imagine that we have a list of names and we
want to add Mr. or Mrs to the beginning of those
names, well, we can simply get rid of this integer
no longer need that. What else do we don't need,
we actually don't need this function anymore. So
we don't need this will keep the console actually
let's just get rid of the whole entire program and
start over from scratch and do the same for
Python. So let's initialize a string array.
Let's call it a name. And then that
equals a new string array of size.
Let's Let's initialize sizes to make it simple.
And then we can come in here and manually set
the variables within our array. So I'll do
zero equals, let's say his name is Johnny.
And then let's say that name of
element one is equal to Carla.
And then name of element two
is equal to let's just say that
Zack, and I suppose Zack, thank you. So now let's
write out our function that will do this process
for us. I'm going to come down here and I'm going
to do a void and then let's call it surname,
I believe they're surnames. And then
we can pass in. Let's see, a string
and this is going to be It was
called sir as the variable.
And so now we can do down here name
of zero equals sir, plus name of zero.
And then of course, let's let's print this
out so that we can see what's going on console
dot write line. So what I'm looking
for, and we can print out name of zero.
Come on, there we are. And then we can call
our surname here. And then let's pass in
Mr. Mr with the space there. And then of course,
console dot read key. So a terminal doesn't close
on us. Also, I'm just going to write right here,
just because it's fun to make the distinction that
our program is here. And so I went ahead and
wrote out the program in Python, so you don't
have to sit and listen to my silence for a couple
of minutes. But it does the same exact thing. We
have the nameless here that is initialized
with Johnny Carla and Zach in it. And then
we initialize our surname function that takes the
input of sir. And we essentially just assign sir,
plus the name of element zero, to name
velleman, zero, so we essentially reassign it,
and then we print it out. And here is when we
call the actual function itself. And so if I just
come up here to the play button and press it, you
can see that again, we have Mr. Johnny except for
I put the period in the wrong spot supposed to
go there, press it again, bada boom. Alright,
cool. So now we have a surname function that adds
a certain name to our names, however, we have
three names. And I really don't want to have to
write three different functions just to do this.
Well, thankfully, we don't have to, thanks to
this next feature that further makes functions
even more powerful. So there is no real limit on
how many inputs we can pass in with our function.
And at the fact that we're using an array here,
we can just pass an integer to change whatever
element in the name array that we want. And so to
do that, I'm just going to add an integer variable
at the beginning here, we'll call it, I'm just
calling ind for index. And then we can simply
just replace this zero here with ind whatever,
integer we pass in i n d again, and then i n d.
And lastly, we just come up here and
then just pass in the zero. So we want
to change the zero element in the name array,
which corresponds to Johnny run that again,
by hitting the play button at the top here, bring
the console window over, and you can see nothing
has changed. And so now that we have this add
to flexibility, I can simply take this line, and
copy and paste, copy and paste, copy and paste,
and just change the index to one which is Carla,
and two, which is Zack. And of course, Carla is
not a mystery. So we can change that to a message
here. And when we run this, it's going to print
out all three of them. So I'll just press the
play button again, and bring the window over. And
would you look at that, and Mr. Johnny, Mrs. Carla
and Mr. Zack function is working perfectly. And
over in Python, we can do the same exact thing.
So I'm gonna pass in an input variable here
called ind again, separate them with the comma
that's important for both syntaxes separate your
variables with commas. And then we can replace
all of the element numbers here with ind, and then
just pass an integer in when we call the function
we get there. Right here. So Mr. Zero. And then of
course, we can do copy, paste, paste. And then one
and two. Carlos misses the Save button clears
all errors, then hit the play button. And would
you look at that Mr. Johnny, Mrs. Carla, and Mr.
Zack, I'll never stop saying this. But functions
are the greatest thing there is high love
functions. And if you think that it stops there.
Well, you're in for a bit of a surprise. But
first, let me introduce a problem to you say
that we want to come down to the bottom of
our program and initialize a new string,
right? And the name here. Let's just say
this is the boss's name, and it equals Helen.
And now what if we wanted to add a surname to
Helens name? Well, because this surname function
is directly tied to the name array. We kind of
can't at the moment, I mean, of course, we could
just come in here and just add it manually, Mrs.
Helen, or we could remove this and then just come
down to the next line and do something like bossy
cool. What is it Mrs. Plus boss here. And then we
also want to do a console dot Yeah, we could redo
the same code over if we really wanted to imagine
that you were doing this as an automated task,
well, you wouldn't want to manually go and add the
surname to all the names that you have. And you
wouldn't really want to rewrite the code over and
over and over. And so the solution to this problem
is by changing this function from being a variable
dependent function into a variable, independent
function, and we can do that by using the return
statement. And so to do that, first I'm gonna get
rid of these two lines, because they're just for
an example. And then I'm gonna go into our surname
function, and we're going to return a string. So
I'll initialize a string, I'll call it temp, and
then I'll sign it to be an empty string for now.
And now we have to replace all of the variable
references to the name array into the temp,
because this is what makes this function variable
dependent. So I'm gonna change this here to temp.
And then I will change this one to temp as well.
And then I'm gonna change this here to temp. And
actually, because we need an input with the
original name is we actually don't need to
initialize this here. So I'm going to get rid
of that line. And we can now change our integer
variable input into a string variable input
and call it temp. And so the very last thing
we need to do here is we need to change the data
type of our function from a void to be a string.
And then you'll see we get an error
saying that it doesn't return a value.
When you cast the data type on your functions,
they have to return the same type of data type
in the return. So we'll go down here and add,
return and temp is a string. So we'll just return
back the temp which has been modified with sir
at the beginning. And so now because we change
the input to surname from the data type integer
to string, you can see that we have three errors
here. For the times that we called it, these
are currently integers, they need to be strings,
which is no problem, we can just input the
actual name that we want to change here. So
of course, the first one is name of element zero,
and I'm lazy. So I'm gonna copy and paste this,
paste and paste and change this to one and two,
which again corresponds here. And if I just hit
save, and then the Start button up here, and then
bring the console, you can see that absolutely
nothing has changed function works exactly the
same. However, the very last thing that we have
to do to make this completely functional is,
again, right here, it's printing out the temp,
so this is only temporary, we get a reference
to that, and then we change it and then we
return it. But you can see here that's that's
not being assigned to anything. So that's the
final thing that we have to do here. But before
we do to further illustrate my point, I'll simply
come at the bottom here and do a console dot write
line. And then we're going to print out name zero,
and then I will copy paste few times because
I'm lazy, changed to one in two. And so if
I come up here and hit the start button and
bring the console and over you can see that
yes the certain names are added for the first
three which is what is inside the actual surname
function. But the last three that were printed
which is outside the surname function is the
actual ground truth to are named of zero element
name of one element and name of two elements
are still the same exact as we initialized it. And
so to fix this, we simply just have to assign it
whatever is being returned right here. So name
of zero equal surname with the inputs and name
of one equal surname with the inputs and name have
to equal surname with the inputs come up here hit
the start button, bring the window over and you
can see that they have actually been assigned.
And just to walk you through what's going on
here. On these three right here we will assign
that name of zero element name of one element
name with two element will equal surname with
some inputs. And so we go into the function and
we pass in the inputs. temp, which is the actual
name at the moment and then surname is a name
that we want to add to the beginning of the name
and so we will assign the surname to the beginning
of the name and then we will print that out and
then we will return temp. And so because this
whole function right here, is returned with the
value whatever temp is which again is calculated
here, we will assign that return value to
name of element zero named value one and name of L
admit to. And now at last to bring it full circle.
Now that we have this flexible variable
independent function surname, we can
initialize our boss string here, which equals
Helen, and simply just reassign it by going boss
equals surname. And then we're going to
pass in boss here. And we can pass in Mrs.
And as simple as that. And just to prove it to
you, I'm going to get rid of these three lines,
make it a bit less confusing, hit the star button
and bring the window over. And as you can see,
we have Mr. Johnny, Mrs. Carla, Mr. Zack, and
at the very end, Mrs. Helen. Now that is how
you write good code. And so we're in Python,
we can make this change really easily as well,
we can simply just change this to say temp,
and then change this as well to say temp,
and then change this one to say temp. And
of course, we want to change our input to be
temp, oops, and then come down here.
And then we want to assign this to be
name of zero, and then this one to be named one.
And then this one to be named to. Of course,
and then we need to assign this here name of zero
equals surname with these inputs, and then name
of one equals surname with those inputs,
and then I'm lazy. So I'm gonna copy and
paste the last one change that to name a surname
equals the last of those inputs. And of course,
I'm getting an error here. It's saying that
assigned to a function which doesn't return,
I forgot to return here. So we're simply
just do return tip. And then of course,
we can't forget our boss, Helen. So we can
initialize that by saying boss equals surname.
And because we're initializing this, we simply
just pass in Helen. Like so. And then Mrs.
can come up here, hit the play button. And voila,
Mr. Johnny, Mrs. Carla, Mr. Zack and Mrs. Helen
functions are just absolutely incredible. I love
these things. We barely scratched the surface
with what's possible with functions here. But
hopefully, your creative juices are flowing in,
you're thinking of different ways on how
you might be able to apply a function.
I've said it before. And I'll go on record saying
that, again, functions are probably the most
powerful tool when it comes to programming.
In fact, if you're familiar at all, with all
the breakthrough research that's happening in
the field of machine learning, well, it's all
powered by functions. So I hope I was helpful
for getting you excited about some functions.
But that's everything you need to know to get
started with programming in regards to functions.
Now, commenting can be a make or break for
your coding success, especially if you're
working on a team on an open source project or on
a project, you plan to work on long term comments,
just as you expect our way to leave comments
within your code in a human readable format,
so that you know what's going on in different
parts of your code. At all times, sometimes
you'll write out extremely complicated code that
makes perfect sense in the moment. But when you
return to that code months later, or give it to
someone else, so they can add on to it, it may be
really difficult or a ton of wasted time trying to
reverse engineer the code. So let's take a look at
how to use commenting in two different languages.
Because I think it can be really helpful for you
to see how they compare and contrast. And plus,
you'll pretty much learn two languages at once. So
on the left is the language C sharp using the
ID Visual Studio, which should interest you if
you want to do windows development or make games
using a popular game engine called unity. And on
the right is the language Python three using the
ID Visual Studio code, which should interest you
if you want to get into more general programming
or data science. Alright, so here I have two brand
new console projects. And if you don't know how
to make a new console project, neither C sharp or
Python or both, be sure to check out the video in
the description. It's called How to install an ID.
And at the end of that video, I'll show you
how to do that. Alright, so the first thing
I want to go over is line commenting. So over
in C sharp and left, I'm just going to remove
these two lines that come stock with every new C
sharp project. And I'm going to start creating a
little fake project. So I'm going to initialize
a couple of floats. We'll call this location x
is going to do one 2.345 F and then we'll do
another one float location y and we'll do 123
point 456 All right. Oh f Sorry. Alright,
so these variables are just going to act as
fate coordinates for and lo example. So I'm gonna
create a more involved Boolean, I'm gonna say bull
in oops, in position, let's say in pause
equals, and let's do location x is greater than,
I don't know, let's just say 12. Right. And then
we'll also check if, if location, y is less than
30, for example. But then outside of that, we'll
also check, or if I'm about to go off screen here,
I'll scoot over, or if location, x is greater
than location, y, and then we'll put a semicolon.
And now we have a more involved bullying.
Alright, so here, we have maybe one of
the greatest examples of how line commenting is
pretty useful, or it can be pretty useful. Rather,
I'm going to go on top of our bullying here, and
I'm just going to do forward slash forward slash,
and that right there, it starts our comment,
and we can write whatever we want. So I'm
just going to do my best to explain what this
Boolean does. So if location, x is greater,
is greater than 12, and 12. And location why why
is is greater, no less than, less than 30. Or
if location x, x is greater than location, y, y,
then we are in position. Sorry, it's a bit long,
and it doesn't exactly fit with the rest of
the code. But that is how you write a line
comment. And the way it works is when your code is
compiled, anytime that the compiler sees a double
forward slash, it knows to ignore everything after
it. So just pretty much will go to the next line.
And over in Python, it's a lot
of the same, I'm just going to do
loke oops, loke x equals one 2.345. And look, y
equals one 2.412 3.456. And then I'm going to do
in pause equals, let's see loake x is greater than
12. And what is the loq? Why is less than 30? Hmm.
Or we have look loq already forgot x is
greater than x is greater than look Why?
Boy, that was brutal. And to add our comment,
I'm just gonna come over here above our in
position variable. And instead of doing forward
slash forward slash, that form of currency is
not accepted in Python, I'm going to hit the
pound sign or the hashtag, whatever you call it,
and then I was going to write out our message. So
I'm not going to write it because that's going to
take forever again, I'm going to copy it from here
and then paste it. And there we go. Comments, and
comment. Sorry, I just realized the Python font
should probably be a bit bigger. So I'm just gonna
make that a bit bigger. Yeah. So that's one use
case for line commenting probably one of the most
useful cases for line commenting, however, you
can do something else as well. So let's say that,
you know, we try out this Boolean and it just
isn't working right for for whatever reason,
well, we can do a line comment on everything
after the assignment operator, and then just put,
like, for example, equals one, just to make sure
that oops, we actually need to put my true here,
just to make sure that this Boolean is actually
working, just for example, and then in Python,
it's all the same, use the hash tag, everything
after that it's ignored, and you just put true
oops, true. Oops, no semi colon. And Yep, that's
another use case, that can be quite handy as well
when debugging your code. And so the final use
case I want to show you with line commenting is
let's say that we're going to return these back
to that assignment. And let's come down here.
And then let's add an if statement. So if
in position, right, we want something to
happen. However, we don't exactly know what
we want to happen yet. We have an idea maybe
maybe we don't know how to do it. Maybe you want
someone else to do it. Well, what we can do here
is just add a comment. on like, here, I want to
display something, you know, some notification,
I don't know, I just want to display something
here. And you can leave this comment here,
maybe come back to it later, maybe give it to a
friend, maybe do some research and then you know,
learn how to do it and then implement it. This
comment is just an easy way for you to, you know,
know what your intent was with putting
this if statement there. And in Python,
it's really similar, but a little different. So
let's say we do our if statement, if in position,
we'll come down here, we can write our comment,
which was, again, copy and paste, copy,
paste. However, we can't leave it like this, you
see, if we had saved, we will have a problem,
which is, we have a parsing error, a
syntax error, rather. And the reason is,
because if you do if you do an if statement,
and then you indent, which you have to do,
there's there's nothing when it runs as if
statement, it's not going to run anything.
And that's a syntax error in Python. So we can
just simply put, like print, you know, zero,
for instance, just so that it clears that syntax
error. And technically speaking, you don't even
have to do a print, for example, you can just do
like empty quotes, whoops, you can do like empty
quotes. And that will work just the same, but
it has to run something within the indentation.
Because again, this line is ignored. Alright, so
that was line commenting. Next, I want to talk
about block commenting. So to demonstrate, I'm
going to get rid of all this code that we just
did. And then oops, yeah. And then I'm going to,
let's just say that you're creating some like,
complex algorithm that you quite understand, but
you kind of don't understand. So I'm just gonna
create something, it was just a representation for
an advanced algorithm, just use your imagination.
Let's do loq y, divided by equals four, right? And
then we need to return it or something like that.
So we'll do local New equals loake y divided by
loquax. For example, oh, I have to initialize that
this is not Python floats. And then finally, let's
just return it. Let's do. Let's do this console.
Oops, console dot write line. Right? line,
location, new. All right. So let's just
say this is some advanced algorithm,
and you just implement it in your program.
But all of a sudden, like everything's broken,
nothing works anymore. You're like, what's going
on? This isn't behavior that I expect, I know that
this is working, right. This is obviously, you
know, very straightforward. But maybe this part
of the algorithm isn't working right. Now, you
could, you know, go by and do like, you know,
forward slash forward slash forward slash four
slash. And if you have a bunch of these do that
line by line. But one really convenient ways use
block coming, which in C sharp is just one forward
slash, and then an asterick. And the after ended
doing the opposite, so an Asterix and then one
forward slash, and that is one way that you can
quickly comment a whole block of code. Now one
really important thing to take note of a block
commenting is that you have to have a start, and
you have to have an end. Because if you don't have
an end, what happens here is that it comments out
everything after it including the brackets. And if
the brackets has a start, but doesn't have an end,
you're going to get a bunch of errors. So
they all I always have to have a start,
and they always have to have and now in
Python, I'm just going to replicate our super
advanced algorithm here, I'm going to do loake
x times equals two and then loake y divided by
equals four. And then we're going to do
loake nu equals loake y divided by loake. x,
then we'll just print it because why not look
new. And to add block commenting in Python,
it's similar, but also very different. And what
I mean by that is you want to come up to above
or if you want to do your block, comment and just
do three single quotes. And again, it needs a
start and he needs a finish. If you do not have
a finish, you are going to get a syntax error,
because it needs a start and a finish
for the triple quoted string literal,
aka the block comment. Now the very last type
of comment that I want to go over is summary
commenting. So to demonstrate, I'm just going
to get rid of All this code is no longer needed.
And then I'm just going to initialize a float
variables, call it loke equals zero, for example.
Next, let's create a quick little function, I'm
going to go outside of our main function and then
do static float. Let's call it ret, one. And then
let's, let's pass in a float, and then we'll call
our float a sum, make it easy. And then what we're
going to do is we're going to return a, let's see
a plus one. That's what we're going to return.
And then let's just use it real quick. So we'll do
loke equals rat one, and then we'll just pass
in itself. So it's going to plus one to itself.
And just to prove that we'll do console dot write
line, even though it's not about proving in this,
it's really about comments, but we'll
just do that anyway. Console dot read key.
And then I will hit the play button. And
boom, there we go. Zero plus one equals one.
So our function works. But let's say that you
know, it's later down the line in your project,
and you come back to the script to upgrade or
fix something, you see that Loki goes right one,
what does that do, and you go down to the
read one function. And let's say this is
a lot more complex, you don't really understand
what's going on. Well, you might waste a lot of
time reverse engineering to figure out what that
function is. But what SOT what can solve that is
by adding a summary comment. So adding summary
comments in C sharp is actually really easy.
All you have to do is go right above whatever
function that you want to add a summary to
or method and just hit backslash, backslash
backslash, it will autocomplete if you're in
Visual Studio, meaning just fill in whatever
your your summary is. So I'm going to do plus
one to the input. Now, if I go over the red
one, you'll see that now there's a little
description there. And it tells me exactly where
does it pluses, one, two, whatever the input is,
the input is Loke. So it's going to be
local plus one is what it's going to return.
Simple, easy, and to the point. And they also
have some other variables that you can fill in,
you can fill in like whatever the parameter A is,
you can put out what that is for you can put out
whatever returns, and in the right context, it
will display that information for you as well.
And over in Python, I'm just going to get rid of
everything and set up our scenario real quick. So
loke equals zero doing a do def read one, and then
we need our a input. And then let's see return,
whoops, return a plus one. And then we just
simply do loke equals what is the right one,
and then pass in Loke. And then we can print
low out, and then we don't need a input. And
just to prove that it works, I'm going to hit
play up here and you see that we have a one.
Now to add summary comments to Python methods and
functions, all you have to do is go right under
the method or function in Python, and then hit
three single quote characters, and then another
one. So you pretty much block comment. And then
you just type whatever the function is. I'm just
gonna pop copy this because I'm lazy. And then I'm
going to paste it here. And so now if we go over
here, it shows you what it does definition red
one, it pluses one to the user, I'm sorry, to the
input. And then we can add more if you want like
a equals, you know, float, for instance, just more
information for the user. And that's pretty much
all there is to it. And there you have it, guys,
that is pretty much everything you need to know to
get started with programming in terms of comedy.
Well, all right, congratulations, you fully made
it through the course. Now, how do you think
you did? If you really aren't sure, you should go
back to the your first program lesson section four
and retry it on a different tier. If
you're able to complete your first program
on his hardest difficulty, then you know, you
are officially ready to go out into the world
to find your own problems to solve and
code up your own ideas with your new
found skill. But before I let you go completely, I
just want to pump you with some inspiration on the
cool possibilities that you can take with this
skill from here with more practice of course,
but I just want you to think about everything
you do these days. Just think about the fact
that almost everything you interact with in this
new digital age is some way determined by code
online banking, offline banking, text messaging,
tweeting, watching this very YouTube video even
driving your smart car now or using your smart
toothbrush. Lock your home with your Smart Lock
or even using yourself Smart thermometer, the
list goes on and on and on. And of course,
From this day on that list is only going to
grow larger. Our world is becoming more and
more dependent on programs running the show,
which is a whole other conversation. But again,
congrats because you at least now have what
it takes to better understand and contribute
to that landscape. I wish you and your coding
adventures nothing with the best. And the last
thing I want to leave you with is this bit of
advice. You're guaranteed to do amazing things
with code so long as you follow this final
rule. Remember to always feed your curiosity.